i know called the shadow chancellor next
checker rachel reeves
thank you mr speaker we meet today when
inflation has hit its highest level for
40 years
every pound that people had last year
can only purchase 91 pence worth of
goods today
that's what inflation of 9
means
our country had a cost of living crisis
and a growth crisis
prices rising
growth downgraded and no plan for the
future
none of this though is inevitable
it is a consequence
of conservative decisions and the
direction that they have taken our
economy in over the last 12 years
this government is increasingly a
rudderless ship
heading to the rocks
while it is willing to watch people
financially drown in the process
where is the urgency where is the action
because the time to change course is now
we need an emergency budget
to deal with the inadequacy of the
chancellor's spring statement
with a windfall tax to help get bills
down and help families and pensioners
weather this storm
on the day that inflation has reached a
40-year high
the chancellor is missing in action
as energy bills and anxiety levels soar
the response from this government
diminishes in comparison
i'll happily give way to the honourable
i thank the honourable lady of giving
way will she accept when she asks for
where is the action that today
there is a hundred and fifty pounds
going into the bank account from
councils across this country
be if they're in council tax band a to d
the action that labour are proposing
is a win for tax to take up to 600
pounds of people's bills
energy bills as the honorable lady knows
went up by 54 an average of 693 pounds
150 pounds with all respect just doesn't
cut it
labour has proposed a windfall tax and
we first proposed it on the 9th of
january over 4 months ago
what was the first response from a
conservative minister to labour's policy
it was to insist that a windfall tax
would be unfair because shell and bp and
i quote
were struggling
north sea oil and gas producers and
making 32 million pounds a day in
unexpected profits
meanwhile there are parents going
without food so that their children
don't miss meals as they try to pay
their bills
madame deputy speaker that is struggling
and now we know
that for each and every day that the
conservatives delay bringing forward a
windfall tax families and pensioners are
forking out 53 million pounds in their
energy bills i'll happily give way thank
you for giving away and i do support
them our party supported the the uh
amendment last night but they shut the
minister in relation to to oil and gas
but nobility is right and just to
illustrate this
pension protection for our our
pensioners there's a real need for that
this morning one of my constituents told
me his brother sleeps in a sleeping bag
as a pensioner because that's how he
keeps warm another pensioner tells me
she can only turn on the heat in her
house for one hour per day and so when
it comes down to helping
our pensioners one way of doing that is
the very thing of the honourable lady is
referred to and that's to do the
one-fold tax on those people who are
making exorbitant profits
wilson
i thank the honourable man for speaking
for speaking so powerfully about his
constituent and a pensioner after years
of working contribution to this country
sleeping in a sleeping bag to keep warm
this government got rid of the triple
lock
and now they are refusing to implement a
windfall tax
and every day the case for labor's
windfall tax gets stronger while the
tory defense we're refusing to act gets
weaker and weaker
yet last night
every single conservative mp voted
against a winful tax for the third time
people can no longer afford to pay for
the government's mistakes the government
should put the national interest first
and follow labour's advice it is time to
do the right thing it is time to put the
needs of people first it is time to
introduce a windfall tax to get bills
down
i'll give way to the honor very grateful
to have for giving away i just wonder if
she could clarify one thing for me
there's a bit of a dispute about how
much a windfall tax raises per household
there's about 25 million households in
the uk could she just confirm how much
money per household a windfall tax
actually raises
well a windfall tax would raise around
three billion pounds and combined with
the
extra receipts that the government are
receiving in vat because prices have
gone up so much that money could all go
directly into taking money off people's
bills it would make a real impact now
every single day these energy companies
are making 32 million pounds in
unexpected profits this government
increases taxes on working people a
labor government will be increasing
taxes on the big oil and gas companies
the cost of living crisis
is being made worse by a wage crisis
as years of conservative governments
have failed to stand up for working
people at the conservative party
conference last year
the prime minister bragged of plans for
a high-wage economy
so how is that going
well let me update the house
in the six months since then
average real terms pay has not risen
it has fallen
and if you look behind the headline
figures
data released by the institute of fiscal
studies yesterday shows that not only
are workers experience a fall in their
real pay
but the gap between those earning the
most
and those earning the least is widening
too
these are the hospital porters
the supermarket assistance the delivery
drivers
the very people who worked tirelessly
through the pandemic to keep this
country going and their wages are no way
keeping up with the rising cost of
living
i'll give way to the honourable
gentleman i thank the the honourable
member for giving way i just wanted to
have clarification on the figures
because they are very very important i
mean she said that a wimple tax would
raise three billion pounds and amongst
the 25 billion million households that's
just over 100 pounds each which is
actually less than the government's
giving but then she said
she said that it would be 600 pounds per
household and that that would cost about
18 billion pounds which is 15 billion
pounds more than the windfall taxes
raised so where would that extra 15
billion come from is that an increase in
government borrowing
our scheme is very clear we would
introduce a win full tax we would use
that money to reduce v80 on gas and
electricity bills from five percent to
zero and expand the warm homes discount
from the measly 140 pounds that people
get today to 400 pounds and we would
fund that
through the windfall tax through the
additional v80 receipts that the
government are getting in at the moment
because that prices are so high and
through the additional corporation tax
receipts that the oil gas companies are
paying now the government are going to
end up doing this the question is only
when they will get on and deliver for
their constituents at the moment you've
got oil and gas companies making record
profits and people paying record bills
this is a question of whose side you are
on
the government are very clear they're on
the side of the oil and gas companies on
this side we are very clear we are on
the side of ordinary families and
pensioners
and even now
this government has failed to bring
forward
not just the whimple tax but the
employment bill that has been repeatedly
promised
and there is a real world price to this
as well
allowing the scandalous threats of fire
and rehire to continue to drive
conditions at work down
it's not just in the appalling case of
piano but in other sectors too
it should have been outlawed
but thanks to this government's action
it is being encouraged
employment rights for the modern world
of work will not just protect workers
but boost growth and financial security
that makes for a stronger economy
with firm foundations rather than
allowing a race to the bottom which
takes away dignity as well as eroding
family finances i'll give way to my
honourable friend
uh
my friend for giving way uh many of my
constituents as well as uh struggling
with rising fuel uh bills and food
prices are worried about the precarious
work that they're in not knowing what
hours they'll get from one week to the
next and worried that they'll be fired
by unscrupulous employers does she agree
with me that the queen's speech is a
missed opportunity to introduce the
long-awaited employment bill so that
workers get the dignity and security
that they desperately need
and the sad truth is that the government
used to agree with you because it was in
their manifesto to introduce an
employment bill in fact they've been
promising it for five or six years now
so let's have that employment bill to
protect people at work so that working
people don't have to resort to going to
food banks that they have that security
and dignity that work should provide
april's imf data show that families in
britain are more exposed to the cost of
living crisis compared to countries such
as germany france and the u.s because of
depleted savings
savings are declining and household debt
is on the rise
not because millions of people can no
longer manage a budget
but because millions of people cannot
afford a conservative government
working families are increasingly
struggling with their budgets
because the chancellor has failed to act
in his budgets
the food foundation believe that since
january
2 million people have not eaten food for
at least a whole day because they cannot
afford to i'll give way to the
honourable gentleman
yeah she i know she knows that the
number of people in food banks in 2010
or something like 26 000 it's now 2.6
million 100 times that but would you
agree with me that if you contrast the
growth of the economy by 40 percent in
the 10 years 2008 under labour
with the dismal growth now the ifs has
said if we were on the same trend growth
the average person would be 11 000
better off and therefore able to weather
the storms where we're suffering and the
reason they're suffering is because of
the tory government
the honourable gentleman is absolutely
right and that is the tory growth
penalty that because of a lack of growth
in the economy
average earnings are 11 000 pounds less
than growth had if growth had a state at
the rate that it was under the last
labour government and the honourable
gentleman also points to a hundred fold
increase in food bank use
this is not normal
it is the consequence of conservative
governments choices
meanwhile what have we seen in recent
weeks suggestions from government
ministers
that people can take um in their
suggestions from government ministers or
what people can do in their own lives to
deal with the cost of living crisis the
prime minister thinks that a 77 year old
pensioner who rides on the bus all day
to keep warm should be grateful
for their discounted fares
the environment secretary has lectured
people struggling with the costs of food
to buy own brand
and the
minister for levelling up has treated
the need for an emergency budget as if
it was an audition for a comedy club
another out of touch minister just this
week has told people that if they are
financially struggling they should
simply work more hours or get another
job
as if it is as easy as that
the chancellor continuing to insult the
public's intelligence by denying that a
compulsory 200 pounds loan
is somehow not alone and now blame your
computer system for his decision not to
help the lease well off mr madame deputy
speaker what planet are they on i'll
give way to honourable lady who's been
trying
i thank my right honourable friend for
giving way does she agree that given
that wages have been falling for the
last 14 years and inflation is now at 9
or 11 for the poorest families that
there is an alternative to people's
wages being squeezed that this
government could instead squeeze profits
shell and bp
raked in over 12 billion in the first
three months of this year alone and it's
shameful that every member opposite
voted against a windfall tax yesterday
when they had the chance
voted against the windfall tax not for
the first time not for the second time
but the third time every single
conservative mp opposing what they know
is the right thing to do a win for tax a
labour government would tackle the cost
of living crisis head on a windfall tax
on oil gas producer profits to cut
household bills by up to 600 pounds a
home insulation policy that will save
millions of households up to 400 pounds
a year a discount on business rates for
high street firms funded by attacks on
the online giants
and maybe the chief secretary can tell
us in his speech
why they won't abolish the unfair
outdated and unjustifiable non-dom tax
status and use that money to keep taxes
for working people down
and finally madam deputy speaker labour
would put a stop to the chancellor's
fraud failures that allowed 11.8 billion
pounds of taxpayers funds to go to
criminal gangs drug dealers and worse we
would claw back every penny of taxpayers
money that we can because the public are
sick of being ripped off they want their
money back
madam deputy speaker
we're now in the worst of all possible
worlds with inflation high and rising
and growth low
and falling
in other words stagflation
this conservative government must
address the underlying weaknesses in our
economy which are the result of years of
tory failure
growth has stagnated not just this year
but over the last 12 years
falling from two percent on average
under the last labor government to just
1.5 a year in the decade leading up to
the pandemic
the conservatives have failed to work
with british industries employers and
trade unions to create the economic
growth that would benefit everyone
and for 12 years
this approach has sown chaos and
uncertainty making it impossible for
businesses to invest with confidence
and now the uk economy has the worst
growth projections of any g20 economy
but one
russia
the bank of england have issued a stark
warning of a downturn next year with gdp
projected to fall
and it's not set to get much better
after that
in 2024 expected growth that the the
minister says from a sedentary position
it is set to get better oh yes expected
growth the year after is expected to be
0.25
well done tory government almost 10
times lower than what the obr predicted
just in march
we've heard nothing from this
conservative government to change that
and if he's proud of that record good
luck to him no plan to provide the
catalytic investment we need to create
new markets no plan to get trade moving
again and tackle the supply chain
problems facing business no plan for a
new industrial strategy to make the most
of britain's potential bringing good
jobs to all parts of britain the
conservatives have become the low growth
party and our country is paying the
price
i'll give way to the honourable general
thank my right honourable friend for
greenway and she's making really
powerful points about uh the the falling
growth and it should be as concerned as
i am i'm sure about the statistics which
show the decline in business investment
which i think is down nine percent where
we're seeing
a 34 fall in automotive production
massive uh hit to the uk economy uh the
the impact on our foreign competitors is
less so
they
those countries have a strategy does she
agree with me that this government seems
to fail to have an industrial strategy
for example gaining semiconductor
production in this country and that is
what is needed and what the labor
government would do
i think the honourable gentleman but for
that intervention if you look at the imf
numbers it shows that investment as a
proportion of our economy in the uk is
18 if you take into account public and
private investment in other similar
economies that the imf look at is 23
now if you add that up over the next six
years the imf's uh
projection forecast horizon that's one
trillion pounds less in investment in
the uk
compared to what you're getting in other
countries huge missed opportunities
create those jobs of the future in those
industries of the future that my
honourable friend wants to see in
warrick and levington and that all of us
want to see in our constituencies now
the government's lack of action is felt
by businesses
in april the price of materials for uk
manufacturers increased at its fastest
rate since records began with prices up
by nearly a fifth on the previous year
adam deputy speaker when i speak to
businesses they are worried about
falling consumer confidence and a lack
of spending power as well as the costs
that they are having to face
the british retail consortium explained
that the rising cost of living has
crushed consumer confidence and put the
brakes on consumer spending
so many businesses who worked tirelessly
to adapt and survive the pandemic were
banking on this year to recover
and it's just not happening
we could be so much better
our geography our universities our
industrial heritage
offers so much potential
but the government doesn't do enough to
unlock it
i have seen the brilliant businesses and
emerging industries that will power our
economy and lead the world
businesses like nanopore a technology
and life sciences firm that was started
as a research team in oxford university
and now employs more than 600 people
like rolls royce in derby where i was a
couple of weeks ago which is leading
pioneering research with world leading
engineers developing carbon neutral
technologies
or like castle to mills in my own city
of leeds
once a key part of west yorkshire's
textile industry but now a creative
collaborative space housing freelancers
remote workers and startup businesses
but the success i see all around the
country
could be strengthened with strong
leadership and vision from government
ministers are more concerned
about the next headline or photo shoot
than creating credible plans for growth
and success
madam deputy speaker on the day that
inflation spirals out of control
where is the 3.4 million pound pr budget
in the treasury and what are they doing
today
i will give way to the onboard gentleman
i'll sit here again next time um
the she mentions earlier the 200 pound
support for households in the right of
their energy bills and that also that
got to 100 of households um the 150
pounds council tax deduction
got to 80 of households well she set out
what percentage of households would
receive the 600 pounds per household
that she set out what percentage
it's great to see our honorable members
opposite taking so much interest and it
does suggest to me that a policy from
them on the windfall taxes coming soon
it will be welcome we've said that the
600 pounds would go to a third of
households so we would expand from 140
to 400 pounds and it would go to a third
of households and the honourable member
like me is an mp in yorkshire and across
yorkshire every day
an extra 4.5 million pounds is spent on
energy costs as a result of the party
opposites failure a total of 220 million
pounds in the seven weeks since the
energy price cap went up so constituents
in thursday and water like my
constituents in leeds west are looking
for answers and an expansion of the warm
homes discount paid for by windfall tax
would make a massive difference right
across our region in yorkshire
now we need an ambitious plan from the
government for the future that's why
labour will scrap business rates and the
system that replaces it will incentivize
investments promote entrepreneurship and
bring life back to our high streets
now the race is on for the next
generation of jobs
labor will make the investment we need
with a growth plan to bring
opportunities to the whole country
working in partnership with great
british industries to get us to net zero
and revitalize coastal communities and
former industrialized towns
we don't want to be importing all the
technologies and products we need if we
can make it here in britain we should
that is why labour government will buy
make and sell more here at home
and we will make brexit work with a
bespoke uk eu veterinary agreement to
cut red tape for food and agricultural
industries
mutual recognition of professional
qualifications to help our fantastic
business services industries and making
it easier for our creative industries to
tour and perform
unlike the conservatives labour will
ensure that our economy grows and that
prosperity is shared
i'll give way one final time very
grateful for giving away on the matter
of making brexit work there is concern
that the united kingdom now mirrors the
united states with a labour shortage
rather than mirroring the common and the
the right to work across the european
union and it's having a drastic effect
on the whole of the united kingdom of
great britain and northern ireland can
they maybe see a wee bit more about how
they want to emulate rather immigrant
united states market situation labor
much fortunate rather than europe
the best way to fill those gaps in the
labor market is to be training people up
here in britain and we see it with the
nurses shortage that was in the papers
today that we are having to bring in
nurses from all around the world because
i'm not training up nurses here there
are job vacancies here in britain and we
need to be ensuring that our young
people get those opportunities to train
for the high paid and high skilled jobs
here in britain
madame well he says no one disputes it
why aren't they doing it
madam deputy speaker the tories are out
of touch and they're out of ideas
they're the party of high taxes because
they are the party of low growth their
choices have made the cost of living
crisis much worse than they needed to be
their decisions have left those with the
least fearing for the future
the tories cannot be trusted with public
money and have had in billions to their
friends their donors and the fraudsters
we need an emergency budget with a
winful tax to keep energy bills down
we need a government that takes growth
seriously
we need a new vision for a fairer and
more prosperous economy
labor has a different economic approach
pro-worker pro-business with a plan to
unleash the potential of both a labour
government would steer our country
through these difficult times together
i urge honorable and right honourable
members across the house to do the right
thing today and to vote for an emergency
budget to get our country and our
economy back on track
[Applause]
the original
question was that a humble address be
presented to her majesty as on the order
paper since when an amendment w has been
proposed as on the order paper the
question is that the amendment be made
i call the chief secretary to the
treasury sam club
yeah
thank you madam dr speaker and it's a
pleasure a privilege to respond to this
debate on behalf of the government i
have to say i thought that was an
uncharacteristically uh poor speech by
the shadow chancellor one which one
which i'm afraid to say failed to rise
to the the magnitude of the of the moon
the reality is
in in the shadow of the pandemic and war
in our continent
everybody understands that these are
challenging times and the people are
anxious about the future
the measure of a government of any color
is the determination imagination with
which we respond to the challenge of the
day
we responded quickly and comprehensively
to the greatest challenge of our
generation at the outset of the pandemic
and looking forward we are helping to
create the conditions for economic
growth by investing in skills by helping
businesses themselves to grow and by
building the infrastructure that
provides the backbone of every economy
around the world
the crucial thing and the reason today's
debate is so important is that we focus
on that growth and this queen's speech
does just that
let me begin by note that overall our
economy has proved very resilient last
year the uk was the fastest growing
economy in the g7 growth
growth in the first quarter
if if honourable members opposite listen
they might learn something growth in the
first quarter was stronger than in the
than in the us germany and italy and
pushed out put 0.7
above its pre-pandemic level at the end
of 2019 the imf its part forecast the uk
will be the second fastest growing g7
economy this year and then after other
economies have caught back up as they
rebound more slowly from the pandemic we
will have the fastest growth in 2025 and
2026.
but i i i'll give way in a moment far
from the dire forecast about
unemployment from 2020 being realized
instead we see unemployment has fallen
back to just 3.7
below pre-pandemic levels and the lowest
since 1974
that 12 million jobs and incomes were
protected during a pandemic the
unemployment is now lower than before
the pandemic that we were the fastest
growing economy in the g7 last year is
all thanks to the careful economic
stewardship of my writing friend the
chancellor and this conservative
government i'll give way to a gentleman
i thank the minister for forgiving way
um given that inflation is now at nine
percent i think it's a 40-year high does
the minister and his benches regret
abandoning the triple lock and putting
so many pensioners into poverty
as i'll allude during the course of my
remarks we have to be very careful that
in setting our tax and welfare policies
that we do not worsen the very problems
that we are trying to manage and this is
a really important dynamic which we have
to hold imbalance as we seek to set fair
uh offers on on all of these subjects
madam doctor speaker it's still little
more than two years since the onset of
the pandemic and as the prime minister
told this house last week its impact has
been enormous with the largest recession
on record requiring a government
response amounting to nearly 400 billion
pounds
the government as this house well knows
moved heaven and earth to support our
economy doing things only weeks earlier
no one could ever have expected us to
even need to do and those efforts worked
now human nature being human nature it
is easy to take it for granted when
disaster is avoided but there was
nothing inevitable about this and this
house and this country oh my right and
we'll find the chancellor are thanks for
steering us through this situation in
such strong condition
the challenges we face now i'll give
away momentarily the challenges we face
now are global in both origin and impact
we're seeing inflation as a consequence
of the unsteady and tentative unlocking
of the global economy post-pandemic and
we'll need only look at a situation in a
city such as shanghai to see just how
disrupted global supply chains currently
are and this is particularly
concentrated clearly on fields like
energy and food i'll give way to under a
gentleman i i thank the minister for
giving way and i've i'm glad that he's
saying that the chancellor and ministers
are moving heaven and earth to help the
good british people but would he not
agree with me that had certain
individuals not moved heaven and earth
to give out billions of pounds of crony
covered contracts to companies which
ended up having tory donors as friends
who can forget madame deputy speaker for
example that 11 ppe contracts were
dished out to a pest control company 252
million pounds which ended up going not
to a ppe specialist but to a company
specializing in offshore trading and
foreign currency trading that had those
individuals not moved heaven and earth
for those particular companies then the
good british hardworking people would
not be in such a predicament now
well i think it's very important to set
out a number of a number of facts about
this situation because this is subject
to repeated misrepresentation 97 of all
ppe that was purchased by the government
was fit for use that's the first thing
to say the second thing to say is we
obviously had to proceed at enormous
speed giving these injured seasons of
the pandemic situation to procure that
pp and of course the bench is opposite
we're leading the charge on that and to
the honourable gentleman's point about
some of the resources that were being
advocated i would remind chancellor
herself was recommended that we sought
ppe from a historical clothing
reenactment company as part of the
proposed solution so i i i think the the
the the point i would make here is that
there was there was a desperate
situation we responded to the pace where
there has been fraud against six jacka i
am as clear as any minister in this
house and indeed as every member of this
house will be that we should pursue it
and we are funding a dedicated taxpayer
protection task force from hmrc with 100
million to do exactly that
i will give way one more time then i
should make some progress i'm very
grateful i understand that lots of
countries in the world have been through
many similar problems and there is a
cost of living crisis in lots of
different countries but can you explain
to me why the british government is
being so miserly when a country like
greece
which has a similar set of issues and
has been through much more difficult
economic times in the last 12 years is
managing to meet 80 percent of the
additional costs of fuel bills this year
for the poorest households
well one has to uh set into context
obviously that the action that every
government takes against this particular
situation and a particular
economic options that have opened to
them including obviously the impact on
on taxes which is something which we're
acutely aware of but
this this government has consistently
shown that we'll rise to the challenge
and anybody anybody who says that 22
billion pounds is misery is simply
misreading the reality of economics in a
way which i i think speaks volumes as to
the labor party's wider approach to
trying to budget responsibly and manage
our public finances in a way which
protect what protects protects those it
protects the most vulnerable in society
and the services on which they rely
uh madame speaker
as we return to the situation as it
stands today the bank of england has
said they expect inflation to peak at
just over 10 percent in the fourth
quarter this year before returning to
target over the course of the year ahead
the reality is that high global energy
prices and supply chain pressures are
pushing up prices in economies right
across the world including the united
kingdom and this has been worsened very
significantly by russia's invasion of
ukraine which has injected so much
uncertainty into the economic outlook
we're monitoring the data very closely
there is no question i do not dispute it
that these challenges are a setback to
our recovery and they're having a
significant impact on the cost of living
the subject of yesterday's debate led by
the chancellor however last year's
strong rebounding growth has put us in a
good underlying economic position with
half a million more people on the
payroll now than before the pandemic
began and gdp above pre-pandemic levels
i'm going to make some further progress
then i'll give way again as we heard
yesterday the chancellor understands the
effect that inflation is having on
households and is providing support
worth 22 billion this year to ease those
pressures he will keep all of those
issues under coast review and we will
bring forward a program of measures at
such time that they will make the right
difference in a targeted way but we must
be very careful not to fuel the very
challenges that we are working to
overcome being that inflation itself
or the size of our public debt we will
be spending 83 billion pounds on debt
interest this year
we must and we will manage the public
finances responsibly because we must not
saddle future generations with our debt
and because i will momentarily and
because we want to see the burden of
personal taxation reduced
could you just confirm the nature of the
figure of 83 billion of the tax charge
that he's just referred to
is that in fact a cash demand on the
government or is in fact quite a
substantial part of that
rolled up so that we don't need to pay
it it's merely attached to the infinite
index index index linked bonds
well so some of this does indeed forge
you as cash payments and some of it is
rolled over but the the reality is that
we we absolutely need to note that when
you are running an 83 billion pound
interest payment on an annualized basis
you are not in a position to maintain
market confidence unless you set out a
sustainable trajectory to address that
and a sustainable solution cannot be to
borrow our way out of the situation it
must be to grow our economy and to
create high-skilled high-wage jobs and
we have a comprehensive plan to do so
that is the choice we've made as a
government and it is absolutely the
right drill i will give way yes i will
give away
i'm very very grateful because you
mentioned a moment ago that there's 500
000 more people in payroll but he
neglected to say that that doesn't
increa include self-employed people and
would he confirm that according to the
office for national statistics there are
in fact 444 000 fewer people in work
than before the pandemic not as he
implied half a million more hmm
there are half a million people more on
payroll i was very i was very clear
about that and the headline unemployment
rate is 3.7
and we and we should celebrate that that
is a genuine public policy success it is
something which we contrast very starkly
with the situation we inherited in 2010
when we took over in government and it's
something which i certainly have
determined that we should continue to
support by making sure that our economic
policy is the right one moving forward
because the party opposite has only one
answer to every problem to spend more
they have made by our calculations 418
billion pounds worth of spending
commitments while setting out precisely
how eight billion would be funded
the scale of the spending the party
opposite would undertake is vast but
what concerns me and should concern all
of us is the lack of seriousness with
which they consider how to fund their
commitments this is the luxury of being
in opposition while in government there
is no ducking away from the big
challenges that we grapple with
imagine speaker achieving economic
growth is not as simple as putting one's
foot down on the accelerator of a car it
is a fast subtler a more balanced
enterprise i will momentarily including
multiple carefully weighed decisions
designed to mutually reinforce each
other over time will the minister agree
that the engine of growth in our economy
is the private sector it's businesses
getting up and doing working hard and
developing the growth and the jobs and
the prosperities countries we can't rely
on the state to do everything private
business must be supported
well my friend is exactly right he's
always a fantastic advocate for example
for the car industry uh in his part of
the of the midlands and this is this is
absolutely the case that we need to make
sure that we have the engines of growth
able to fire and our plan for growth
published last year sets out how we
would increase investment in the three
pillars of that growth infrastructure
skills and innovation i'll give way
to minister giving way in terms of
business opportunities specifically for
small and medium-sized business the
national institute of economic and
social research uh basically is pouring
cold water on his government's bunker
and the benefits of brexit in the
economy so wonderfully disagree or
disagrees when it comes to small and
medium-sized businesses who need people
in the country now not trained ten years
down the line that links with the eu
through trade and the potential labor
market mobility have benefited northern
ireland as he agree or disagree
i'm very clear that we were right to
implement the majority decision of the
people of this country to leave the
european union of course i'm very
pleased speaking
speaking to his point on small and
medium-sized businesses the procurement
bill which i'll be speaking to later in
my remarks it's precisely designed to
make sure that small and medium-sized
businesses can access the benefits of
public procurement in a way which will
work to their considerable benefit
now madam speaker we have made excellent
progress against our plan for growth
with a landmark capital uplifting a
spending review that i chaired last
autumn the creation of a uk
infrastructure bank being led by my
friend the economic secretary more
funding for apprenticeships and skills
training a big injection of public
investment into r d and the launch of uk
wide help to grow schemes
i want to see us go further looking at
innovative supply-side solutions to
problems in particular delivering the
homes that people need ensuring that
people have access to the services they
need and carefully managing a risk of an
inflationary spiral
this is all about as well my friend for
rugby just alluded creating the the
conditions for public sector growth in
his may's lecture earlier this year the
chancellor set out his plans to create
the conditions for that growth by
supporting a culture of enterprise
through a focus on capital people and
ideas and the government has already
taken steps to encourage business
investment such as the super deduction
on expenditure incurred since the first
of april last year and until the end of
march next year companies have the right
to claim 130
capital allowances on qualifying plant
and machinery investments allowing them
to cut their tax bill by up to 25 p for
every pound they invest making our
capital allowances regime one of the
most competitive anywhere in the world
the power of our private sector has also
been shown in our tech industry where
there was more than 27 billion pounds of
investment in 2021 the uk sits alongside
the united states and china as one of
only three countries in the world who
produced over 100 tech unicorns and the
uk boasts a thriving startup scene with
a new tech business launching every half
an hour throughout the course of 2020.
i'll give away i'm very grateful and i
declare my interest on this point um he
talks about investment in private sector
businesses equity investment is vital
eis and seis is absolutely fundamental
to private sector investment in
businesses that those schemes are due to
expiry in 2025 would he announce at this
spatchbox today that those schemes will
be extended
now
my honourable friend really tempts me
here but
in all seriousness this is something we
are acutely aware of indeed i had
meetings on on this issue this week
alone and my only friend the economic
secretary is looking at this issue very
very closely clearly we want to make
sure that we have the right investment
climate to support uh the kind of
activity to which he eludes
madame speaker as the prime minister
told the house last week we need the
legislative firepower to fix the
underlying problems in our energy supply
in housing in infrastructure and in
skills which are driving out costs for
families across the country the queen's
speech will help us to grow the economy
which is a sustainable way to deal with
our cost of living challenges and ensure
we deliver on the people's priorities
the bills outlined will do so in many
different ways
every corner of the country can
contribute to and enjoy economic growth
that's why we've created the uk
infrastructure bank whose establishment
uh the uk infrastructure bank bill will
complete and which will be explicitly
tasked with supporting regional and
local economic growth and helping to
tackle climate change as it goes with 22
billion pounds of capacity the bank will
be able to support infrastructure
investment and level up the whole of the
united kingdom in turn boosting private
sector confidence and unlocking a
further 18 billion pounds of private
investment the energy security bill
meanwhile will build on the success of
the cop 26 summit in glasgow reduce our
exposure to volatile global gas markets
and deliver a managed transition to
cheaper cleaner and more secure energy
all while we continue to help with
energy costs right now through a nine
billion package an increase to warm
homes discount and the one billion pound
household support fund
i've already alluded to the importance
of skills we've achieved plenty on this
already but we are far from done
everyone everywhere should be encouraged
to fulfill their potential the higher
education bill will help to ensure our
post-education post-18 education system
promotes real social mobility putting
students onto pathways on which they can
excel it will give them the skills that
they need to meet their aspirations in
turn helping to grow the economy
meanwhile a bonanza of brexit bills led
by my right on refund the the minister
for brexit opportunities mean we will
continue to seize the benefits of our
departure from the european union and
create a regulatory environment that
encourages prosperity business
innovation and entrepreneurship
regulations on businesses will be
repealed and reformed and it will be
made easier to amend law inherited from
the european union
the procurement bill as i alluded to
earlier will make public procurement
simpler providing opportunities to small
businesses which for too long have been
out of their reach new procedures will
improve transparency and accountability
and allow new suppliers
to market to bid for future contracts
another benefit to brexit is the freedom
with which we can now negotiate entirely
new trade arrangements with partners
around the world
the trade australia new zealand bill
will enable the implementation of the
united kingdom's first new free trade
agreement since leaving european union
spurring economic growth through our
trading relationships creating and
securing jobs across this country and
well-made opposition front bench members
snipe having spent years trying to
prevent our exit from the european union
this side of the house knows we have
honored our contract with the british
people that is why ultimately we are in
government to deliver on those
opportunities and they are in
opposition of having a growing up
economy is of course about investors
knowing that we're one of the safest and
most reliable places in the world to do
business the economic crime and
corporate transparency bill will send
that message out loud and clear
cracking down on illicit finance it
costs the economy and the taxpayer an
estimated 8.4 billion pounds a year and
strengthening our reputation as a place
where legitimate businesses can create
and grow jobs
the final bill to which el drago has the
attention today is the financial
services and markets bill yeah the uk
now has a unique opportunity to assess
whether it wants to do things
differently to ensure the financial
services sector has the right rules and
regulations for uk markets
and to further enhance the system which
is already the envy of the world the
chancellor and the economic secretary
have been outspoken in expressing an
ambitious vision for a sector which can
contribute so much to this country more
open more innovative and more
competitive the financial services and
markets bill represents further progress
towards making that vision a reality
establishing a coherent agile and
internationally respected approach to
financial services regulation that is
specifically designed for the uk
removing red tape promoting investment
and giving our financial services
regulators new objectives to ensure a
greater focus on growth and
international competitiveness
madam dr speaker this is a full and
ambitious agenda supporting and
encouraging economic growth in many
mutually reinforcing ways across the
entire country we continue to keep the
wider situation under review including
obviously the impact of russia's illegal
invasion of ukraine but crucially our
focus is on the best solution of all a
growing economy supporting high-wage
high-skilled jobs the prime minister
told the house last week our ambition is
to build the foundation for decades of
prosperity uniting and leveling up
across the country
that is what the public rightly expect
and this is where our collective efforts
will be focused in this parliamentary
session
order before i call the next speaker
just a a reminder that it is very
important that
those wishing to speak in the debate um
do get here for the
opening
contributions from the front bench that
they also make sure they get back in
very good time for the
closing speeches it is essential and
courteous to be there and also
to stay in the chamber for
most of the um debate
um because it's important to hear what
other people have to
say
um after i call the snp spokesman i'll
be going to the backbenchers and i don't
want to put a time limit on but i would
advise that about
seven minutes would be um very helpful
to make sure that everybody gets an
equal contribution
sncsp spokesperson alison brulis
thank you very much madam deputy speaker
i'm admitting speaker today is national
numerous cd and there's going to be a
lot of figures flying about this
afternoon and it often makes me think
that it would be helpful in this place
if we were allowed to do as they do in
the us senate and have great big charts
we can point to to make these debates
easier for people to follow but the bank
of england's predictions on gdp growth
thankfully
for the government are quite easy to
illustrate they're pretty much a flat
line the cost of living crisis and
brexit continue to hold back growth and
opportunities for a more sustainable
inclusive growth conscious of our
climate obligations presented at the cop
26 summit and my glasgow central
constituency last year are being
squandered it's not so much a union
dividend it is a stagnant economy and it
doesn't have to be this way
madam deputy speaker we need to
recognize that the endless pursuit of
gdp growth at any cost
destroys communities and the planets and
growth should be inclusive and it should
prioritize policies which tackle
inequalities contribute to net zero and
provide high quality jobs
investing in green technologies and
insulating and retrofitting homes and
improving public transport would all be
a good start but there are really no
bills within the queen's speech which
get close to that ambition
in scotland the snp well-being at the
heart of our economic strategy and it's
through well-being and fair work that we
can deliver higher rates of employment
and wage growth reduce poverty and
improve outcomes for disadvantaged
families and communities
i was proud to serve on the s and the
scottish government's social justice and
fairness commission which prior to the
pandemic set out some of this direction
of travel
and last week the scottish government
announced the establishment of a new
centre of expertise in equality and
human rights and it will see the
scottish government working with leading
experts to address economic inequality
built in the principle that a fairer
economy is a stronger economy
post pandemic madam deputy speaker
there's a clear choice presented to us
over whether to lead or to lag behind
other successful and more equal
economies while we recover from covent
delivered net zero tackle the structural
inequalities
and and grow the economy and the uk tory
government have chosen to ignore the
problems and to lag
the uk economy is now forecast to be the
worst performing g7 economy next year
and this week we had more of the
chancellor's sleight of hand on twitter
and using a scale on a graph that makes
less than one percent in gdp growth look
good well less than one percent in gdp
growth isn't that good and the
government should stop pretending that
it is and it's in no small part a
consequence of their policy choices
madam deputy speaker there has been no
clear economic strategy from the uk tory
government and yet the policy choice
that looms over all things from the
northern ireland protocol disputes to
manufacturing and to labor supply is
brexit
there is no doubt madam deputy speaker
that global forces are posing huge
challenges now but these have merely
been compounded by brexit the daftest of
all economic choices
by december 2021 leaving the single
market and customs union had reduced uk
goods trade by 14.9 percent analysis
from the centre for european reform
shows that uk exports have taken a
larger hit than imports
pushing through that brexit cliff edge
in the middle of a pandemic masking the
economic damage regardless of the
economic cost as an act of great
economic self-sabotage i will give way
to him in a second gdp growth in the uk
is only about half of the eu average
since the brexit referendum i'll
certainly give weight him if he thinks
that if you can explain
why there is a benefit of brexit when we
see only economic harm
just mr imaginative speaker asked her to
collect correct the record if she looks
at the office for national statistics
website she will see that the opposite
is the case that actually uk imports
have fallen from the european union but
uk exports to the european union
actually have recovered uh it's not
clear why that is the case but that is
what the office of national statistics
says and i hope she'll go and read that
website and correct the record
it goes to my point i suppose you can
you can make all kinds of
statistics show all kinds of things but
what we hear from food producers in
scotland is that it is very very
difficult for producers in scotland to
get their high quality exports to the
european markets
and that is a direct choice of brexit
we've also seen um easier for eu goods
to get into the country and more
difficult for uk goods to get out all
kinds of difficulties that these mad
policies have caused
madame deputy speaker we face weak
growth in 2023 compared not just to the
g7 but also most of the world as well as
by far the highest inflation rate
compared to the eurozone figures today
putting the inflation rate at nine
percent
are shocking and it's only
me and some of this has come via the
government's choice to increase vat back
to 20 that was a choice and a lot of
that has come through
in the inflation rate today given the
ramp in energy costs more price rises
are yet to come for certain
adam posen the president of the peterson
institute for international economics
told the treasury select committee last
week in his view a substantial majority
of the inflation differential for the uk
over the euro area is due to brexit a
choice by this government that is making
things harder for people in these
islands an act of self-harm supported by
of course the tory ideologues but
supported also now by the labour front
bench who want to make brexit work
apparently against all good reasonable
good evidence and against the 62 percent
of people in scotland who voted to
remain in the eu and when i asked
ministers earlier on in the week about
the benefits of brexit they pointed to
free ports and tea side not huge
benefits to my constituency
don't want to labor the point but when
it comes to the freedom of movement if
they want to make brexit work maybe the
easiest way is to make the northern
ireland protocol cover the whole of the
united kingdom of great britain and
northern
ireland makes an interesting suggestion
because of course
northern ireland has benefited from this
eventually
speaker investment in our communities
has also taken a direct hit from the
loss of european structural funds the uk
government's shared prosperity fund will
see scotland allocated 32 million pounds
in 2022 55 and 23 125 million in 2024
but even that third year of funding
delivers less delivers less than
scotland received before brexit and if
you'd like to explain to me why scotland
deserves less now than they had before
brexit i'll take his intervention
would you like to explain i'm grateful
to have a giving way would you like to
explain to the house how much harder it
would be for business and for living
standards in scotland if scotland
uh followed her suggestion and the snp
suggestion and left the united kingdom
with a border across the middle of great
britain
there are multiple benefits from
scotland being independent and certainly
the greatest one was not having to live
with policy choices by this government
that none of our people voted for
the scottish government has calculated
that a sum of 162 million pounds per
year would be needed to replace european
regional development fund and the
european social fund increasing 183
million pounds per year when leader
funding and the eu territorial program
cooperation programs are added in this
leaves a significant shortfall for
organizations and projects who are
already operating with significant
challenges from the pandemic and the
cost of living crisis and of course many
of these projects were contributing
significantly to economic growth funding
projects like bridges and green
infrastructure retraining those who had
lost their job or who were far from the
labour market and without the non-e to
replace these projects these areas and
these people will struggle to make
progress as bloomberg is already
suggesting is happening with the flawed
tory levelling up fund
our next speaker's investment was
stagnant before the pandemic because of
the drawn out uncertainty of brexit an
unnecessary commitment to leaving the
customs union and the single market the
harm to the economy and to people's
pockets could have lessened had
different choices have been made and
there has been a lot of talk about the
northern ireland protocol but the
reality is the manufacturing northern
ireland has found that the issue is
largely with gb suppliers who are
unwilling to send to northern ireland
while eu supply chains have recovered
and there has been a 28 increase in
sales with the eu
and manufacturing jobs in northern
ireland too are now growing four times
faster four times faster than the eu
average
madam deputy speaker the bills within
this queen's speech did nothing to
redress the damage caused by brexit and
as james withers from scotland food and
drink has observed he has said had the
war in ukraine not happened we were
already facing energy bills rising a
world waking up from a pandemic brexit
for sure has made nothing better but has
made a number of things a lot worse
mr weathers also pointed to the labour
market being in disarray and this uk
tory government's obsession with
limiting immigration is causing unharmed
untold harm to our growth prospects the
office for national statistics noted
yesterday that around half a million
people have left the labour market
completely since the start of the
pandemic and we don't yet know how they
will come back meanwhile vacancies are
running a record high of 1.295 billion
but who will fill these jobs the
government has absolutely no answer on
how these jobs will be filled and it's
already having an impact on these
vacancies because the british chamber of
commerce survey have found that
companies can't fulfill orders due to a
lack of staff as well as soaring
material costs perpetuating hostile
environment is bad economics as well as
morally dubious politics and it is not a
recipe for growth as a recipe for
self-inflicted economic catastrophe
madam deputy speaker there is precious
little in this queen's speech that will
help with the spiraling cost of living
crisis and soaring energy prices and the
april 2022 price cap was already 75
percent higher than one year ago
miata fanbooler of the new economics
foundation has said that the government
has said that its priority was to help
people with the cost of living crisis
yet we had 38 bills that will barely
have an impact on that agenda
and the money in people's pockets
whether they are in work whether they
are out of work is being eroded every
single day by inflation
the uk tory government could choose to
put money in people's pockets they can
bring forward an emergency budget to
make sure that the least well-off those
really struggling those who need support
with their energy bills to
to get by
could be supported the snp government
has has uplifted the benefits in its
control by six percent there again the
uk tory government lags behind and
people are seeing the money that they
are receiving eroded every single day
the uk government should be converting
the 200 pounds heat now pay a liter loan
into a grant they should be increasing
as the
chief executive of scottish power has
said that grant substantially he says 1
000 pounds to help people with their
energy bills such as the magnitude of
the increase in people's costs they
should scrap their aggressive national
insurance tax tag a tax on job at the
worst possible time they should reverse
the 1040 pound cuts to universal credit
they should support those on legacy
benefits who have seen very very little
from this government
and they should introduce a real living
wage a living wage for all a living wage
that can actually be
allow people to live on it rather than
their pretending living wage which is
not even available to all ages there is
age discrimination baked in to their
pretendy
living wage and they should look at
removing vat on energy bills
because that is a significant cost too
and the government
has been wreaking it in adam deputy
speaker they have had an additional
amount of money coming in through the
taxation system that they didn't expect
the spring statement set that out it
will be increasing every day as vat
receipts come in through the door and
inflation soars
the rising cost of living for poorer
families is nine times larger than for
the richest five percent as a proportion
of income
the ifs figures suggest that while
inflation today is at nine percent for
the least well-off inflation is shy of
um just shy of 11
and the impact that that has on people
madame deputy speaker can sound a bit
abstract when we start talking about
percentages here and there
but child poverty action group have
calculated that the value of someone's
universal credit with inflation running
at nine percent the value of that
universal credit falls by
790 pounds per year that's a lot of
money to people who'd receive those
benefits and the government should be
doing something more about that
madam deputy speaker all the way through
the supply chain costs are increasing
from those growing crops to those
processing and transporting food to
those stacking in the shell so those
cooking their tea and putting it on the
table businesses have been pushed to the
very limits absorbing these costs and
this cannot continue for much longer
and i'm deputy speaker it is hard to
hide my frustration when i watch
treasury ministers in this place because
they have all the levers that my
colleagues in hollywood don't have and
yet not one iota of the ambition or the
imagination there is so much more that
they could do to invest in people to
invest in communities to work towards
the promise of cop 26 and to build a
fairer and more just and more equal
society to grow but in a way that leaves
nobody behind we cannot rely on the
conservatives of the tories both of them
brexiteer parties now
because scotland wants to take its place
in the world we want to be part of
something uh where we can be connected
rather than relying on the tiny
ambitions of this government people in
scotland are here are yearning for a
government with the powers to do better
by its people i hope they will soon get
the chance to vote for it in an
independent strategy
damian green
yeah it's a pleasure to follow the
honourable lady i rise to support many
of the bills in the speech and in
particular to support the contention
that slow growth is the long-term bane
of the british economy going back many
decades and i therefore wholeheartedly
welcome the fact that the chancellor has
made raising productivity and therefore
growth his main task and the urgency of
this task is only amplified by the scary
inflation we are now experiencing he's
absolutely right to emphasize this as
the central purpose
of his chancellorship um and in his
opening excellent opening speech the uh
chief secretary uh made the point that
there are three pillars uh to this
approach um i i was
going to mention five i hope this isn't
another sign of rapidly rising inflation
uh that the numbers have gone up so
quickly um but on top of the ones he
mentioned um i would add
and in particular commend in the queen's
speech the idea of spreading economic
activity and opportunity um all around
the country
we know that if if all if all the uk was
as productive as london and the south
east
uk gdp would be boosted by some 180
billion pounds uh there are as the
honourable lady from glasgow central uh
mentioned many figures flying around
today but that is a very significant and
simple one we would all all over the
country be significantly richer if we
could make the less productive parts of
the country as productive as the most
productive parts and therefore those
bits of of the leveling up bill that are
about spreading
activity and opportunity are i think
absolutely central to the success of our
economic policy over the next uh couple
of years um as for the planning parts of
that bill we may wish to return to that
uh in a later uh debate and the other uh
one of the things he did mention were
skills of course absolutely essential
and in that i very much welcome the
schools bill of course school education
is about much more than preparing for
economic life but consistently higher
standards in our schools will give us a
more productive workforce and therefore
greater wealth
and in the end more leisure time it is
absolutely one of the the bases on which
we need to build not just a healthy
society but a healthy economy
the other element i would add which he
didn't mention specifically
is the use of science and technology
again successive governments frankly
going back more than half a century
going back as far as harold wilson have
emphasized the need to harness science
more effectively to give us a long-term
advantage in a competitive world
and i think one of the things we've
learned over those many decades is that
it needs to be done
in a focused way and in that regard i
think the genetic technology bill is
particularly welcome and it is in one
specific area but it is a hugely
important area and it is one in which we
ought to have an international advantage
and and should wish to exploit it um he
mentioned infrastructure uh and in a
week where we have seen uh crossrail
operating i think we should all
celebrate the fact that we can um even
if slightly belatedly build grand
project
in this country um i hope the uh the
details of the transport bill when we
see it do actually encourage innovation
as well as simply government activity
because that's hugely important
and that's the fifth point of course and
one that he mentioned as well innovation
is the most difficult thing to legislate
for it requires an attitude of mind a
culture that grows from a tax system
that encourages risk taking an education
system that provides the necessary
skills and the opportunities for people
to make a difference particularly in
their own area
and it's one
yes
thank the honourable member for giving
way
does he agree with me on that point that
climate education in schools through
primary to secondary and vocational
courses is absolutely essential if we're
to meet our legally binding target of
net zero by 2050.
it's one of the things and sure she like
me spends a lot of time visiting schools
in her constituency and i'm struck by
not only the uh the standard of the
teaching uh
in that area but also the enthusiasm and
engagement
of young people um on that issue and and
absolutely that's that's very important
but it's another of our more innovative
sectors that i want to concentrate on
for a few minutes
because i'm afraid it's one area where
the bills before us threaten to take us
in the wrong direction and i refer to
the creative industries which is an area
where britain is undoubtedly world class
and which any government would want to
support encourage and perhaps above all
listen to when it considers the future
in this regard i have reservations about
the media bill which will come before us
let me quote from the government's own
white paper on broadcasting called up
next
published last month it says the uk's
creative economy is a global success
story and our public service
broadcasters are the beating heart of
that success they produce great british
content loved across the uk and the
world over the government wants it to
stay that way good so do i and so do
millions of people who value bbc channel
4 as well as itv and channel 5. they all
do a good job what worries me looking at
the white paper and indeed the
announcements made is that the
government's warm words are not matched
by sympathetic actions
take channel 4 first
the government had a consultation it was
overwhelming desire uh to keep the
ownership situation as it is um and that
was ignored um the government has argued
uh in ignoring the consultation that uh
channel four needs borrowing powers so
that it doesn't in the end have to rely
borrowing uh for borrowing on the state
channel four has come up with a
suggestion for a joint venture that
would enable it to stay with its current
ownership regime and but still access
private capital um that was ignored
instead the government has said it is it
insists on on carrying on uh with
private uh with privatization but if you
care about a successful sector
and the creative sector is successful
and that the many small businesses who
make programs for channel 4 are
particularly successful you should
listen to it when it tells you how best
to strengthen it for the future um i i
as a conservative i find it
extraordinary that we have a
conservative government that is saying
the gentleman from whitehall knows best
that the the government is deciding how
best to run this particular part of this
particular sector ignoring in particular
the small businesses that make it up i
thought this into small business was a
core conservative aid
and and we seem to be ignoring this and
and let's go from the abstract to the
concrete this is either channel 4 is
either going to be bought if this
legislation goes through which i hope it
doesn't
either be bought by a big us player
in which case
let's look in five years time at how
much
quirky different innovative uk-based
content is being made
for channel 4
particularly as it happens outside
london and the southeast outside the
traditional broadcasting areas which
channel 4 is good at or it's possible
that itv will buy it which will mean a
reduction in competition in the tv
advertising market and again speaking as
a conservative i thought competition was
one of the things we believed in and
wanted to
encourage
and beyond channel 4 the government
plans to move on to the bbc it is
rightly consulting on the future funding
of this hugely important national
institution
but it's slightly difficult to take a
consultation seriously when at the
outset the secretary of state has
announced her conclusion that the
license fee has had its day it's an
arguable position but it's unarguable
that it makes a whole consultation look
like a sham the dtms select committee
which i'm a member of looked at this
issue last year and broadly speaking
concluded that for all the disadvantages
it has we know what they are the license
fee was the least bad option for the
coming years let's have a proper debate
on this hugely important and complex
issue and not a sham consultation where
the verdict has been given before the
evidence has been considered and again
let's listen to the voices of those who
have made our creative sectors such a
big economic contributor to the country
and something to be really proud of in
modern britain to conclude then i
there's very much i welcome in the
queen's speech but i hope the government
will listen on some issues because
otherwise there's a danger of stifling
growth in one of our best economic
sectors britain needs a thriving
creative sector and the creative
industries need a government that will
support and nurture them by creating a
regulatory climate in which they can
thrive creating jobs and wealth and also
creating experiences and memories that
the british people will share with each
other i'm sure this house will help the
government achieve that end thank you
hillary ben thank you very much indeed
madam deputy speaker this morning the
foreign secretary said
we are in a very very difficult economic
situation and we all recognize that that
is true
and while there are some things that no
government control
i would encourage ministers to reflect a
little bit more
on some of the difficulties that it has
brought about itself and british
business
now in this speech the chief secretary
somehow neglected to mention
the fact that our goods trade with the
european union has since january 2021
had to contend with
red tape bureaucracy and cost including
increased transport costs that the
government has dumped on british
businesses
by the deal it concluded and we know we
have small and medium-sized companies
who are struggling to export to the eu
because of that we know that there are
musicians and performing artists who
look at visa applications customs
declarations um the member who rather
remember just spoke talked about the
importance of the cultural sector they
found it's incompatible with trying to
tour in europe we know that farmers are
suffering from shortages of labor on
monday i was in kent i'm co-convener of
the uk trading business commission we
talked to a fruit farmer he said last
year i couldn't pick eight percent of my
credit
so what's he done this year he's
reducing
the amount that he plans
now what does that do for british food
security its benefits for other
countries growing more but it's making
it harder for british farmers to grow
more here and while
businesses having to cope with all of
this cost the government has just now
for the fourth time postponed checks on
eu businesses
exporting into the united kingdom so
they face less of the checks and costs
the government has dumped them on to
british businesses and the odr as
members will know say that the uk has
and i quote missed out on much of the
recovery in global trade
and according to the hmrc
the number of uk businesses exporting
goods to the eu
fell by an astonishing
33
last year
compared to the year before and that is
mainly small businesses
who have said we can't be bothered with
all of this we're giving up exporting
how does that help economic recovery of
course i would give way to the
honourable gentleman
uh he's making a very strong point and
i'm not a ramona in any shape or form
but in the bank of england's evidence
including the governor of the bank of
england to the treasury select committee
this week and indeed he's written
evidence that committee and need the
minutes of the military policy committee
meetings on the labor shortages the uk
is facing
none of those mentioned brexit not a
single one
why does he think that is i i mean is it
not the case that we must confront the
brutal facts if we're going to solve
some of these problems
well the i can only report what i was
told by the farmer on monday and he has
relied over the years on workers who've
come from eastern europe and he says
they're just not coming in the same
numbers and that's why i can't pick my
cross that's the point that i'm making i
i will give way and then i'll make some
progress
right honourable gentleman uh for giving
way because he had the pleasure as i did
of having lunch with some senators who
were visiting here from france and i
believe he was at the very conversation
where they were saying how difficult it
is for them as well to find seasonal
agricultural workers because of the
disruption caused by the pandemic
well undoubtedly disentangling the
impact of the pandemic and other factors
is um continuing work it's a point the
ons make when it publishes the
statistics but there is no doubt at all
the change in the visa regime that is
being operated by the home office now is
having the impact on british farmers and
that was the point that i was trying to
make now i long for the day when these
things
i i'm
very quickly because of the time
constraints i'm very grateful to him for
giving way and i think he's making an
excellent point and i've also been
given the same feedback by small
businesses does he agree with me there's
also a very serious connection here
between the rising cost of food and the
lack of labor for british farms and that
this particular area could be driving
inflation
if you put more cost and bureaucracy red
tape increased transport costs on
businesses that is going to increase
prices because that's one of the ways
that businesses cope now these things
need to be sorted out but frankly as
long as there is no trust between the
european union and the united kingdom it
isn't going to happen and the principal
cause of distrust at the moment is the
standoff over the northern ireland
protocol which is the other issue i
wanted to raise
now we've got two problems one is that
the northern ireland government is not
functioning and the second is that the
northern ireland protocol isn't working
and the good friday agreement the power
sharing the peace it has brought cannot
be jeopardized by trade problems caused
by the protocol now it is extremely
tempting
to dwell on the miserable history of how
we got here uh how the prime minister
moved from promising he'd never put a
border in the irish sea and then he
probably did one when he became
the occupant of number 10
described it as a great deal for
northern ireland but i would say in all
honesty that his failings and his
inconsistencies are not a reason
to inflict damage on northern ireland or
on the british economy when so many
people are struggling
we all knew that leaving the european
union would create difficulties uh on
ireland
everyone agreed the only thing everyone
agreed on was that there could be no
return to a hard border
practically the only
thing and that's why
the most important part of the protocol
talked about goods at risk and this is
at the heart of the debate goods at risk
having entered northern ireland of going
into the european union as opposed to
goods that are going to stay in northern
ireland that was never defined the joint
committee was given the task of dealing
with it now we have a standoff at the
moment
um in one way if the standoff could just
be extended and extended and extended uh
the grace periods continuing to be
prolonged by the government unlawfully
as per the protocol the eu's starting
legal action staying it while they try
and negotiate
um
that's one way of dealing with it
um
in fairness the eu did move it moved on
medicines and i praise uh mara sefkovic
for having done so he changed eu law to
allow nhs patients in northern ireland
to get nhs messages pretty obvious
really
i said to him on thursday when he
appeared before the parliamentary
partnership assembly thanks for doing
that but if you can move on that can you
not move on other things as well because
there are remaining problems we all know
the list see potatoes parcels guide dogs
supermarket deliveries to shops organic
food divergence on the use of titanium
dioxide an ingredient in cakes and ice
cream i was not previously aware of
where
the current proposals that the eu has
put forward would actually
provide more checks and problems than
the current standoff and it's important
that we recognize that i say to the
government as i said to the foreign
secretary yesterday that threatening to
disapply the protocol
isn't going to work because in the end
it will result in retaliation
and if retaliation results in further
obstacles to trade or heaven forbid a
trade war that is going to make the cost
of living crisis even worse we have a
real eur in war in europe going on at
the moment we do not need a trade war
with our biggest trading partner at the
same time the eu needs to understand
it's got to move uh to help bring this
crisis to an end and if one takes
supermarket deliveries
um
those supermarkets will sell only to
shops in northern ireland what exactly
is the risk of the integrity of a single
market from a sandwich a cake or a
chicken i'm a vegetarian that is bought
in a supermarket in strabane or belfast
can anyone actually point in what 16
months of the grace periods operating to
a single example where the integrity of
the single market has been damaged
i'm not aware of one at all there is a
problem with divergence and i hope a way
of mutually recognizing each other's
food standard production arrangements
can come so in conclusion madam deputy
speaker
this crisis arises from a practical
problem and it requires a practical
solution and that is what politics is
meant to deliver that is our job
and we need patient diplomacy and we
need negotiation which takes as its
starting point the purpose of the rules
rather than
the rules themselves they're there for a
purpose
and apply those to the uni and
particular circumstances of northern
ireland so frankly could we have less
squabbling could we have more cool heads
could we have less escalation more
conciliation and my message to both
sides in the partnership council is a
very simple one you've got the power to
deal with this sorted out
just a gentle reminder that my guidance
was um seven minutes um chris craving
speaker i'll endeavor to fulfill that
but i would say to the right of
gentleman that he's right about
conciliation but it is also noticeable
the european union is preventing the
united kingdom from participating in a
horizon in europe which is allowing the
israelis to do so that doesn't feel to
me like an awful lot of goodwill from
their side and that's to be regretted
madame deputy speaker i rise to support
the queen's speech
the reality is as we focus on economic
growth these are extraordinary and
difficult times for our economy now
we've had in this country to deal with
an unprecedented series of problems and
frankly so have our ministers as well
something that's often forgotten by the
other side of their throat brickbats at
them
the reality is actually we now know that
the government handled the country
handled the tragic circumstances of the
pandemic pretty well as we now know from
the wealth world health organization
many countries suffered so did we but we
were far from being the bad performer
that has been suggested and of course we
also forget now madam deputy speaker the
continued impact of the pandemic in
china where there are severe lockdown
still that is causing an economic ripple
effect that is contributing to the
inflation problem that we face and the
sad reality is that when oil prices soar
when food prices soar when the cost of
household energy soars all things that
are basically outside the control of any
individual government there are very few
governments that can waive a wand and
solve them
now i'm pretty supportive of much of
what this government has done how it's
gone about dealing with the range of
issues that have arisen but i would like
to make one very simple point to the
minister and his colleagues you cannot
achieve growth by over taxing our
economy
the decisions have been taken on tax
have been taken
but the direction of travel needs to
change and needs to change soon
we also need to start by stepping up our
incentivization of investment
if we're to deal with the huge energy
challenges this country faces we've got
to do more here
that means continuing dramatic progress
we've made on wind and solar power it
means i suspect looking again at tidal
energy it means developing hydrogen
we would be though it has to be said in
a much more difficult position if this
government and the coalition before it
had not placed as much emphasis on
renewables that was clearly the right
thing to do
but
we also need more domestic production of
gas
there are those who say we should stop
all fossil fuel projects now i take
completely the opposite view as the
world rightly moves away from coal
something needs to take its place
countries that have been dependent on
coal not suddenly going to make a
complete switch to renewables or
zero-emission nuclear power stations
overnight
so gas which is the cleanest of the
fossil fuels must be a short-term
priority for us
and indeed i think it's the move away
from coal in parts of asia which started
the gas price surge in the first place
and it's pretty clear madam deputy
speaker the world doesn't actually at
the moment have enough gas for the
transition to net zero particularly as
we deal with the consequences of the war
in ukraine
so we will see prices continue to remain
high unless we deal with supply issues
that's why it makes absolute sense in
the government's right to be supporting
additional extraction of gas from the
north sea
and frankly i do say to ministers i
think we will be in dereliction of our
duty if we did not look again at the
potential to use shale gas to help us
through
and to those who say no more uk
production i just say this the emissions
from a tanker of gas from qatar are
roughly twice those of a similar
consignment from the north sea yeah yeah
i want to cut emissions
i also believe we need a steady
transition to net zero by 2050
but it is a transition
and burning fuel that generates twice
the emissions just makes no sense
gas is a key part of our transition to
net zero and the more it can be produced
in the uk the lower our emissions will
be
we also need to move rapidly on nuclear
nuclear and i welcome the government's
commitment to that as well we cannot
achieve net zero without it
now madam deputy speaker let me turn to
the issue of the environment and
conservation if i have a disappointment
in this queen's speech it's that the
legislation i was hoping for on
conservation slipped beyond this session
and i would say to the leader of the
house in his place and i hope he will
make sure it comes back in the next
session we urgently need to take forward
the progress we've made but to put in
place a modernized framework for
wildlife protection in this country
it for example makes no sense to have
expansive protections in place for newts
which are numerous here but not for
creatures like the hedgehog which have
declined so much
i've pushed for the hedgehog to have
greater legal protection i look forward
to this happening in the next session at
least
but there are steps that can be taken
now
when the leveling up bill comes before
the house i will be tabling an amendment
if the government has not already acted
to require a full wildlife survey of
every development site and if vulnerable
species are found there there should be
a legal duty to relocate them to an
appropriate habitat elsewhere
no more should we tolerate developers
cutting down all the trees on a site
clearing all the foliage and they're
turning it to a wasteland before they
have even applied for let alone secured
planning consent
we need growth
we need more houses but a cavalier
approach to local wildlife cannot be the
consequence
this session madam deputy speaker i will
continue to push ministers to go further
and faster on bottom trawling in marine
protected areas
i know we've made a start in the first
few areas but there's much further to go
this is a really important part of
protecting our ecology and it is one of
the benefits
stronger environmental protections in
our seas that is now deliverable after
we have left the european union it would
not have been possible while we were
still eu members and finally madame
deputy speaker a broader issue on
conservation i want to applaud ministers
for the work they're doing
internationally particularly what lord
goldsmith is doing to support the congo
basin
and i believe the leadership of the
right honourable member for reading west
on cop and its aftermath is exemplary
but one of the key moments of the coming
session will be the negotiations at the
cbd summit on biodiversity this year
i want to see the uk play a key role in
delivering what's needed a renewed
international drive on species
protection and habitat restoration
the wwf estimates that the amount of
degraded land internationally where
deforestation has taken place
followed by over farming is the size of
south america
if we're going to tackle climate change
and protect endangered species and deal
with a global food shortage we need to
start recovering this land restoring it
for wildlife in some areas or in some
areas properly managed agriculture
and with a focus particularly on
creating sustainable livelihoods for the
people in those areas
our ministers need to make sure we set a
path towards those goals
as we finish our year of cop presidency
and take part in the cbd discussions so
madam deputy speaker a lot to do a
growing economy a move towards net zero
doing our bit internationally to secure
a proper future for all our environments
i'm glad at least to support a
government which in my view has made a
good start but there's still a lot to do
now do you wish
thank you madam deputy speaker madam
deputy speaker this is a queen speech
that provides mediocre answers to the
wrong questions the government
acknowledges that there is a cost of
living crisis
but they don't want to do anything about
it
they acknowledge that there's a housing
crisis but they're not willing to
control rent so that people can afford
to live in their homes they acknowledge
that energy is expensive
but do they want to talk about
meaningful price caps do they want to
talk about retrofitting or insulation
did they vote in favour of a wintful tax
to lower bills when they had the
opportunity to yesterday
no no and no
this is a government government madam
deputy speaker that tells us it wants
action on the climate crisis
and then when a protest movement comes
along to demand just that
introduces legislation to have them sent
to jail
they want to invest they tell us
in the future
but conservatives have been in power for
12 years and they've cut the public
sector to shreds
wages will be lower in 2025
than they were in 2008 when i was 12
years old
since they came to power the number of
people on zero hours contracts has risen
more than fivefold all of this happened
on their watch
and are they going to reverse it
no
in 2010 the trussell trust handed out 48
000 food parcels
last year they handed out 2.1
million
meanwhile britain gained a record number
of billionaires between them owning
597 billion pounds about triple the
annual operating budget of the nhs
that madame deputy speaker is the
dynamism of the market for you it's the
kind of dynamism that makes an elderly
lady sit on the bus all day to keep warm
because she can't afford to heat her
home
what we need is a publicly owned energy
system that delivers cheap green energy
an above inflation rise in the minimum
wage at least the restoration of the 20
pound universal credit uplift but really
a reversal of all the benefit cuts since
2010 we need rent controls
and finally madam deputy speaker i'd
like to address the disgrace of
explicitly excluding trans people from
the so-called ban on conversion therapy
once again the government acknowledges
that there's a problem
but will it extend the protection of the
law to those who need it most
no
to young trans people half of whom have
attempted suicide by the time they reach
the age of 26.
so transphobic parents will still be
able to hire someone to psychologically
abuse their child in an attempt to stop
them from being trans and this practice
will still be perfectly legal
what kind of message does that send to
young trans people fighting to survive
we need a government that is on the
right side of history madam deputy
speaker but instead we have a government
of pound shop authoritarians made on the
playing fields of eaton and in the daily
mail's wild wilder's dreams
they know there's a problem
but what they can't do is recognize the
truth and that's that the problem is
then
you hear them
thank you madam deputy speaker and
um it's appropriate that i'm following
the
quite passionate speech by the
honourable lady for nottingham nice
about the
conversion therapy bill i broadly
welcomed the queen's speech in the
government's legislative program i was
always in favor of
some kind of legislation about
conversion therapy but the more i've
looked at it
uh i'm less and less happy that there
should be such a build not because i'm
in favor of conversion therapy
but because i can't see this is either
necessary or desirable i'm ready to be
proved wrong but i can think of no
coercive behavior that is not already
illegal that it would ban
and this bill will be used to stoke
exactly the kind of bitter disputes
about transsexuality which we need to
resolve before we legislate next in this
field again i'm ready to be proved wrong
let's see the bill
but i think we could have done with some
pre-legislative excruciatingly of such a
bill
i i
i i give way to my honorable friend i'm
very very
giving away because although conversion
therapy and indeed hedgehogs are both
fascinating subjects in terms of
achieving economic growth does he agree
with me that what the government is
doing on leveling up funds and bringing
investment that can act as a catalyst
for further investment into great small
cities like gloucester will actually
help create jobs and footfall and retail
all of the things that people in our
country value in order to have the
opportunities and jobs to bring about
that grace
i'm most grateful to my honourable
friend for that intervention but i think
we should recognize that these issues of
conversion therapy and transexuality are
very important to
certain sections of society and they
need to be addressed but we need to be
sure that we address them the right way
um i welcome the fourth coming up
i will give way but i don't want to give
away too often because we're not
timeless
bring forward a bill on uh the
regulation psychotherapist that you know
recommended banning conversion therapy
some years ago
attended a conference where 100
conversion therapists attended so this
is a widespread and a borrowed practice
and would he agree with me that those
people who say transsexuality shouldn't
be
be included seem to be the people who
think that uh people would go through
the process of becoming a trans woman in
order to rape another woman but of
course there's a lot of male rapists out
there it seems to be a big effort to
want to have your head kicked in by
other men in order to do that and that
trans agenda people should be included
in the bill
intended to make a great speech about
this subject i know the point he's made
i watch to move on i do welcome the
forthcoming legislation to protect the
belfast good friday agreement and i i
would say to the um
the right honourable gentleman who spoke
a few moments ago um
that
maybe
we agree about a great a great deal
about the future of the northern ireland
protocol the question is whether we can
make it happen unless we have some
legislation coming down the track as
well because the eu hasn't actually
changed its mandate but i just want to
concentrate today on uh on much more
immediate challenges
the covet supply chain disruption
persists in many parts of the world
notably china and now we have russia's
dreadful war against ukraine and this
has
frankly shattered the geopolitical order
we've become used to for decades we all
used to believe in what the germans
called vandal to handle the mistaken
faith that nations that trade together
would never go to war with each other
president putin has smashed that
confidence
business and governments
are reducing their exposure to
dependency on all
autocratic regimes this is throwing
globalization
into reverse creating massive price
increases in shortages
poorer nations are acting to keep their
food affordable for their own people for
example india has just banned wheat
exports following indonesia which banned
palm oil exports we have an acute
growing
and potentially far greater energy
supply crisis in europe
europe cannot continue to rely on supply
from russia
this crisis requires a vast
reorganization of europe's energy supply
and trading arrangements
and this massive adjustment will take
years and is unprecedented
only major food and energy producers in
the world like canada and the us will
avoid the worst kind of recession
at least the united kingdom can produce
some of our own gas and oil and can
continue to expand renewables but why
are we pumping our surplus gas out to
europe this warm spring to fill eu
storage capacity when we should be
filling our own because the government
shut it down
we need to reopen our gas storage
capacity as quickly as possible
i fervently hope
that we can achieve net zero by 2050
without excessive cost so the government
is right to see gas as the essential
transition fuel but why import gas when
we can produce our end more cheaply
meanwhile we must all recognize the cost
of living crisis
yes
crisis
even before today's shock rising cpi to
nine percent the commons library have
given me
striking projections for the effect of
this on households
the full year of cost of just energy and
food prices will rise
by well over a thousand pounds per year
for the lowest 20 percent of households
by income
and by 1500 pounds per year for
pensioner households
a summer package to rescue the most
vulnerable households is needed to avoid
real financial distress and personal
anguish
and to support economic demand of of the
most vulnerable households
or we are creating possibly a worse
recession than is already expected
so i welcome the suggestion in today's
times that the government is considering
a package
the spring statement represented
peacetime thinking life after after the
unforeseen covert crisis
like after the unforeseen kobe crisis
the treasury must adapt to this
unexpected war in europe and accept this
new global energy and economic crisis
also requires a very substantial policy
response i have to say far greater than
the three billion package that the
labour party has offered us
though i don't um subscribe to the rest
of their uh fiscal um at the rest of
their physical proficy
i would suggest the 20 pound uplift in
universal credit should immediately be
restored
the abolition of that on domestic fuel
would abolish a regressive tax which
actually hurts the poorest households
the most
we can do this now that we're outside
the eu the government should abolish the
green levees on energy bills and fund
them from the exchequer as recommended
by professor dieter helm the government
should provide pensioners and poorer
families with the confidence they can
afford to stay warm
we should double the warm-head discount
and treble the winter fuel payment
this package would cost not three
billion pounds but thirteen and a half
billion from july in this tax year
current tax year but that's still less
than the recent tax increases we've seen
um and uh it is about
six percent of gdp and affordable
now or later we should also consider
relief for middle-income households
the lower 40 percent of households will
feel severe stress from energy and food
costs alone we could start reindexing
tax thresholds or more and that would
have the advantage of uh incentivizing
work and and productivity
i have watched governments and
oppositions and i think we saw it today
blindsided by their own commitment to
outdated thinking and policies in the
past
there is no excuse for another such
episode my right honourable friend the
chief secretary is right to sound
cautious
but we can see what is coming and i am
confident this government will act as it
must
ms brown thank you madam deputy speaker
5156 people were admitted to hospital
between september last year and february
this year
with malnutrition
in england alone
5156
that is more
than the whole of 2010 the number of
people being admitted with scurvy has
doubled
in the last 10 years and we're meant to
be
the sixth or maybe sometimes the fifth
wealthiest country
in the world
we have a inflation running at nine
percent and for the poorest families
it's a 10.9 percent because more of
their money is spent on food and on
energy where inflation is higher
they're getting a rougher deal than
anybody else that's my constituents
and the government answer so far is 200
pounds they call it a gift it's not it's
a loan it actually puts up next year's
bills even more
and one thousand pounds and more cut on
universal credit the honourable member
is right on the members absolutely right
of course we should be restoring the 20
pounds a week on universal credit and
actually we've got to do more for
pensioners who are on fixed incomes as
well
government has said oh get a better paid
job oh yes it's easy isn't it just get a
better paid job
or get a different job and all they've
told us get more hours well it's just
not that simple especially if you have
caring responsibilities
and incidentally that's one of the
cheapest deals that the government gets
isn't it um free carers in the country
and or shop more carefully
for value brands to the people on the to
ministers honestly not understand how
ordinary people do their shopping every
week
that's what they've been doing for ages
and then they're not deciding which
brand they're deciding whether to buy
anything at all
and
drive around on a bus all day just so
that you don't have to pay for your
electricity bill that seemed to be the
prime minister's answer just before the
local elections and now his new version
is cut civil service by 91 000 well i'm
guessing there'll be even fewer people
sorting out the passport um office and i
don't know about anybody else's um
office but my office at the moment is
inundated with people who are saying
i've got to go to a funeral i've got to
go to a wedding i've got a holiday
that's been planned and i won't get any
of the money back if i don't have my
passport by next thursday and i put it
in more than three months ago
so i'm sorry but cutting civil servants
by 91 000 doesn't always
go well and now
the one that really amuses me is the
prime minister's latest version is let
them eat foie gras
we're allowed to have foie gras because
apparently it's not conservative to stop
people um maltreating animals so as to
get a more exciting diet
i don't think this is a gracious speech
it's so flimsy it barely counts as a
great gracious intervention to be honest
i mean it's so threadbare it barely
covers the government's dignity and it's
it's it's nothing more than a letting
out of air it's a tired sigh a long yawn
a tedious exhalation a great big yeah
of a queen speech
there's no plan no project no leadership
no ideas no program for government in
here
some of the so-called bills a little
more than glorified clauses
and great governments give us really
significant programmes of government
legislative programs the reform act the
the abolition of slavery act the nhs act
and the minimum wage act and what do we
get here
the harbours seafarers remuneration bill
now of course it's good i mean this is
the definition of um slamming the door
shut after the horse has already bolted
isn't it in relation to pno but why
isn't it a proper bill which would do
banning
fire and rehire in its totality
i mean there's a whole load of groundhog
day bills which were promised in last
year's queen speech which apparently
were meant to have completely forgotten
and you know the high-speed rail crew to
manchesterville promised last year never
happened the telecoms infrastructure
bill for 5g promised last year never
happened counter state threats bill i'm
really keen on this one because i think
we need to update the laws on espionage
in this country promised last year still
not happen i'm not going to if i don't
mind because i'm hope i'm looking
forward to hearing his speech later and
i'm sure it'd be absolutely magnificent
the mental health bill which was
promised last year and still hasn't come
to being there's one that's long overdue
bill which is the economic crime bill
and now i've been arguing for this for a
very long time in 2018 there was an
opportunity to introduce all of the
measures that i i guess that we might
have by the end of this legislative
session and
but company's house still says on its
website companies house does not verify
the accuracy of the information filed so
we do not know when we read that boris
johnson limited was dissolved on the 5th
of january 2021
we don't know whether that's true
we might like it to be true but we don't
know whether it's true or for that
matter we don't know that big boris's
bouncing bonanza limited was dissolved
on the 1st of february 2022 it's listed
on company's house but whether that's
true we don't know and where is the bill
to seize assets
it's it's it's great that we are
freezing assets um from those who are
sanctioned uh for their participation or
their involvement or their engagement in
putin's regime but there's nothing to
seize assets which is what we really
need to do and other countries are doing
and then there are all the twaddle bills
complete and utter twaddle bills my
favorite i'm afraid is the human rights
bill which will either be compliant with
the european convention on human rights
in which case it's completely and
utterly useless
or it is does not comply with the
european convention on human rights in
which case it will herald the uk
departing both the convention and the
council of europe and in which case it's
an act of self-harm
and then there's the northern ireland
protocol bill i'm really looking forward
to the day that somebody in the
government finds out who actually signed
the northern ireland protocol that's
going to be a really good day but what i
worry about is we've been preaching
quite rightly to vladimir putin and
president xi about abiding by
international law and then barely a few
years after we sign up to a treaty we
want to tear it up i mean the only
person who is laughing about all of this
is president putin
um and then there's the bill to
privatize channel 4.
this comes from a culture secretary who
didn't know that channel 4 doesn't
receive public funds
who didn't know that channel 5 has
always been a private air body
and who actually told at the salvation
army magazine war cry i am not an mp for
any reason other than because god wants
me to be
i am just a conduit for god
now i worry about people like that and
bringing in legislation in this i have
to say
um and so so i don't think madam deputy
speaker that this queen's speech
addresses any of the problems that my
constituents have
they are choosing between eating and
heating they worry about whether they're
going to be able to pay the rent they
worry about their fund their family
and we still haven't addressed any of
the issues in the nhs
i had cancer three years ago and i was
told that i had probably less than a
year to live i know how important it is
to have early diagnosis
we at the beginning of covid we had a
4.4 million
backlog of people waiting for surgery we
now have a 6.1 million backlog and i
still see no answer to getting people
back into
getting them there the treatment they
they need and they receive to save their
lives that's why i say
this is amir
harriet baldwin
thank you madam deputy speaker and uh it
was interesting to listen to the
honourable gentleman from ronda uh i
won't be joining him in the lobby this
evening to vote down the entirety of the
queen's speech which is what he is
choosing to do including the economic
crime and corporate transparency uh bill
but uh nevertheless um
he made his points forcefully and well
uh i do want to endorse what the uh
chief secretary was saying though when
he ran through the important range of
bills that are included in today's
queen speech but
i think we have all been completely
shocked and taken aback today by this
headline rate of inflation reaching 9
and it is a very very sobering moment uh
that has been noted in many speeches in
this chamber today
and i would start by saying therefore
that i think
that our chancellor has been
an unlucky chancellor
he's had to face
a pandemic
he's had to face
war
he's now had to face due to the
consequences of that evil war
this inflation that is harming uh the
pockets of uh everyone across the united
kingdom
but i think that it's right to say that
my constituents feel very lucky that
they have had this chancellor throughout
these difficult challenges
they feel lucky because he was so quick
to provide help during the pandemic and
that the furlough scheme and the small
business income support scheme to name
but two of the many schemes the cultural
recovery fund is another were so
gratefully received by constituents
during the pandemic and i think it is
thanks to his plan for jobs that we were
able to see yesterday that very
foundation of what we are all trying to
achieve through economic growth which is
just a quite remarkable level of low
unemployment in this country it is the
lowest level of unemployment madam
deputy speaker since
1974 and there were other remarkable
things in yesterday's job uh
announcements there were a high a record
high number of vacancies and i think i'm
right in saying it's the first time that
the number of vacancies actually
exceeded the number of job seekers in
this country so the plan for jobs has
has worked well the help that the
chancellor gave through the pandemic has
worked well and we are in a position
today where we face this high inflation
rate of being able to say that we do
have a strong job market i think it's
also worth noting uh madam deputy
speaker that uh this month marks the
25th anniversary of the independence of
the bank of england and i am going to
start strike a uh a consensual note by
saying i think that was a really good
policy decision to make the bank of
england independent and i think we need
to all reiterate how important it is
that the bank of england has that
independence but also reiterate how
important it is for them to achieve
that two percent inflation mandate and
reiterate that today that is incredibly
important to our constituents that we
have uh low inflation that can form the
foundation for achieving economic growth
i would also like to put on record that
i believe that uh again this might
surprise members on the bench's office
opposite i think a windfall tax
well i i think i i think it has it is a
winful tax that helps the lowest uh
income households is the right approach
and i believe it is the approach that
this government is already following
uh there is already a windfall tax on
the oil and gas sector
whereas most corporations in this
country pay 19
corporation tax uh those in the oil and
gas sector already pay a 30 corporation
tax and a 10 windfall tax on top of that
and because the price of oil and gas has
risen so much there has been a windfall
to the chancellor from that increase in
price and he has rightly spent that
windfall on those who are in uh the
lowest income household so
just this week uh people in council tax
band aid to d and my constituency will
be receiving 150 pounds
cash grant in their bank accounts
next july uh in a couple of months time
uh there will be a hike in the national
insurance threshold which will put
another 330 pounds a year into the
pockets of those who pay national
insurance we have also heard about the
200 pound smoothing impact in terms of
household bills i would also urge every
pensioner in this country on a low
income to check that they're not
entitled to pension credit there are 850
000 pensioners in this country madam
deputy speaker who are not claiming the
pension credit they are entitled to and
can we all agree that we should
encourage our constituents to claim that
it not only gives them extra cash but it
also means that they get other benefits
there's also the household income
support fund which has been doubled to a
billion pounds i would direct any of my
constituents who uh reach out to me who
are struggling with bills to go and ask
about that fund and there is the warm
homes discount which has been both
increased and widened in terms of its
eligible eligibility so yes these
measures are important and they are
targeted on
the lowest income households rather than
a five percent across the board cutting
v80 on fuel bills which would really
benefit those most who live in the
biggest houses
so
madam deputy speaker in conclusion i
would like to say that it doesn't matter
how
much bad luck the world has thrown at
you and i think in the chancellor's case
he has been unlucky i think by doing the
right thing you can make the luck that
would be a strong foundation for
achieving economic growth
sarah olney
madame deputy speaker it's a pleasure to
speak in this queen speech debate just
as it was a pleasure to see her majesty
yesterday at the opening of the
elizabeth line our new railway line
coming through london
um and
as obviously
as the member for ashford already
mentioned it's been uh overrun in both
time and budget but actually i think a
small upside of that is that her majesty
got to open the line that bears her name
during her jubilee celebrations and i
think that is uh but the line itself in
terms of its uh its innovation uh the
infrastructure uh the opportunity it's
provided uh thousands of young people
develop their skills the level of
ambition that it shows uh for economic
growth in this country is actually a
much better tribute to her majesty than
the speech that was delivered in this
place in her name last week and we're
here today to talk about how that speech
achieves economic growth and i'm afraid
to say that really there was very little
in it at all and we all know i think we
all accept that economic growth
particularly at this time is absolutely
vital
not least to support our small and
medium businesses but all the
organizations uh that support employment
and entrepreneurship across this country
and what we've seen yesterday uh is the
uh unemployment figures uh we see them
at the lowest level since 1974 and as
members of the opposite bench not least
the prime minister earlier today
highlighting that as a good thing which
it undoubtedly is but what we also see
for the first time i think ever is that
there are more vacancies across the uk
economy than there are people looking
for work and i think we have to look at
the serious implications of that because
that is going to be a real break on
growth if we cannot fill those vacancies
if businesses cannot get people into the
skilled jobs that they need to push
forward to grow their businesses to
create opportunities uh and and to
provide that economic growth then that
is really going to hold this country
back so it is quite uh a serious issue
as well as as some people have said uh
some cause for for celebration but i
think one of the other things that's
really highlighted is as we've all been
saying nine percent inflation is what
we're now facing um and that means wage
growth but it means a greater wage
growth acceleration in the private
sector compared to the public sector and
i'm seeing for myself in my constituency
i was on a visit uh to kingston hospital
the other day and they're telling me
that actually their biggest issue right
now is being able to discharge patients
out of hospital uh and back home but
they can't get they can't discharge
patients they can't get the care
packages and they can't get the care
packages because people don't want to
work in care for very low wages when
they can get better wages working for
hospitality or retail and so i think we
need to look and sit and concede that
there is a perhaps if you like a dark
side to these unemployment figures and
that is really uh going to inhibit
growth
and i think the other thing that we're
really beginning to see is that we are
not trading uh to the extent that some
of our our partners across the world are
according to the obr the uk has become a
less trade intensive economy by the
fourth quarter of 2021 uk exports
remained about 12 below pre-pandemic
levels and trade as a share of gdp has
fallen by around 12 since 2019 two and a
half percent more than any other country
in the g7
and the government pledged in it in the
queen's speech to continue to champion
international trade delivering jobs
right across the country growing the
economy and yet trade is declining
there's no determined plan for growth
they've talked about their free trade
agreements with australia and new
zealand um but i think we have uh
highlighted on several occasions before
the potentially negative impact that's
going to have on british farming and i
don't think that the government have
really are really listening to the
concerns of farmers on this particular
issue
um
and
in in my own constituency in richmond
park businesses are telling me about the
multiple barriers that they're facing to
trade and that's having a negative
impact on their ability to grow very uh
successful and popular restaurant in
richmond town centre called don
fernando's was closed after 32 years
there was a myriad of different issues
but not least the high cost of importing
uh the food and drink from
from spain in particular that they
relied upon to deliver their high
quality uh spanish cuisine
and a drinks company uh complications
custom check complete lack of support or
advice from hmrc leftist goods in
quarantine for almost three months now
obviously any kind of food or drink uh
trader facing those kinds of delays
cannot uh cannot operate uh when when uh
fresh food or drinks are being kept for
that uh that length of time
so the government really does need to
get on board with some of the issues
that are being thrown up by brexit by
the red tape by the customs checks uh
and really needs to work hard to unlock
some of these uh some of these problems
if they want to support some of our
smaller medium
enterprises
i want to particularly to highlight my
disappointment that there wasn't more in
the queen's speech about insulation
we've talked a lot today about fuel
prices and that's a very very real
anxiety for many households across the
country and we all know that one way of
tackling that is to get to grips with
some of our very poor housing stock uh
and obviously our low-income families
are particularly impacted by this we
need to see a great deal more from this
government to support households and
particularly social housing tenants and
their housing providers to
improve insulation improve uh energy
efficiency in our housing if we really
got to grips with that now if we really
launched a big drive right across
the country and particularly those
low-income families if we did that now
think of the difference we could start
making when those fuel bills really
start to rack up in the autumn and the
winter if we were really serious about
this and it's not just about the few
bills that our constituents are facing
now and are dreading uh in the in the
winter it's also about the government's
net zero commitment uh because to reduce
uh carbon emissions our households are a
serious contributor to that and we
really need to get to grips with that
issue uh if we are to meet our net zero
commitments
um
and i was interested to find that
there's only 1 690 installer businesses
that meet the requirements to
participate in government schemes there
is such a great opportunity here for
improving innovation entrepreneurship
skills training right across the country
the government needs to put some serious
money and some serious thought into that
as soon as it possibly can
um and the final thing that i really
wanted to address uh like other members
uh today i really welcome the mental
health bill but i want to see a lot more
from the government to recognize the
scale of the issue it is i think the
number one uh problem in my constituency
access to health services of all kinds
i'm hearing from constituents about
dentistry about surgical procedures
about gp appointments but my experience
is that the most critical issue is
access to mental health services the
impact of the pandemic and the lockdown
on our children has been profound and we
are failing them if we don't get to
grips with that impact from our very
youngest citizens who were deprived of
some of their early years of schooling
and have so much still to catch up on
socialization and learning in a
classroom
and and
separation anxiety from their parents to
our teens and our young adults who have
spent some of those critical socializing
years in their bedrooms and are finding
it very very difficult to reconnect with
everyday society especially as they move
from school to uh to to whatever they're
moving on to they're finding it really
hard to move to university to training
to further education to employment
because they've missed out on some of
that critical development so i really
really want to see the government do a
great deal more
i've got multiple cases of constituents
waiting for treatment i've got a young
girl aged just 12. she was referred to
cams in march 2021 and 13 minutes 13
months later still awaiting treatment
her parents are absolutely desperate she
has been hospitalized twice repeatedly
sent home duke from school due to
suicide attempts and it is putting
schools under so much pressure and i
think we can really see as well that
schools are really struggling to cope uh
with these complex mental health needs
sharp rise in those presenting higher
levels of risk um and we are calling the
liberal democrats calling for a
dedicated qualified mental health
professional in every school to help
with that first uh that first level
support for young people but also to
help the teachers who are really
struggling to deal with this issue so i
think there's multiple ways that we
really need to respond to the challenges
of of our current economy and our
current society and i'm afraid to say i
find that queen's speech has failed in
all of these things and i really really
urge the government to do more on these
issues thank you madam andrew
thank you very much deputy speaker i'm
delighted to be called in this debate
and i want to talk about three areas in
my seven minutes the economy general
practice and schools and schools and
yesterday i was delighted to get the
very good news from the house commons
library that unemployment has fallen by
1725
in the year to april in my constituency
now every one of those people is an
individual everyone able to contribute
to a household budget everyone able to
help with the family finances and
sometimes i don't think we realize what
an economics job miracle this country
has been over the years in the middle of
the last decade the united kingdom was
creating more jobs than the whole of the
rest of the european union put together
that is an amazing jobs creation record
and the fact that the economy uh is
still enabling those jobs to be produced
at the moment after the covert shock and
after the ukraine shock is quite
incredible and i pay tribute to all the
businesses large and small and to
government policy uh for enabling um
that to happen and of course what is
happening in ukraine is uh having a big
consequence on people's cost of living
one thinks of those storehouses in
odessa full of grain
that could go around the world to feed
hungry people and would help grain
prices come down would help us here in
the united kingdom but because of the
evil action of the putin regime that is
not allowed to happen ukraine also
the world's fourth largest producer of
ammonia and fertilizer having a huge
impact on the problems that are that are
that our farmers are facing
at the moment
i'm also acutely conscious that um
housing particularly in my constituency
in large parts of the southeast is a
mammoth part of people's outgoings
there's a lot of talk at the moment
quite understandably about increasing
energy costs and increasing food costs
in my part of the world it is not
unusual for people's rent to be
two-thirds of their income that is
simply not sustainable and it is really
tough for people on lower incomes in uh
high housing cost areas we do need to
confront that i know the prime minister
gets that i know the leveling up
secretary and housing secretary uh gets
that and that in my view is is really at
the heart of
of poverty issues in large parts of the
south of the country and if we were to
build more zero energy bill homes as a
british architect bill dunster obe in
fact the architect of port cullis house
if that doesn't put you off him there's
my colleagues have got officers there
but uh for years uh you know he has
pointed out it is possible to build
homes which sell back more energy to the
grid than they draw down so you don't
have gas and electricity bills so that
is fantastic for our greenhouse gas
emission targets and for this huge
energy shock that is causing so much
worry and concern uh to too many of our
constituents and i know we are reducing
carbon in new homes by 70 but i would
encourage the government to go further
and faster in this area and i was very
pleased to see the chancellor say
yesterday i note the 22 billion i note
the and 83 billion pounds in debt
interest but i was pleased to say
to hear the chance to say yesterday and
i quote we will do more to support the
most vulnerable uh that is absolutely
right i look forward to those details
particularly perhaps for the disabled
and pensioners and uh given the chance
of record and how he's got the country
through covid i know he will not
disappoint in that area
the second
briefly yes of course does he agree with
me that the statistic that emerged
yesterday which is that we have actually
increased the number of people with
disabilities in employment
to 1.3 million after setting a 1 million
target in 2017 we've achieved that
target within five years is an
astonishing
result of hard work by many people
including of course the applicants
themselves yeah well i'm so grateful to
my honourable friend um for uh making
that point there's a wonderful indian
employer in my constituency he calls his
disabled staff differently abled and i
think that's a wonderful way to put it
actually because they have amazing gifts
to bring and often employers will say
they are some of the most hardworking
and the most dedicated which is why our
disability confident campaign you know
is is so important and clearly has been
uh successful so i thank my honourable
friend for raising that point the second
area i want to raise and i'm
particularly focusing on the leveling up
and regeneration bill and what it needs
to do
is the appalling difficulty that many of
us have on both sides of the house
in getting sufficient additional general
practice capacity where there are huge
new housing developments and we are a
country in my view
that generally does public
administration well i have rarely come
across a child that doesn't have a
school place for example we plan
many things well in this country because
we have brilliant civil servants we have
brilliant local authority officers we
generally do this well i think a major
exception i have to say which i really
would ask the front bench please to note
and please to take back um across
government is that doing this for
general practice um
is not working well it is at the moment
a sort of alphabet soup of different
places you can go to to try and get a
health hub or extra uh extra gp
surgeries you could try section 106 you
could try community infrastructure levy
you might be lucky with a housing
infrastructure fund maybe your local
authority will come to the rescue or
perhaps even
capital from the government from the
treasury to the department of health and
social care it is complicated it is
uncertain and we are not serving our
constituents well by making sure um that
this general practice capacity is
available i've got 14 000 new houses
being built that will help with the
housing issues i spoke about earlier but
that's 36 over 36 000 new residents
coming to my area and we must have the
general practice capacity for that and i
will keep campaigning on that issue
until it's resolved
turning to the schools
bill lots of good things in schools and
indeed in skills that this government is
doing and never has that been more
important and i am very pleased to be
able to report to my uh my friends on on
the front bench that the church of
england is particularly pleased with the
schools bill and uh why why is that
significant because the church of
england with a roman catholic church
they actually run one third of the
schools in england so they're quite a
big stakeholder in
this area and uh the bishop of durham
and nigel agendas our chief education
officer have said how pleased they are
they have they have extremely good
cooperation with the secretary of state
uh for education uh they are delighted
with it they think we can do a lot more
together and i'm very pleased to be able
to uh report that um i like what we're
doing on lifetime skills t levels are
really important i think there's a
little bit more work to do on
apprenticeships
and
what we're doing employer representative
bodies is absolutely right i have a
particular issue with cnc operators in
in my area
engineering businesses really screaming
to get hold of them i have the skills
minister coming to outrageous on the 6th
of june
working very closely with the bedford
college group and we must press through
these are jobs that pay around 48 000
pounds a year
it is not right that we can't get people
to do these jobs and i'm looking forward
to the skills that ministers visit
robert thank you madam deputy speaker
the gracious speech the the other day
was most memorable for being a queen
speech without a queen
it was also an agenda for from a
government without clear
direction flailing around in its 12th
year and as the ifg said it reads like a
manifesto aimed at the party base more
than a realistic programme which is what
you get when you have an administration
diverted from the real issues of the day
by self preservation so one on the face
of it 38 bills is a frenetic level of
legislation the most in almost a decade
and four times that of the last queen's
speech if you strip away the bits that
are reheated leftovers they couldn't get
through the lord's last time
all the bits and pieces that are
scrapping eu regs is actually a very
thin speech paradoxically it's a scatter
gun of afterthoughts and it puts off all
the really big decisions
so when the prime minister the other day
had a go at our hard-working civil
services having a manana culture the
word translates and told us tomorrow he
seemed to identify his own government
the fact that they've been gripped with
putting everything in a kind of too
difficult for right now box
to be dealt with tomorrow so although
the words cost of living crisis were
included in the text the speech was
missing any big overarching ideas to
address the way bills are crippling
household finances from the weekly shop
to leaving the lights on heating the
house filling up the tank all of those
things and their answer to when they
might deal with any of the above or the
record inflation we've seen today is to
some ill-defined date in the future when
the problem we all know is now
and you know take the the flagship
pledge banning buy one get one free on
junk food
again kicked into the long grass
i don't know if that was because they're
not into the nanny state or it was nanny
he's gone now hasn't he it was nanny he
told them to do so whatever it is it
just reeks of timidity
and the whole thing is like a really bad
episode of neighbours where we've got
number 10 and number 11 at war with each
other the only thing they're agreed on
is if you've broken the law you can get
away with it you don't have to resign
and from the content of this queen's
speech you wouldn't know that we're in
the midst of a european war or that
we're coming out of a global pandemic
with a spluttering economy edging close
perilously close to recession or that
we're in a climate crisis
instead what have we got ideological
hobby horses and populist posturing a
higher education bill consisting of
student number controls and lifelong
loan in time entitlement this is more
dumbing down than leveling up
and then there's a freedom of speech
bill roundly condemned by and everyone
in the he sector that's what you get
when you've had enough of experts there
is a bill to curb insulate britain but
nothing that would actually help
insulate britain's homes
and you know with high streets
increasingly boarded up and turning into
cash deserts
it's shameful that food bank usage is
rocketing but in acton banks are an
extinct species and tsv is now gone in
healing which is you know going the same
way too
and faced with the crisis at home and
abroad what is the government's priority
in the middle of all this
to privatize the widely respected
channel four which costs us all not a
penny it's a solution to which there's
no problem it's condemned by prominent
conservatives like the ex-culture
secretary who's now the health committee
chair the right honourable gentleman
he's gone now the ex-deputy pm and
member for foxton so even their own side
don't like it it wasn't even in their
manifesto and it looks like revenge do
you remember they promised this when the
prime minister didn't turn up to the
channel for election debate and they
replace him with an ice sculpture
and we've now got a bill for bo that is
the brexit opportunities bill laughably
titled more dead ends and might have
been and more rewriting of history all
over so the prime minister trumpeted
removing v80 on domestic energy during
the referendum campaign his exact words
were when we won't leave we will be able
to scrap this unfair and damaging tax
the country obliged six years on in the
middle of an energy price uh crisis
nothing
then there's that manifesto pledge that
brexit would allow them to ban importing
foie gras which is so cruel to ducklings
and geese vanished all because the prime
minister is too chicken to do anything
about it
only one words but no concrete proposals
on fredfie hunting all our constituents
writing in their hundreds about these
things gone
and two years on since the promise of an
employment bill that sounded really good
didn't it employment rights flexible
working carers leave also disappeared
from the creed speech despite the piano
scandal bo
seems concerningly a handy cover to
euphemistically deregulate and scrap
protections in a race to the bottom of
singapore on thames which we know that
at least half the cabinet salivates for
and we now know that the plan is to
leave the european court of human rights
repeal and dilute your eu law bypassing
parliament it's all very fitting for a
government with an aversion to being
held to account
wasted time populist headline chasing
when we could be addressing the real
prices of the country feeling the pinch
the ft said it's red meat over real
reform a bunch of ill-considered
old-time unnecessary and nakedly
political measures flogging off that
great thatcher legacy channel 4
waging a trade war with the eu joining
russia only russia has done this before
quitting the echr
and
regulating street naming none of these
things i've knocked on loads of doors
over all these years every day in the
run-up to election nobody wants any of
this a normal person on a doorstep
yet nothing to tackle the climate crisis
or cut energy bills or make people more
secure at work or turn around our
struggling economy none of the stuff
people desperately need with the roller
coaster nature of this government that's
prone to new jerkism and tearing up its
own manifesto commitments rather than
thinking through problems on this
occasion this ostensible blizzard of
bills but ultimately too little too late
queen speech without a queen
although i'm pleased to see hrh was on
crossrail yesterday and and she's been
enjoying the horses recently uh sorry um
hrh has been an able stand-in but what i
would say is maybe we can all agree that
her majesty will deliver many more
addresses from the throne starting with
as soon as possible one from our right
honourable friend the leader of the
opposition when we retake the reigns
bring it on
crispin
thank you mr speaker i draw the hat
suspension tonight entry in the register
and rise to give general support to this
uh queen's speech
um there are areas where i'm uh
particularly enthusiastic there are one
or two areas where i'm uh i have a
little note of warning for the uh for my
uh uh for my whips um but
i thought the tone of the uh honourable
lady for uh ealing central and the uh
rhino gentleman for for the ronda was
just um rather surprisingly wide of the
mark um
uh in their remarks which were
uh that was just a little ungracious in
regards to the gracious speech i think
um to say as in the case of the uh
oliver jones for the rwanda that this
queen's speech lacks content and doesn't
really have a theme
this is explanatory notes for the uh
leveling up and regeneration bill um
talk about substance
where he was complaining there are bills
that would be no more than clauses in
other bills um this thing has 11 parts
all of which could be very substantial
bills um in other cases and
it recognizes
that the reputation of this
administration is very much going to
depend whether by the next election
we have put in place
uh the path to actually delivering
delivering leveling up and regeneration
in practice
um and that those parts of the country
that lent us their vote
in 2019 are going to convert that to a
rather more permanent arrangement when
they see this administration actually
beginning to deliver in a way that they
have not seen um for decades so this is
the most
important center of the
legislative programme
and by and large it will have my
my full support
there are also within it specific
opportunities madam deputies speak
around a genetic uh technology bill
championed by our absolutely marvelous
science minister
which open up potential opportunities
for growth in our economy uh and for
investment in
science and research
where the united kingdom should take the
opportunities to establish a
global leadership in in this space
the northern ireland troubles legacy and
reconciliation
bill
as a veteran although i do not serve in
the province of my time in the armed
forces um i think is is a product of
long consultation and a wise reflection
to try and find the right balance to
deal with the difficult issues uh
engaged uh the social security
end-of-life bill is to be welcome to
recognize uh long periods which people
now have to
live with the prospect of knowing that
their lives are going to enter extend
benefits from six months to 12.
the public order bill is i welcome in
general to hold these people to account
who are just intent on disrupting uh
society
um but in its content i slightly uh feel
we may have missed an opportunity of
imposing criminal sanctions on these
people why not civil sanctions
if they are determined um to go to the
greatest trouble for the greatest number
to impose cost on our public services
and costs on people who have been
disrupted by their activities in a in an
unfair way um as regards uh what the the
cause that they're trying to promote um
i think we should have
explored uh civil sanctions um uh rather
more uh carefully
um because
if people with resources are then going
again stick themselves to the road um so
people's travel arrangements are
disrupted or
tied themselves to the top of
underground
trains um
there's then a specific uh
opportunity for
uh
restoration to those people who have
been
inconvenienced by them and i think as a
great supporter of restorative justice
i think we should be trying to widen the
spread of this within
the justice system more widely to hold
people accountable
for their actions obviously against
those people who they uh who they uh
damage
uh obviously i welcome the inclusion
immigration speech of the conversion
therapy bill
um
however it uh it's not obviously it's
not yet been presented to the houses but
we're continuing to be uh to being
drafted we might hope to see it uh
before we rise for the uh for the uh for
the summer recess
and i would just very gently say to my
uh right honourable friend the prime
minister that
uh
it may be easy to make a
uh
a
a slap quip over um
the leader of the opposition's expense
about laughing what a woman looks like
but he perhaps doesn't need to look very
much further than project to see this
question can be just a little more
complicated um
than a first glance might suggest
um which is why i think that gender
identity
should be included with an escape of the
conversion therapy uh band bill and i
will certainly be uh lending my support
to the colleagues on all sides of the
house who will be
working uh in that direction to make
sure that this is a proper uh conversion
ban and it protects um
that protects
both people around sexuality and gender
identity
on the boycott
bill
where there will be legislation to
prevent public bodies engaging in
boycotts that undermine community
cohesion
i understand the purpose of this
however
um i think we just need to be a little
careful here i'm afraid i
uh i supported the amendment uh previous
in the last session that uh my
honourable friend for uh right honorable
friend from newark um uh around sarah
and and that was an error of judgment on
my part not paying sufficient attention
to what
uh uh
uh to what what the what what the
business was
um and i don't tend to repeat that
mistake uh if this boycott measure comes
back
and is designed to take away from people
the the ability where a nation is in
gross breach of international law of
being able to make their own statement
about what they believe about the policy
of of that nation and obviously the
nation in question is israel and
obviously the community cohesion that's
being thought about is uh is
anti-semitism within communities and i
fully appreciate the uh the uh the
concerns of the government on this
but if a nation is in grace breach of
the fourth geneva convention has invaded
and occupied territory and then settled
it
um and is then killing journalists
in that territory observing what is
going on in there
we might just want to reflect on what
capacity there is in our society to say
we don't think that's right
um and our ability to say so
um notwithstanding the obvious uh uh
issues surrounding uh anti-semitism that
are uh that are associated uh in that uh
in that area
um
uh
on finally madame deputy speaker on the
northern uh
protocol bill as it as it comes forward
i do think the statement we make about
the gracious speech and about our values
as a society about the values of britain
post-brexit
are incredibly important and we need to
be a nation that is going to stand up
for the rule of law that is going to
stand up for the
rules-based uh international system
to sustain our security and our role in
the world the enormous reputation of the
uh of the
the city of london and the commercial uh
part of our justice system where
countries from around the world come to
have that uh their company uh uh uh
disputes adjudicated under british law
in british courts are a huge credit to
our uh our country and our system and to
the fact that uh british law people are
in general trusted
uh i don't think we should be playing
quite so fast and loose with uh taking
the powers to overturn the protocol
until we have actually explored every
conceivable other option including
holding a european union responsible for
the consequences of an overly legalistic
approach and which i think will be a
better route
stephen killer thank you deputy speaker
the recent local election saw the
conservatives lose almost 500 council
seats across britain as the public
delivered its verdict on the
conservative government's performance in
westminster voters expressed their
dismay at the chancellor's refusal to
get a grip on rising inflation or to
offer family support through the cost of
living crisis
this gracious speech therefore provided
the conservatives with an opportunity to
reset to bring forward legislation to
meet three major challenges to rap
tackle rising household bills to start
growing our economy again and to build
that all-important resilience into our
economy that we require at a time when
hostile foreign states like russia and
china are on the rise
yet the conservative government has
offered none of this
which is why the entire gracious speech
has fallen utterly and spectacularly
flat
despite the opening sentence of the
speech containing a government promise
to help ease the cost of living for
families there was nothing of the sort
to be seen in the speech with household
energy bills rising by 700 pounds per
year and inflation outstripping wages we
needed a government that was ready to
tackle this crisis head-on
instead the conservatives are raising
taxes on working people
and in this they are an outlier no other
government is responding to this cost of
living crisis by hammering working
people with more taxes
the labour party has a clear plan
firstly we would scrap the national
insurance rise
then we would reduce energy bills by as
much as 600 pounds per household per
year expand the warm homes discount and
support those businesses that are
hardest hit
this would be paid for by a windfall tax
on the spiraling profits of oil and gas
giants who by the admission of bp bosses
themselves have more money than we know
what to do with and are effectively a
cash machine
but we would also look to the long term
in addition to these immediate crisis
management measures we would fix the
foundations of britain's economic model
because despite the government's latest
attempts to shift the blame
it is quite clear that the roots of this
cost of living crisis are not global
they are national
madam deputy speaker the reality is that
the chancellor is presiding over a high
tax economy
and the reason for this is that for more
than a decade the conservatives have
presided over a low growth economy based
on insecure work and chronic under
investment driving a productivity crisis
indeed britain has a 20 productivity gap
with other leading nations there's been
chronic under-investment by conserving
consecutive conservative governments in
research and development
but the impact of that is that there has
been a real investment shortfall in the
uk compared with europe by the private
sector
figures from the oecd show that private
sector investment as a share of gdp in
britain is the lowest of the 36 members
assessed
at the heart of the decline in
productivity has been the decline in our
manufacturing sector
since 2015 alone the government has lost
more than 230 000 manufacturing jobs
the result has been an increasingly
unbalanced economy in favor of london
and the southeast and proof that the
conservatives are not leveling up
they're leveling down
communities across britain's proud
industrial heartlands in the midlands
northern england and in south wales home
of my aberrant constituency in our
portal but steel works of which we are
immensely proud they're struggling to
get a look in
what we need madam deputy speaker is a
modern manufacturing renaissance
it's far easier to drive productivity
gains in the manufacturing sector than
it is in services
but this is manufacturing that's not
based in the old industries of the past
it's modern it's green it's high-tech
the industries of the future
and they are the industries that deliver
the good meaningful productive well-paid
jobs that you can raise a family on
and they are the jobs that will get our
economy firing on all cylinders right
across the uk
we need to get britain making and
exporting at levels that reflect our
true potential
this is why the shadow chancellor's
policy of make buy and sell more in
britain is so important a labour
government would change procurement laws
so that british government must buy
british by default
a labor government would introduce a
green steel deal creating a
world-leading steel industry to power us
through the century ahead and a labour
government would back one hundred
thousand businesses with start-up loans
to boost british smes
labour's plan to build a better coat
post-covered economy to drive growth and
truly get our economy firing on all
cylinders
with good jobs at its heart contrast
this approach to on our approach on
working good jobs that you can raise a
family on
with the conservatives axing of the
long-promised employment bill which was
expected to outlaw the type of dreadful
business practice we saw when 800 pno
ferry workers were sacked and replaced
by foreign workers paid less than the
minimum wage
labour would outlaw this practice
immediately across the board
ma'am deputy speaker modern
manufacturing renaissance will not only
help to boost growth and help us build a
vibrant modern economy for the future
it will also help us build that
resilient economy for the future at
britain that can stand on its own two
feet more firmly by backing british
manufacturing we can reduce supply chain
pressures caused by the behavior of
authoritarian states like russia and
china and by the kovid 19 pandemic
in this regard an energy security plan
is also crucial it is staggering frankly
that china owns 33
of the hinckley point nuclear power
station
madame deputy speaker there's too little
in the uk government's new agenda which
actually gets to the core issues the
underlying issues that underpin this
cost of living crisis
a wasted decade of low growth has left
us with a weak and insecure economy that
is ill-prepared for the challenges and
turbulence of an uncertain world
building that economy is the job of
government
politicians are not bystanders in this
the chancellor is not a victim
the tories have become the party of high
taxes and low pay because they are the
party of low growth
and the party of insecurity
we on these benches believe that britain
deserves better
a labor government would help workers
and families through this cost of living
crisis and deliver that resilient
growing sustainable economy that will
get our country fit for the future thank
you
sir edward lee
the honourable general avaravan attacked
us for being the party of low growth but
this is a party which has presided of a
situation where we have more people in
employment than ever before
and unbelievably the number of vacancies
are actually more
than those who
are unemployed
but he is right and this is why i'm
going to follow the honor general
abhiravan to focus laser-like on what we
are told to talk about today although we
are allowed to stray a bit to this queen
speech debate and that's what the
british people care about and that is
achieving economic growth so in time we
can have an interesting debate about
channel 4 privatisation about frog
and about conversion therapy but these
are not the overwhelming priorities of
the british people at the moment
what they are concerned about is the
cost of living crisis now there's never
been an easier opportunity
for the opposition to attack the
government in terms of broad economic
statistics
but of course that ignores the fact
that when the at the time the last
general election took place we couldn't
possibly have predicted the impact of a
global pandemic or unbelievably
war in europe as a result of the cruel
tyrant putin trying to recreate
an old style empire
so the government no government i would
argue since the second world war has
faced greater challenges and i would
contend
that generally
the opposition has failed to provide any
substantial alternative polities
policies
which would have
greatly alleviated the situation with
regard to the war in ukraine or the
pandemic
now i am going to hold the government to
account however i want to hold them to
account on the tax burden
i think
given that families are suffering
and people are lying
awake at night desperately searching how
they pay bills we are in such a crisis
that we have to move
in a far more radical direction on the
overall tax burden this is a question i
put to the chance mix checker yesterday
in treasury questions
and i was quite pleased with his
response when i urges to be a priority
we are now facing the heaviest tax
burden since the 1940s
freezing income tax thresholds combined
with more inflation will push many
people into higher tax thresholds as
paul johnson of the institute of fiscal
studies said almost all workers will be
paying more tax on their earnings in
2025 than they would have been paying
without these parliament's reforms to
income tax nics
the rise in inflation projected to is
perspective to spark the biggest decline
in living stands in any single financial
year
so i do follow the honourable general in
calling for a for radical policies i'm
not sure i'm not against the windfall
tax but i'm not sure on its own if you
divide its receipts around every
household in britain it's going to make
a great deal of difference and frankly
the chance has to come back
to this house
in time for the budget or preferably
before and have a tax a cut in the
overall tax burden
the next thing i want to talk about is
the housing crisis if we're going to
kickstart the economy if we're going to
help our young people get into housing
we just simply have to build much more
housing
the number of dwellings
where according to building control
figures building workers was started on
site was 41 600 in october december 2021
that was a three percent decrease when
compared to the previous quarter a three
percent decrease when compared to the
same quarter of the previous year the
number of dwellings completed was 41 330
in october to december 2021 a four
percent decrease when compared to
previous quarters an 11 percent decrease
when compared to the same quarter a year
before
the fact is this is a crisis and what i
do welcome the queen's speech is the
government is honestly attempting to
find some way through planning controls
to try and get the housing we need
but we have to have a similar effort
that we had after the second world war
where harold macmillan was building 300
000 council houses every year we have to
really see this as an absolute and
complete priority
now the next thing i want to talk about
is that there's no point in building
more housing and this is a crisis we
need to address there's no point cutting
taxes at the same time immigration is
out of control
and the government really has to
understand that we simply cannot replace
mass immigration from the eu with mass
immigration from the rest of the world
and that's why these channel crossings
are so totally and that's why the home
secretary is right to try and address
them for all that's controversial
last week on the 9th to the 15th of may
607 migrants detected across 25 boats in
the channel the week before 28th of may
792 migrants 30 boats the week before
that 25th of april the first of may 254
migrants seven boats
this cannot go on we have to
build the houses
we have to control migration
we have to cut taxes we have to
kick-start the economy and the very last
thing i want to say although there's
been great criticism of the government
over the protocol we have to unite this
united kingdom we cannot have a
situation where there is no proper
government in northern ireland the fact
is the dup are not going to come back
into government unless we deal with the
protocol of course we want to and i say
this to the honorable gentleman for
rygate of course we want to respect
international law we have to sort this
out
so
these
issues that we're now facing are really
urgent
really
important and i just urge the government
to have a and i'm sure they're our
listing
to
address them in the sort of dramatic way
that we would that we were trying to
address issues following a world war
because the effects of the pandemic and
the effects of the
war in ukraine are so grave that we
should all unite together with a sense
of compassion to help
the people who are suffering now under
this level of inflation on this level of
rising costs and on this level of rising
taxation
clive lewis
thank you madam deputy speaker um
i stand today i'm like the honourable
member for mid beds not as a conduit
of god
but as a heretic
shaking my metaphorical fist at the
crumbling edifice of economic orthodoxy
debates today's debate title achieving
growth really does beg the question
to what end
because for more than 70 years
successive governments have primed
themselves in the mirror and admired
what they saw
growth
that mirror is better known as gross
domestic product and it has become
our key metric for judging how beautiful
we are as both an economy
and a society one we use to gauge
progress and as a proxy for our
collective well-being and yet
the mirror we've been staring into all
these years is less of a bathroom
variety
and more of the fairground reflecting a
distorted image at odds with the reality
many of our constituents have confronted
over those long decades
growth madam deputy speaker
is an illusion one that is partly
responsible for driving three key
challenges we now face
rising inequality the erosion of
democracy
and the climate crisis
so let me turn first to inequality in
the past 12 years we've had gdp growth
albeit sluggish growth and hence by our
main metric of choice our collective
well-being should have increased even if
only incrementally that's the logic of
the message we in this place tell our
constituents you've never had it so good
because the economy is growing and yet
by focusing on growth we all too often
evade the hard political political
questions
about
distribution because if the economic pie
is growing then the proportional size of
the slice
matters less
but it's still an issue that gnaws away
people's sense of fair play
back in 2016 during a brexit brexit
debate a remain campaigner told his
audience if we leave the eu
gdp gp will fall
he was of course if we've seen
correct but that's not the point
i wish to make the point is the heckle
from the lady in the audience that came
back that's your bloody gdp
not
ours
because she knew that for millions like
her the proceeds of growth were never
fairly shared
that when the economy grew the
overwhelming beneficiaries of that
growth were the rich and powerful not
her
and even when it was growing but not
fast enough for its main beneficiaries
it was the public services that she
relied on that had to be discarded again
in the name of economic growth
which lead us on to the second great
challenge of this century defending
democracy not just from external threats
like russia but from within
why
because if people do not see the reality
of their lived experience reflected in
the political discourse of their
politicians
do not hear see their reality being
discussed in this place then that gulf
is dangerous because citizens end up
believing they are being deceived and
nothing nothing is more dangerous or
destructive to our democracy we must
understand our constituents buy into any
political economy depends not just on
their absolute wealth but rather on
their relative wealth to those
around them
and has been as has been repeatedly
demonstrated the more unequal society is
the less satisfied its citizens will be
resulting in political instability
higher crime rates and higher levels of
mental health illness and we wonder why
demand for mental health services is
going through the roof in this country
but let's for the sake of argument park
both democracy
and inequality to the side for one
moment and let us ask ourselves this
question how do you square unlimited
growth
on a finite planet it's a fair question
but one that never gets a remotely
convincing answer
apparently it's through increased
resource use efficiency and productivity
gains the global
the global economy will in the next
half of this century triple the number
of people to 3 billion who would enjoy
western levels of consumption
that's despite the fact that the 1
billion us of us already consuming that
much are using 1.6 times more of the
planet's resources
than is sustainable you can do the maths
in other words the growth delusion is a
fallacy that will drive climate and
ecological destruction
and kill us all
because only in the warped reality of
our current growth obsessed economic
model is expansion without end
seen as a virtue
in biology it's called a cancer
madam deputy speaker bobby kennedy knew
this truth more than 50 years ago when
he made his now famous speech on the
limits of gdp growth as a metric for
success he understood gdp is mercenary
blind to morality indifferent to
suffering gdp growth loves pollution
especially if it has to be cleared up it
relishes crime especially if more
prisons must be built and it delights in
war especially if countries require
rebuilding in the aftermath
that doesn't mean there is no place for
gdp as an economic tool but if we had to
successfully face the existential
challenges of this century then we need
new political tools for measuring
well-being the health of our democracy
and the ecological and climate cost of
our economic activities
mark palsy thank you uh madam deputy
speaker and it's a pleasure to follow
the honourable gentleman for norwich
south who addressed the
topic of today's debate achieving
economic growth by seeming to argue that
economic growth is not only not
important it's not desirable and i
wonder therefore whether he'll be having
a word with his front bench who seems to
have spent most of the afternoon
criticizing the government for not
delivering sufficient economic growth
but that's a that's
that's a mess of utter for him um it's a
pleasure uh madam deputy speaker to uh
take part in today's debate to uh to
address the issue uh a question and to
raise one or two uh points about the
the queen's speech and the delivery of
successful growth will be delivered
through the effective role of the
private sector it's the private sector
which are rather wealth generators and i
was delighted that the chief secretary
in his opening remarks uh accepted that
reality and currently both the economy
generally and individual businesses
face exceptional challenges challenges
that haven't been
encountered
for generations and those are a revolve
around first of all the recovery from
the covid pandemic and right now uh
addressing the issues that arise from
the conflict um in ukraine and the
impact that that's having on energy
prices but i recently spent uh a really
interesting lunch time with the
local chain business of chamber of
commerce at coventry and warwickshire
and whilst i was expecting them to talk
to me about supply chain problems i was
expecting them to talk to me
about the challenges that are
presented through inflation but the
biggest single issue that they wanted to
talk to me about was ensuring that they
had a workforce with the right skills
and the recruitment and retention
of their staff now
we've heard from many people and not
least the member from south east between
two spoke about the jobs miracle
and the ons tells us that unemployment
is the lowest since 1974
and job vacancies are at a record high
of 1.25 million in fact we've got more
vacancies than we have uh people
looking for work and the unemployment
rate is now just 3.7
the again the lowest for 50 years and
the figures for my constituency tell
exactly the same story with unemployment
levels falling and vacancies rising but
that presents
real uh challenges for for
businesses and the effect of staff
shortages
we will recognize as customers as
consumers
short stuff businesses don't have the
time to
respond to
the phone to enquiries there is a
decline in service levels but very
significantly for both the businesses
and the broader economy as a whole
opportunities
are missed and in previous years madam
deputy speaker uk companies were able to
look uh to eastern europe to
fill vacancies when they had staff and
skill shortages
but following our departure from the
european union
that has become
less uh of an option and
one of the issues that the businesses
raised with me was the loss from the
workforce uh often arose because of uh
covid uh
that
people were
over between the 50 to 70 age
demographic
either lost or left their jobs during
the pandemic and i think one of the
issues governments should focus on is
how we might consider getting these
experienced uh back uh
back into the workforce there's been
lots of references to the to the ons and
their reports and the os uh brought out
a report in march 2022 just a few months
ago entitled the over 50s lifetimes
lifestyle study which looked at the
motivation of 50 to 70 year olds leaving
employment during the pandemic and found
that 77
of those aged 50 to 59 left sooner than
they'd expected or intended to
19 left because of stress and mental
health but the 58 percent would consider
returning to the workforce and 15
percent actively want to return and if
they do return to the workforce 36
percent would
consider a flexible attitude to working
most important and 69 percent would want
to work part-time and i really do think
it's important for government to
consider ways in which we might make
getting these people back into the
workforce because they're able to make a
contribution on the one hand and they
have
valuable experience and i saw an example
of of these kind of people in the
volunteers that i worked with
in delivering of the
vaccine program
so the demand exists within the economy
and
but it's not able to be fulfilled and we
need to put uh the the the two together
um in respect of issues relating to
business uh
one key thing that is important
in achieving economic growth uh but
through uh attitudes of investors
customers suppliers and the workforce is
that it's important to be able to
understand the true state of our company
of a company and i note the government's
interest in restoring trust in our audit
and reporting systems uh through our
corporate government system as the
member of the bay select committee we've
looked at audit and i was disappointed
to see
that the audit reform bill in the
queen's speech remains only in draft
form
and i i do want to see swift action to
ensure that the full bill comes to the
house as promptly as possible we've got
the dominance
of of the big four we've had
many reports three independent reviews
as well as the work
by the select committee and i do want to
see
government
making sure that there's a transparent
apparent and effective ordinance system
is is uh or is introduced there are uh
plenty of reports calling for change and
we've had events at carillion patricia
valerie thomas cook piano ferris
and bhs we we do need to rectify that
and i i hope that that will be incred be
brought forward um in terms of growth of
course it's important to see that growth
is equalized
across the country and the leveling up
provisions are incredibly
important one of the things i do want to
see within the planning system is to
make certain that adequate as an
adequate supply of land is made
available for business that's a an issue
in my constituency we're at the centre
of england we're an ideal location for
the logistics businesses
that want to serve the country
but the
land is very rapidly taken up and
i'm very concerned that even now many
local councils have no up-to-date local
plan and instead of relying on waiting
for applications to come in and
development control
i do note some of the provisions in
respect of uh local involvement um but i
think that the current neighborhood
plans are too bureaucratic and
long-winded
and take too long to implement and and i
do note
trying to get
more
involvement in planning issues and the
principle of street referendums but i'm
very uneasy about those proposals i fear
that they may become a vehicle for
disputes between neighbours and i think
government will have a real challenge in
defining what constitutes the street
um in respect of new housing uh
the housing supply is a vital part of
economic growth building houses
themselves or an economic activity and
of course new housing provides uh a
housing for workers and the member for
gainsborough uh reminded of that in his
remarks a few moments ago
in my constituency we've got probably
one of the best examples i think we'll
find in the country of delivering new
housing at volume
through our sustainable urban extension
to rugby called holton
which is being developed by a master
developer urban and civic who has much
greater control of the over the
activities of the house builders they
see themselves and i see what they're
doing as creating communities as well as
building homes and it's vital that we
provide the infrastructure first and
then rugby that means we've got a link
road to the main urban community we've
got both primary and secondary schools
delivered early and the challenge now is
for us to get the health care provision
to come along at the same time and so
they're i'm very proud of what we've
achieved in rugby and there is a great
deal in terms of development there
madam deputy speaker i'll conclude by
noting that there are many provisions in
the queen's speech that will support our
businesses that will enable growth and
development to take place
i really hope we can manage without a
formal time limit but that means that
that i have to ask colleagues to stick
to about six minutes i mean six minutes
and 20 seconds is okay eight minutes is
not really
liz savile roberts
uh an honor to follow the member for
rugby and his his broad critique of the
queen's speech
but of course
today's inflation figures add to
mounting evidence of
uk
stagflation
and the conservatives 12-year record of
failure let's remember this has been 12
years this party's been responsible for
the economy 12-year record of failure to
deliver
an economy that delivers
well-being for people across the united
kingdom
and from the banking crisis to the
present day the conservative party have
sought out every opportunity to impose
austerity
to bring about a hard brexit of their
own making
which together
have combined to aggravate the uk's cost
of living crisis yes there have been
other causes
and those causes have been beyond our
control or the government's control or
possibly any government's control
but
these are ideological choices which will
go down in history
as tory creations
out of ideas other than to centralize
powers they don't possess and blame what
they don't know
the conservatives sit on their hands as
the economy for which they are
responsible
fails to work for households and
businesses across the uk
firstly the leveling up and regeneration
bill does
nothing to correct past mistakes or
deliver for the future
welsh government has stated that this
government's post-brexit funding
arrangement for wales falls short
by 772
million pounds of structural funds alone
for the period 2021 to 2025. this isn't
only an assault on welsh devolution and
that's labour's minister for economy's
words not mine
but a broken election promise more
broadly sources including bloomberg
illustrate a failure to maintain current
standards
let alone deliver any improvement
across most of the uk
and especially across wales
now this is not what was promised on
page 15
of the welsh conservative 2019 manifesto
and it said that no part of the uk loses
out from the withdrawal of eu funding
and it certainly isn't what's promised
on page 29 where it was said that wales
will not lose any powers or funding as a
result of our exit from the eu
three years into this government and six
years on for brexit this government
cannot articulate or deliver any clear
benefits to wales instead we need an
honest funding settlement
devolved engagement and focus on
delivery rather than glossy
announcements other elements of the
queen's speech give pause for thought
too
rather than correct wales is under
funding from hs2 of over 5 billion
pounds
wales gets instead wait for it
great british railways
instead rather than work with transport
for wales our own publicly owned
transport body it seems that
westminster's solution to historic
underfunding is to override our solution
while not correcting the underlying
public problems that need fixing
put bluntly
this government's approach to a
difficult difficult problem
is to stick a union jack on it
and sing a song of praise to past
glories
nostalgia does not an economy make
madam deputy speaker plaid camry drove
the creation of the development bank of
wales
yet its future and how the new uk
infrastructure bank will work
will
rather than over the devolved
institutions are yet to be unclear we
don't know how what we are operating
what we are doing for ourselves to
improve the economy of wales how that
will align with what is being done here
that is not good government of course
i'll give way
and of course in scotland we have the
scottish national investment bank
already up and running already working
and nothing from the government and
exactly how that will interact either
with their plans
and this lack of working together does
not help anybody's economy
now this queen's speech does nothing for
the basics of the welsh economy all to
address the ongoing cost of living
crisis regarding the latter i reiterate
black henry's call for emergency budget
and measures including a win win full
tax increase energy bill support and the
expansion of the rural fuel duty relief
scheme for wales
regarding the queen's speech obvious net
zero but alas missed opportunities
include the devolution of the crown
estate and the establishment of a welsh
national energy company to support local
renewable generation and fix grid
capacity
measures by the way which play community
have agreed with labor in wales through
our cooperation agreement where i would
say that it is good to see politicians
working together for the common
interests of all the people in all our
communities rather than in conflict and
i must ask this government somehow or
other to address the shortage of grid
capacity because for many areas of wales
without further grid capacity we cannot
grow our own renewable supplies and make
the best of that opportunity
westminster's refusal to countenance
legitimate devolved proposals to boost
our economy scorns our democratic voice
and emphasizes how until we have full
powers over our future we will always be
treated as second best
simultaneously mocked
for seeking handouts
and told to be contented with handouts
but for the immediate the immediate
crisis i hope the chancellor will indeed
address this with an emergency budget or
whatever he chooses to call it
including measures like a reformed sme
tax relief in wales to boost
productivity as a first step
and i also hope that the uk government's
wanted british nuclear great british
nuclear will work with and learn from
wales's company aguina which is already
in existence and already at work to
develop the nuclear license site at
transformath
and to close them it seems that
where there is a problem
the uk government's answer is to cobble
together a uk branded institution a
wallpapering over the self-perpetuating
vortex effect of research funding public
investment and targeted tax relief that
keeps the south east of england within
the pale
and the rest of england's regions
northern ireland and the nations of
scotland and wales to remain as always
beyond the pale of economic privilege
kevin hollenrick
thank you mom mr speaker
it's a place to speak in this debate and
um
i'd like to focus uh my reacts really on
the
um
and the work of smes in terms of driving
economic growth for me they are
absolutely often in this place they have
the engine room of economic growth more
than anything else
taking a step a step back from that the
most important thing in driving economic
growth the foundations of that are
productivity of course which leads to
prosperity
is more competition
competition is very good for opportunity
but it's also very good for consumers
it drives down prices and drives up
service so absolutely we should look at
competition in my view my experience in
business when we started our business
back in 1992
um where we estate agency business um
so uh we quickly got to a leading market
sharing our marketplace and we're doing
quite well and in two or three years
time we noticed lots of other um for
sale bars popping up all over the place
and select boards and new competition
came in it was taking market share from
us we suddenly were no longer the the
new kids on the block the people who got
number one we've been pushed off our
perch as the market leader and it made
us look at what we were doing and become
more efficient more effective worked
harder and put a new package dealer so
we could once again become market
leaders and this is the effect on in
competition the driving force behind all
those benefits for consumers we see from
competition that's how it works in
reality
um
well very briefly yes i thankfully i
remember giving away that point and i
think he's made a point about
competition can i ask him uh what
competition drives um
energy water and rail they seem to be
natural monopolies if i'm not mistaken
so perhaps you could tell me how the
free market and competition helps drive
down prices in those sectors
interesting because energy distribution
was very competitive in this country if
you remember a huge expansion the number
of energy distributors which led to
driving down the prices very very
effectively whether they got caught out
of course is the huge increase in
in wholesale costs which drove lots of
those people out of business but that
was an excellent example our competition
does work and drives down prices for
consumers increases choice so like but
that's a good example in terms of energy
people who produce source energy
i agree with it there's not enough for
those big producers which is why we've
got to be careful when when one or two
big
companies dominate the marketplace
it was gk chesterton who said
too much capitalism isn't too many
capitalists it's too few capitalists
and that's why we need to focus on
competition make sure that the
environment is uh very uh attractive to
new businesses starting up and growing
smes and that's why all our policies to
me should focus on small businesses not
on big businesses they can generally
look after themselves
a couple of issues we have already in
terms of
and we've got to look at the brutal
facts when we look at this i'm afraid
and i was a bit disappointed as i said
earlier in terms of the governor of the
bank of england when he was talking to
the treasury select committee about some
of the issues we're seeing in
labour shortages which is driving
inflation second inflation we weren't
looking at some of the issues smes
particularly experience in terms of
accessing labour because net migration
in 2020 the the year we have reliable
data over has dropped by 88 into the uk
from 271 000 people down to 34 000
people net migration now that is people
say that's a good thing which ones that
get hold on immigration and some of that
may be curvy defect but nevertheless for
smes if you're you're on a pub or
restaurant or you're a farmer all these
are smes generally they're finding life
very very difficult so we've got to make
sure there is an available supply of
and the other issue we've got in terms
of um
is red tape at the borders non-tariff
barriers they might be called and that's
causing problems particularly for smes
and we need to make sure i think it's a
45 reduction in the number of smes
exporting
to the european union those are facts
we've got we've got to confront and
we've got to deal with
in terms of um where we need to go in
terms of leveling up which is of
interest to me particularly
being
representing the north
from the north and further north making
sure we level up properly and make sure
the opportunities spread nationwide
equally it is a huge undertaking
the relative gap between eastern between
the northeast and london the southeast
in terms of productivity per capita
in relative terms is as wide as it was
between east and west germany prior to
reunification that took 30 years and 2
trillion dollars to narrow that gap this
is the long haul it's the right thing to
do but it's a long haul we need to get
the private sector to invest that was a
lesson from east germany get the private
sector to invest so certainly things
like eis and seis equity investment to
smes vital that's due to it those are
due to expire in 2025 we need to see
those measures extended i would also
like to see actually enhanced tax breaks
for eis and scis
into businesses in
the
less
less well-off parts of the country is to
attract more investment capital into
those areas
um and the final thing i'm saying
probably the last last minute i've got
um mr speaker is one thing that could
make a massive difference lots of smes
in this country will not borrow
73 percent of smes would rather grow
more slowly than borrow part of that
because the lack of trust between small
businesses and big banks
in other parts of the world where they
have something called regional mutual
banks germany is a good example they
expanded lending during the financial
crisis the uk were contracted lending
during the financial crisis about 20 on
either side regional mutual banks lend
more into the economy at the key times
this could be a really good policy of
driving smes forward in our regions
thank you very much madam deputy speaker
and it is indeed a pleasure to follow my
honourable friend the member for first
and morton and speak this queen speech
marks my fifth in this house in this
relatively short time we've had two
prime ministers brexit a global pandemic
and now a brutal cost of living crisis
yet one fact
has remarkably stayed the same this
government's inability to rise to the
challenge
has stayed the same
and they have not risen to the
challenges faced by ordinary brits and
sadly mandatory speaker this government
drafted queen speech follows the same
disappointing pattern failing to grasp
the severity of the situation millions
of people across our country face at
every turn the absence of any real help
is an insult to hard working people the
experts are clear over 1.5 million
british households will soon face bills
for food and energy which will exceed
their disposable income after housing
costs inflation is now at its highest
level for 40 years at 9 and that is set
to soar
very soon to over 10 and alarmingly
growth is forecast by the bank of
england to be negative next year but
beyond these statistics are people many
honorable members have already
eloquently highlighted the real life
struggles their constituents have faced
and sadly slough is no different i've
had constituents tell me that they have
been forced to cut down to one meal a
day
or had to wear extra layers of clothes
in their own homes
so what is stopping ministers from
acting for example with a one-off
windfall tax on energy companies it
seems that instead of taxing big energy
companies which are posting extra
profits in the billions the chancellor
is more intent on taxing ordinary people
who are now inflicted with the highest
tax burden since the 1960s and even when
people are at work they can't expect to
be offered adequate protection
874 words and not one mention of workers
rights no employment bill as promised in
their own election manifesto and yet we
live in a time when this is more
important than ever
insecure work inadequate wages and
unscrupulous tactics from bad employers
instead government ministers go about
telling workers to work more or get
another job but not to get a decent pay
rise it's absolutely absurd and where
government has decided to legislate it
has completely missed the mark their
priorities madame deputy speaker are all
wrong on crime in particular four queen
speeches and three manifestos yet the
victims bill still exists only in draft
of little use to the thousands of
victims of crime unable to benefit crime
is up and prosecutions are down to
record lows
number of arrests has dropped by 35 000
but victims
and
communities like mine are still
suffering the huge cuts to sloughs local
youth services funding by this
government a real terms cut to school
budgets community safety funding cut by
40
by 2024
even though our crime rate is 28 higher
than the rest of the southeast and 27
percent above the national average this
government's queen speech offers nothing
to address all of this
when it comes to housing but i'm deputy
speaker despite almost an extra 1
million people in private rented
accommodation it has taken this long to
see the renter's reform bill but whilst
there's slow progress in some areas
there's absolutely no word on the
promised 300 000 homes to be built every
year by the mid 2020s a lack of detail
on the decent home standard and no
mention of the lifetime deposit and
frustratingly five years on from the
deadly grenfell tragedy far too many of
my slav constituents still remain
trapped in flats with unsafe cladding
with fire defects with no end in sight
so this queen's speech simply fails to
address the problems ordinary people up
and down our country face because the
benches opposite don't fully understand
the everyday realities for hard-working
people and where is the ambition to
decarbonize our economy our public
transport system to insulate our homes
to accelerate the transition to
renewables where is the annual rolling
program of rail electrification annual
targets for more rail freight huge
investment in green industry jobs what
is a government for if it's not
protecting people prioritizing
privatizing channel 4
over help helping families with
household bills
street referendums or extensions over
investing in youth services arguing over
what human rights to scrap
instead of delivering a properly funded
state pension
it's written by a government out of
touch and out of ideas so i implore upon
ministers madam deputy speaker to see
what is so plainly around them
and do something about it to help the
millions of struggling brits because if
they will not address the serious issues
facing our country they should just step
aside for those of us who will thank you
very much speaker
kate griffiths thank you madam deputy
speaker
i refer members to my entry in the
register of members interests
it's a pleasure to speak in this debate
on the gracious speech in the year of
her majesty's platinum jubilee
i welcome focus on strengthening the
economy and achieving economic growth
that this queen's speech provides after
the huge impact of the coveted pandemic
on all sectors of the economy
leveling up local infrastructure is key
to securing economic growth and i
welcome the steps that the government is
taking to invest in our nation's
infrastructure and transport links
burton and utoxide sit within the
manufacturing heart of the country and
the a50 a500 corridor is home to both
national and global brands including jcb
toyota nestle rolls-royce and many more
and they rely on this vital link for
connecting to international markets and
trade around the globe
in order to support economic growth new
jobs and better connectivity for
business and for my constituents vital
improvements are needed to this corridor
recently midlands connect published
their report the road to success
outlining suggested developments to the
corridor which would see the creation of
over 12 000 jobs and generate 12 billion
pounds for the economy
further these improvements will see
commuters likely to get back three and a
half working days a year by 2050 when
driving through the central section of
this corridor uh where the junction at
utopster has been identified as a
priority element of the strategy
as the project champion for the
improvements to the a50 a500 north
midlands manufacturing corridor i am
looking forward to continuing to
champion this and making the case for
economic growth that these improvements
will bring not only to my constituency
but the wider economy
as well as improving infrastructure it's
vital that we continue to level up our
towns and i welcome the government's
continued commitment to this important
strategy
i was delighted that burton was awarded
23.8 million pounds as part of the town
deal fund to deliver transformative
regeneration for the town
this includes reconnecting the town
centre to the river trent making it an
attractive location to visit live and do
business and i'm also pleased that we
have the chance to submit a bid for the
second round of the leveling up fund
complementing this investment of the
town deals fund and completing the
transformation of the high street for
generations to come
i look forward to following the outcome
of the local consultation and
discussions around how we can continue
to level up burn and utopster and i hope
this is a priority one area the town's
bid will be favorably received as it
looks to deliver on that vision for
levelling up
of course one of the key industries in
burnley nutoxide is the brewing sector
and i was pleased to welcome
staffordshire based businesses to
parliament recently
this was ahead of statutory day and is
to promote the fantastic local
businesses and producers including
molson calls who recently invested 25
million pounds into their burton site
a sign of their commitment to continued
innovation in the great brewing town of
burton
breweries and the wider hospitality
sector have been hit very hard by the
impact of the pandemic and the current
rise in the cost of living
during the pandemic the chancellor
reduced v80 on hospitality goods and
services which was a huge benefit to
businesses in my constituency
however
disruption to these businesses is still
being felt and i take this opportunity
to urge the government to reconsider the
proposal of the long-lived the local
campaign for a permanent hospitality vat
rate of 12.5
this would generate an additional
turnover of 7.7 billion pounds and an
additional two hundred eight six
thousand eight hundred and fifty jobs
over ten years
i welcome this queen's speech and the
government's ongoing commitment to
leveling up and supporting economic
growth and i look forward to continuing
to support opportunities for investment
across burton and utopsita such as the
vital improvements to the a50 a500
corridor that my constituents elected me
to deliver
yes on correction thank you madam deputy
speaker
i was very disappointed in the gracious
speech
as it failed to deal with number of
things which really mattered to my
constituents and i believe to the
country at large
first and foremost and we've heard this
mentioned many many times today
the cost of living crisis
which is clear
inflation is nearing 10 percent
economic growth revised down
slowest recovery in the g7
interest rates up and rail wages have
fallen below 2008 level
the impact of this of my constituents
and people across the country is huge
they're having to choose between heating
and eating a phrase that's been used
quite a lot today
but these choices are real
not imagined as some members on the
opposition would like to suggest
this government is refusing to help
these people
why
i'm not trying to be controversial here
but perhaps fundamentally certain people
in the government don't care and they
hold the ordinary people in contempt
why do i say that
or where does this rot start from
the current prime minister in 1995
penned an article in the spectator
claiming
that working-class men
are likely to be drunk criminal
aimless feckless and hopeless
did he stop there no
he said the children of single mothers
are erased ignorant
aggressive
and illegitimate
it's been like the pot calling the
cattle black
one my ass well perhaps the prime
minister just one bad apple
wrong the current deputy prime minister
the secretary of state for business the
home secretary
and the foreign secretary
co-authored a pamphlet in 2011
which claimed
the british are the most
among the most idlers in the world
well i would like them to come to bolton
southeast and tell that to the care
assistant the cleaners the retail
workers who are often working more than
50 hours a week on minimum wage just to
make end meet and see their reaction and
what they have to taste it is
and then we had a home of his minister
on the morning round a couple days ago
saying well people can move to better
paid job or take on more hours to
address the crisis
well in my constituency they're not many
better paid jobs and everyone's already
working more than they need to do
and then of course we have the member
for actual claiming people can cook
meals for 30p
and implied poverty was a choice but can
i say to him as somebody who actually
cooks quite regularly i can tell you
that you can't get a meal for 30p even
when you're cooking at home
and people in my constituency have
bolton southeast many have been written
to me feeling very insulted and saying
that they can't actually afford to use
their avons because of the energy cost
so i say it's frankly insulting to my
constituents
there is another option though
a real plan to fix the cost of living
crisis
in the first three months
shell has made five billion pounds in
profit
and bp has made
seven billion pounds in profit
that has been made to us the consumers
being charged
the labour party has constantly asked
for and has been pushing for a windfall
tax on oil and gas companies which so
far seems to be falling on deaf ears
and this would be a real fund a sport
package for working families not 150
pounds which is going to be is a loan
being given which people will have to
repay
we've also suggested that the levels
paid
the vat on the energy bills should be
removed
we said the universal credit allowance
should be increased a benefit
which i know the government thinks that
somehow it's all for those people who
are not working in fact many of the
people who receive universal credit
allowance are actually people who are
working but they pay so low that they
still need to rely on state benefits
and by the
reduction of the universal credit
allowance of 20 per week it's affected
14 000 of my constituents
it was a really very important piece of
benefit that they had
and then of course we've asked for
warmth homes discount which would help
towards that as well in keeping energy
bills down
but yes of course
i thank my honourable friend for giving
way and she's making an excellent and
very heartfelt speech which i'm sure the
whole house is listening to intently
does she agree with me that part of the
problem is that many of our poorest
institutions live in some of the worst
insulated houses and it's a virgin need
that we tackle this problem
absolutely right and of course their
situation is exacerbated by that often
they have damping their homes as well
which has not been sorted out
yet the government keeps saying they
refuse to act and they've wronged
because they said well they there's not
money for it
but
we know the 39 billion pound weighted on
the track and trace
which the same system in france cost
only about 3 billion to roll out so the
money is there if there's a will to use
it
there's also nothing in the budget
that will lead to better infrastructure
of trams and trains in my constituency
there is nothing about building more
social housing and affordable housing
especially the use of brownfield site to
fulfill the housing shortages
and on the renewable the government says
we're interested on it we're interested
in climate change
yet they could be real investment which
the labour party has again argued which
would create good jobs and of course
eventually to us having redundant
dependency for energy supplies to other
countries as the ukraine war has shown
this was a missed opportunity
to deal with many issues including the
foremost about living crisis
this government has refused to do that
and as far as i am saying i would say
they really don't care about my
constituents
paul hall
thank you madam deputy speaker i'm
pleased to follow the member for bolton
southeast
but i'm sorry that she like others have
chosen to misrepresent the member for
ashfield
and actually suggest that she goes and
listened to what he actually said
i'm pleased to be able to speak today in
support of the queen's speech on our
final day of debate from the opportunity
to discuss achieving economic growth i
spent my entire career in manufacturing
businesses before becoming an mp in 2019
and i firmly believe in the power of
economic growth and investment to change
towns and the lives of people in them
in order to do so it's important to
encourage both the physical and human
assets that are necessary to sustain an
economic course ecosystem
it's also critical the government
supports all people through the cost of
living challenges and i'm confident our
chancellor will deliver on this in
cohesion with his cabinet colleagues
i know that earlier in the debate the
member for leeds west indicated that
their windfall tax proposal would
benefit 33 of people with 600 pounds
but the member for wolverhampton
southeast as apparently said the rest
would also get 200 pounds
so whilst the indicated tax receipt of
three billion they propose to spend
eight
they either disagree with each other or
its classic labour maths and
misrepresentation
can i just say in my opinion
we are facing a living crisis i don't
care whether it costs 3 billion 8
billion the government needs to bring up
the money to look after those people
of course the government needs to look
after those people
and madame deputy speaker and we need we
will do that and the chancellor will do
that in a cohesive manner with the rest
of his of the cabinet but we must focus
on the importance of resilience
particularly for our national assets the
past two years have demonstrated the
fragility of supply chains and the risk
of geopolitical instability impacting
customers in the uk sorry consumers in
the uk
we need to increase
the use and use some of our newfound
brexit freedoms to ensure that national
strategic assets are kept in british
hands
economic growth and leveling up go hand
in hand
speaking as co-chair of the appg for
left behind neighborhoods i'm convinced
we cannot have the latter without the
former and that's why when making
spending decisions the treasury should
emphasize creating new business clusters
in left behind areas
of course for this to happen we need to
have a skilled workforce in the area and
that's why i think of all the bills in
the queen's speech the one that will
have the greatest economic impact on
areas with historically lower levels of
economic growth will not be any of the
legislation sponsored by bears or the
hype or the treasury but rather the
higher education bill
the northeast is already on the right
track my constituency is fortunate
enough to be surrounded by five
universities
all of which do excellent work to the
north we have of sexual we have
northumbria university which has done
particularly well recently leading from
number 50 to number 23 in the latest
research excellent framework ranking
together with durham university they are
well on the way to creating a northern
research powerhouse further enhanced by
the complementary provisions of
newcastle sunderland and t-side
universities
this bill seeks to improve standards in
education generally and the aspect of
which i'm most excited is the provision
of the lifelong lawn entitlement
guaranteeing four years of post-18 study
which will allow more career flexibility
for those who haven't undertaken any
further or higher education ensuring
they have the chance to get the
education to work in skilled industries
but we also need to enhance the broader
opportunities for people through
supporting t levels and engaging more
utcs like the utc and south durham in
newton aircraft as well as ensuring the
opportunities exist for those who have
had further education in the past would
now want to redirect their talents
one of my primary focuses i deliver on
is shouting up for the businesses in
sedgefield whether they are the
science-led extraordinary businesses in
netpark
the substantial employers like gustam
pitachi crafters companion or 3m newton
aircliff or the murray out of smaller
enterprises in the industrial state are
spread around in places like trimdon
chilton fishburne winged wheatley hill
thornley or furry hill
all of these matter they all need
encouragement
on friday i'll be talking at the make
your mark award at the cliff business
park
meeting businesses i've seen before like
husqvarna still as ebac roman and
gestamp but also the newcomers the
apprentices the innovators and the
environmentalists
we have such a variety in diversity and
we need to encourage each and every one
of them
they need to know that government
strategy supports them whether this is
delivering infrastructure like bringing
train station back to fury hill or tax
breaks for capital investments it's all
part of the mix
developing clusters rarely happen
organically usually they are the result
of a strategy that coordinates
investment in an area
these strategies must consider the
appropriateness of sectoral support as
well for example as part of our draft
region at zero by 2050 the government is
rightly keen to support investment in
electric vehicles an ev strategy for
example therefore has to support new
businesses looking to work on evs and
help existing companies adapt their
current output to them
whilst i would always be supportive of
furthering with investment considering
how much expertise and jobs the
established companies tend to have i
think the good
the government would do well to focus
its primary efforts on them
another part of this strategy that led
by the member for mid norfolk with his
focus on science and innovation
i would encourage him in his support of
the northeast space hub as part of the
coordinated national approach to space
but particularly directly to the asset
base we have in sedgefield in
considering promoting the semiconductor
industry
we have everything from two six as a
major manufacturers through to events
philtronic caromac isacom northern space
and security and pragmatic ic without
interrelated clusters in the areas of
advanced material electronics
resilient communications and space
the development of clusters to support
uk resilience founded on existing
platforms of enterprise can be
transformational in the leveling up of
places like sedgefield
whilst the minister has been to netpark
he and his colleagues were very welcomed
to visit more of this extraordinary
supply chain which would also enable
them to see the fabulous cultural offers
demonstrated in the outstanding county
durham bid for the city of culture and
the proposed leveling upgrade that will
enhance the living environment for so
many in newton necklace
i encourage our pragmatic chancellor and
an innovative pm to deliver on these
bills but also to remember keynes when
he said what do you do when the facts
change
i change my mind
we are in an ever-changing world and we
need to remain as flexible as possible
yeah
stop it
mari black
thank you madame deputy speaker now for
a party that prides itself on the
economy the tories have a shocking
record of running it
our economy has the slowest growth in
the g7 we have got greater regional
inequality than almost any other
developed nation
food banks now do the job of government
and providing for families families that
are more often than not in work
government could start
solving this crisis by providing
solutions like closing uh tax avoidance
loopholes or creating a windfall tax for
energy companies
but instead
we get
endless bills paying lip service to a
manufactured culture war
the priority isn't the economy it seems
to be things like protecting freedom of
speech and yet
the tories are the one that have banned
schools in england from using sources
that are not overtly pro-capitalist
they're cracking down on freedom of
assembly and protest
they're privatizing channel 4 when the
culture secretary didn't even know that
channel 4 receives no public money so
the argument isn't financial and as the
member for ronda
touched upon earlier on when we
considered that the culture secretary
was a key focus of a channel 4
documentary ones about the influence
that christian fundamentalism has over
uk politics it becomes even more
concerning that this decision is
political and it's personal
it is not professional but most
terrifying of all madame deputy
is that this government literally want
to get rid of the human rights act
and that begs the question
for who do they think rights have gone
too far
do you know how scary it is to sit at
home and wonder
if it's you
is it your rights that are up for grabs
we've witnessed one rush
we've our economic strategy is to open
our doors to the rest of the world when
we need their hard work and then chuck
them out 50 years later without a words
notice
we tell our own citizens that their
safety can't be guaranteed in rwanda but
we're perfectly happy to ship asylum
seekers people fleeing war and
persecution over to rwanda as though
their cattle to be dealt with by someone
else
and despite knowing that this plan costs
more than it will ever save
this
is just
little england elites
drunk on the memory of a british empire
that no longer exists
we have
the lowest pensions in europe
the lowest sick pay we pretend minimum
wage is a living wage when it's not
we miss our own economic targets time
and time again we're happy to break
international law
we are turning into a country where
words hold no value and over the last 12
years
i fear we are sleepwalking closer and
closer to the f-word
and i know everyone is
scared to say it for fear of sounding
over the top or being accused of going
too far
but i say this with all sincerity when i
say the f word i'm talking about fascism
fascism wrapped in red white and blue
and you may mock and you may disagree
but fascism does not come in with
intentional evil plans or the
introduction of leather jack boots it
doesn't happen like that it happens
subtly it happens when we see
self present no i've heard enough it
happens when we see that
governments making decisions based on
self-preservation based on
cronyism based on
anything that will keep them in power we
see the concentration of power whilst
avoiding any of the scrutiny or
responsibility that comes with that
power
it arrives under the guise of
respectability and pride
that will then be refused to anyone who
is deemed different
it arrives through the othering of
people
the normalization of human cruelty
now i don't know how far down that road
we are madam deputy speaker time will
tell but the things we do in the name of
economic growth the warning signs are
there for everyone else to see whether
they admit it or not
julie marson thank you very much madam
deputy speaker
it's a pleasure to speak in this debate
um and it's a pleasure to support the
legislative agenda set out in the
queen's speech by this government
when harold macmillan was asked what is
the greatest challenge facing a
statement he famously responded it's
events dear boys event
and it has to be said during my entire
time probably as in this place
we have been buffeted by events
extraordinary events frightening events
not least for our constituents up and
down the country and including in my
constituency of hartford and stortford
fear not just of the health consequences
of a global pandemic but also of the
economic consequences of that pandemic
on lives and livelihoods
and that pandemic is still having an
impact
across the globe notably in china
and the economic impact
of that
kovid resurgence in china in shanghai on
supply chains is also having a
devastating economic impact
we've also had to face
the evil and unjustified invasion of
ukraine by russia
not only have we imposed sanctions quite
rightly which this whole house supports
but that invasion itself has had its own
economic impact
the governor of the bank of england has
warned a treasury select committee this
week of the apocalyptic prospect for
food
prices but he also said very clearly
that 80 percent
of the the causes of inflation is due to
those global factors
and that makes government intervention
very difficult it is a very very
challenging
time and the cost of living crisis is
very challenging for any government that
is facing it it is being buffeted by
global events
and i have to reflect listening to some
very fine and impassioned speeches from
the other side
that i
cannot help but remember that if things
have been differently and if the
opposite side of the chamber had its way
the leader
talking to our nato allies and
shepherding
this country through this crisis
economic um and security crises would
have been the right honorable member for
islington north
and
chancellor who brandished the little red
book in this chamber so i believe very
strongly that we should thank goodness
that it is a conservative government
that has been shepherding this economy
and this country through unprecedented
back-to-back crises over the last few
years and who will continue to do so
this government in its shepherding and
control of the economy
has enabled us to support lives and
livelihoods for the past few years to
the tune of 400 billion pounds
and it continues to support people in
need with a package currently of 22
billion pounds including reducing fuel
duty
raising their national insurance
thresholds uh increasing the national
living wage and other measures
but the heroes of the pandemic
were our doctors and our nurses and our
key workers
the heroes of the future
in this global crisis will be
the business owners the workers in
businesses those who are innovating and
starting new businesses
now that is where the government's role
i see as i've said before in this
chamber is being of a groundsman
of of setting the pitch the conditions
for our bowlers and our batsmen to to be
able to respond to the difficult balls
but to the easy balls we knock them out
of the park but we are the groundsman
and that is where i see the context of
this queen's speech is putting in place
those conditions so that our players can
play the best game available
now that means as the chief secretary
set out dealing with skills innovation
and infrastructure all of those measures
are included within the queen speech the
leveling up and regeneration bill the
brexit freedoms bill data reform
financial services to support our
critical venture capital industry the
infrastructure bank bill the higher
education bill
this is a consistent
uh thought through package of
legislation which will deal with the
global challenges and our domestic
challenges for the years ahead and i
absolutely commend it to the house
[Music]
grant davis
abdul speaker um it's a pleasure to
follow the uh honourable member but
today we listened again to the prime
minister telling us we had a strong
economy
and yet of course when labour left
office there was simply 26 000 people a
year going to food banks now there's 2.6
million 100 times that number
we heard oh yes we've got a strong
economy there's 500 000 more people in
work
than before the covid pandemic but of
course according to the ons
there's
444 000 fewer people at work
because the prime minister conveniently
missed out the self-employed
he said oh we're the low tax party
but of course taxes are now
at a 50-year high the chancellor
increased taxes by 50 40 billion pounds
last year where a share of gdp which
hasn't been this that level since ashley
when we were coming out the second world
war and needed to charge those taxes
inflation is a 40-year high there's a
there's a departmental freeze on
spending so the savage cuts going across
the board
and i can see the secretary of state for
brexit opportunity and government
inefficiency living up to his name in
terms of the delivery of inefficiency
chattering away
the truth is of course that inflation is
helping
ironically the um
the government's revenues because
they've got a four year freeze on
personal allowances and tax thresholds
which i actually mean there's a sort of
creeping increase in tax uh as people
sink into tax thresholds and the
allowances in real terms go down and
this actually means that the planned
cynical attempt to drop tax before the
next election in 24 25 that tax increase
will they will actually be gobbled up by
that inflationary clawback and people in
fact will think they're getting a tax
cut but they will lose twice the amount
of that tax cut and is there an
alternative to this and the answer of
course is yes and where's the evidence
and the evidence is that in the 10 years
to 2008 that labor were in power the
economy grew by 40 percent and we use
those to protect the proceeds not to
just give them away but to double
investment in the health service double
investment education and bring millions
of young people and pensioners out of
poverty we bequeathed a debt
to gdp ratio of 45 percent it's now 90
percent a doubling of the share of debt
and in fact the institute of fiscal
studies that said had that trend growth
continued people would be
11 000 pounds better off than they are
today so they'd be much more resilient
to uh taking on board some of the global
shocks that we all can see whether it's
ukraine or covid or whatever it is
catastrophic mismanagement we saw from
2010 of course it started with osborne's
austerity that simply didn't work it
just drove down growth because people
were expecting they might perhaps be one
of the 400 000 people he said he was
going to sack we then had the sort of
stupidity of the hard brexit where we
decided we'd all be outside the single
market and there's no move now for
product realignment or a minimum amount
of a worker movement to allow
lower cost market access which is what
businesses want so a third of businesses
who've been exporting the eu are now
saying they won't do it at all so we've
got a low growth high cut high tax uh
cut in wages government it's complete
failure now the cr the answer to this
because the reason this isn't a windfall
tax i appreciate but let's understand
what a windfall tax is the oil companies
work on a marginal profit which is quite
healthy and then all of a sudden putin
invades there's an escalation in the
price and there's literally a massive
tax
profit over the cost of production now
they didn't do anything about that to
deserve that that is putin's profit and
the people here deserve that profit to
help them go through the hard times
we're going through because we're
imposing
sanctions and sanctions of course take
time the
the imf is saying that the sanctions
will cut russian economy by eight and a
half percent uh they won't stop a
russian tank and that war of course
needs to be won just to sort this
situation out but that's another story
we certainly do
uh need to increase productivity but
this reality is the ambition of the
chancellor is to bring the investment
per child in education uh in 2024 up to
the 2010 levels we had uh with labor our
young people need to be invested in now
this talk about you know everyone's got
to go back to the office
as we said to the the man on the front
bench oh we're all going to go back to
work in a traditional way but the office
of national statistics did this study to
show that there'd be a very considerable
increase in productivity and a delay in
people retiring if people were allowed
to work from home in particular
women in particular people caring in
particular people looking after families
could work flexibly and what's more
obviously if yeah i don't know one in
five days you were at home then you take
20 percent out of the congestion on the
roads
all the traffic of the roads you take 80
percent of the congestion out so we'd
like to spend less on roads and be
carbon friendly so
the whole approach in terms of
productivity in terms of a green
investment in terms of cognizance of
that is completely ridiculous macron has
said as italy has been saying germany
why don't we have a situation where we
can have a more collaborative approach
to trade
with uh britain and indeed bring in
ukraine because they share the same
values and again all we're doing is
starting a sort of trade war on the back
of what is a very sensible arrangement
namely that ireland should be in the
single market to protect the single
market i mean and obviously the people
you know that's what the government's uh
agreed and that's what we should
continue to continue with and finally
other than the economic catastrophe and
this clear solution
moving forward i have uh finally have
fears that there's also an attack on a
fundamental rights of democracy this if
you read the queen's speech there's all
this stuff about reducing the power of
an independent judiciary now we've seen
haven't we since obviously the
government's very angry with miller
because they gave us a vote on the deal
very angry with the judiciary allowing
you know
democracy to be reconvened after the
prime minister tried to to abandon it
for a long period of time so the supreme
court composition has been changed seven
of its key decisions have been reversed
it's been intimidated by the media and
ministers sitting there slagging it off
in particular the lord chancellor
supposed to defend it the average
ten-year-old chance there's no now one
and a half years used to be four years
he used to be a senior
a judge or whatever or judicial member
who'd respect instead of someone who was
just wanting to get to the next
ministerial position so the our
independent judiciary's under attack our
rights are under attack our democracy is
under attack and i respect the points
that were made by the member for paisley
uh and french south about the ruling
authoritarianism we see in terms of
poverty into the economy and the
democracy and what we fundamentally are
frankly we are better than this we
deserve better than this we don't want
low growth low cuts low wages we want
high growth a fairer stronger economy in
the future and let's roll forward and
deliver that with a labor government
mark fletcher
deputy speaker i just in reference to
the honourable gentleman's contributions
in regards to democracy you would think
in the current circumstances we would be
incredibly careful we cherish our
democracy in this country our
institutions are strong democracy
freedom and the rule of law runs through
the core of this country and to so
flippantly say that democracy is under
attack or that we as another member said
earlier that we are descending close to
fascism
only seconds after saying that words
matter is incredibly frustrating and i
would say i'm afraid the honourable lady
didn't give way to me so i'm going to
return the favor
if i could madam deputy speaker talk in
relation to this queen's speech which i
think actually helps to set out some of
the things that we we have needed to do
for a long time in this country when it
comes to economic growth and i'm
particularly referring to the leveling
up bill which i think from my
perspective offers several solutions to
bolsover and to a region uh which i
refer to the east midlands and to
derbyshire in particular a part of the
country that actually has struggled
since its former industry uh which was
coal mining
has reduced and actually what we've
needed to do for a long period of time
is find a new economic settlement and
actually
within that within those figures behind
our local economy we see a lot of
low-skilled jobs and low-wage jobs and
actually we are not reaching the
potential as a region that we can do and
one of the most indicative statistics is
that investment whether that be private
investment or whether that be public
investment into the east midlands is way
below other regions and one of the
options that the leveling up bill
presents us with is a devolution
settlement now over the last two years
in this parliament i've been very lucky
to be uh pps
to the secretary of state for business
and i've had insights into how various
colleagues engage with ministers here
and one of the most striking things is
actually that regional mayors work and
that actually they they work as a way in
which the private sector and indeed
government can engage with a particular
area and help to bring investment and
jobs and skills and education to an area
and unfortunately the east midlands at
the moment is fighting with one hand
tied behind its back when it comes to uh
competing with london when it comes to
competing with manchester the west
midlands south yorkshire and t side and
it is undoubtedly true that those mayors
are having a huge impact they are
becoming household names across the
country and actually in the east
midlands if you want to invest here you
will have to speak to at least one
county council you have to speak to a
district council at least one district
council you will almost certainly have
to speak to the lep or the local
enterprise partnership and actually it
becomes cumbersome if you want to go and
invest in the west midlands you can ring
up andy street's office and that is a
much easier process and actually andy
street can then pick up the phone to
whoever is needed and actually this
leveling up bill and within this queen
speech you will find uh various
solutions for powers to descend
downwards towards our regions and that
will empower us to create more economic
growth locally one of the other things
that i'm very pleased to see in this
green speech and indeed again within the
leveling up bill is around uh planning
because for too long the frustration has
been that where when
housing comes to bolzova it's sort of
either a salami slicing approach of five
or six new houses added to a village or
it is a huge new estate and you're not
getting the public services that need to
come with that the investment that needs
to come with that whether that is gp
surgeries whether that is a local school
we've actually had a problem in that
demand on those public services has gone
up and actually i think the planning
bill and the outline of it is very very
strong
and if we are looking at leveling up an
area light bulbs over you need to
improve education and skills levels you
need to be able to bring skilled jobs to
the area you need affordable and quality
housing and you need to be able to bring
in infrastructure that he's fit for the
21st century now there is a a a very
admirable line that they on public
transport that the government would like
to get the rest of the country's
transport connectivity much closer to
the standard of london's now i don't
expect that that uh balsava will be
getting an underground system anytime
soon and indeed i would suggest to the
transport secretary that we would just
accept a few new bus routes that
actually work and run beyond seven
o'clock in the evening but i do admire
the uh emphasis on ensuring that public
transport is there because two of the
groups that are most or sorry three of
the groups that are most impacted by
public transport are the elderly there
are the students and younger people and
indeed are those who are on low incomes
and actually it's hard to generate
economic growth without good public
transport and there's many things i'm
looking forward tremendously to the
schools bill because i think there are
many many positive things with that but
one of my great frustrations is that we
have no post 16 education in bolsova and
yet that requires everybody to travel
out but our bus services are not fit for
purpose and i will end madam deputy
speaker because i will stick to six
minutes unlike some others
i will end by saying that i very much
welcome the conversion therapy bill i
think the government will know that i i
think it needs to go further than where
it is at the moment and i hope that that
is something that does happen but i
would like to say that a number of
colleagues have fought incredibly hard
to make sure that this remains on the
agenda and i doff my cap to them because
this is an incredibly important issue
and something that we should put an end
to in the 21st century
margaret ferrier
deputy speaker the queen's speech
presents the government of the day an
opportunity an opportunity to stand back
take stock and realign their priorities
there are aspects of the new legislative
program that are welcome and aspects
that are less so most concerning are the
things that are missing from it all
together i'll start with levelling up
regardless of any personal views we
might hold about the intricacies of the
agenda or how it is implemented i'm sure
that most of us would agree that the
principle targeted and meaningful local
investment is not a bad thing each one
of us could point to projects and our
constituencies that would not only
deserve such investment but would return
on it tenfold
in my constituency there is an enormous
patch of derelict land at shawfield it's
been vacant for decades
opportunity wasted because the land
suffers from a very big problem that
until recent years nobody had the
patience nor vision to invest the time
and money it will take to fix it
the land is contaminated with the
carcinogenic chemical hexavalent
chromium if anyone here has seen the
movie erin brockovich they'll know how
dangerous this chemical is
remediating the site comes at a cost of
tens of millions
clyde gateway a publicly backed
community regeneration project that
generates profit through its work which
is reinvested to fund the new projects
has taken on this mammoth task
they've already remediated huge amounts
of the land but the majority is still
unusable
the location of the site is perfect and
clyde gateway have already proven
further redevelopments on the remediated
land that it is profitable it would
serve as an excellent hub outside the
glasgow city central boundaries for
businesses and residents alike i've even
heard rumors that the cabinet office for
looking at some of the remediated land
to house their offices
for me it's a no-brainer and i really
hope that the project is successful in
the leveling up bidding process it would
transform the local economy but it needs
vision and it needs funding
what i have found through my extensive
conversations with the executive
director of clyde gateway over the years
is that funding streams like the
leveling up port pose their own
challenges
while ensuring that public money is not
flittered away is vital
being too prescriptive stifles the
ability to access and use the money to
its fullest potential
i would encourage the government to
consider how different project types
like shaw field might be even more
successful and subsequently economically
beneficial to communities if funding
streams are more flexible in their
criteria
of course most importantly is a need to
make sure that the leveling up fund is
distributed equitably across the four
nations for the projects that will bring
the most economic value
i'm glad to see the government finally
bring forward the plans for community
access to cash an issue i have board the
treasury front bench details with i'm
sure that's the most vulnerable in our
communities that are the most reliant on
physical cash
and while we have exempt accelerated our
progress to low cash reliance
over the past two years it remains
essential that it is protected and ease
of access restored i look forward to
seeing proposals around the
sustainability of the atm system making
sure they are all free to use for
customers but not in a way that risks
the affordability of maintenance for
providers
i'm also interested to see more on the
measures announced on consumer rights
and protections and the economic crime
bill which is increasingly crucial a
time where people have less if any
disposable income
last week i spoke about safe hands
funeral plans and the devastating impact
the company's collapse has had when
victims who are facing losing thousands
they simply cannot afford to i agree
it's essential this area of our statute
groups is strengthened strong reforms
around limited partnerships and the role
of company's house are needed
i will reserve judgment on the efficacy
of the government's proposals just yet
though until the details become clearer
another bill i needed to see the energy
security bill it is high time and if i'm
honest too late that the government
looks to address the price crisis that
is hitting households so hard
over the past few months this issue has
been high in the list of reasons why
constituents seek support from my office
it has been so frustrating to see the
government offer so little to help the
millions struggling to keep up
it's not just households either there is
no price cap in place currently for
businesses and smaller ones are finding
themselves at real financial risk as a
result
the government advertise themselves as a
party for business they must do more to
back up that claim
there are quite a few bills that we'll
need to see in detail and as soon as we
can the brexit freedoms bill to tackle
retained eu law the bill of rights the
national security bill
and i said that i would come back to the
things that are missing and i will focus
on one but it is a big one
this year's queen speech skirted neatly
around the very large elephant in the
room an elephant that for some reason
the government are determined to ignore
at the very least they do not want to
make eye contact with it perhaps because
they know at the end of the day they can
leave the metaphorical room
everyone else though our constituents
the taxpayers and voters are stuck in
that room eye to eye with the elephant
every single day the room gets tighter
conditions worsen and the walls are
constantly closing in there is no
sunlight and seemingly there is no
escape
the government failed to adequately
account for the single biggest most
immediate and pressing crisis this
country is facing the cost of living we
are all acutely aware of it colleagues
and benches across the house will agree
that we're fortunate to not feel it in
quite the same way so many of our
constituents do
deputy speaker the only way to achieve
economic growth is to invest in our
people the government are not doing
enough of that and that is incredibly
short-sighted
thank you mr deputy speaker and it's a
real pleasure to take part in this
debate that over the last four hours has
ranged over the entire queen's speech
and it's been very interesting to hear
the members opposite both make the case
for tax rises and also for tax cuts and
i enjoyed the case of the uh the lack of
desirability of economic growth i set on
the camp for economic growth is largely
a good thing although not so without
some reservations in certain
circumstances and i sit on the treasury
select committee we take evidence from
economists uh from a whole range of
different economists the whole time and
the good news is that the uk economy is
fundamentally strong we have had too low
growth for too long that is true and we
are facing absolutely unprecedented
challenges as many people have referred
to we've had a pandemic and a war and
before that a global financial crisis
and the chancellor somebody earlier
described him as the unlucky chancellor
and that is absolutely true he's faced
greater challenges than any uh
chancellor uh probably since the second
world war and i think has dealt
admirably with the um
the challenges uh
thrown at him
it's true now that we have inflation at
a 40-year high and that is causing a lot
of challenges to a lot of households as
we've been hearing this afternoon but
that's not purely a uk thing but a
global inflation crisis and i just want
to put on record my continued support
for bank of england independence that uh
we had the governor of the bank of
england earlier this week
and uh we discussed it there there's
been various media reports about people
questioning this shows that the uh bank
of england can't be trusted inflation
that is not true the monetary policy was
never uh suited never aimed at dealing
with a global supply shock that we have
at the moment it's that is not the right
tool for that that does not mean that
the system we have for the bank of
england isn't working it's worked very
well over the last 25 years and the way
to judge it is whether we now it now
brings inflation back over the next year
or two back to the two percent
now one of the mysteries in economics is
actually at the moment and we have this
in our hearings in the treasury select
committee is actually how well the
economy is doing two years ago when the
pandemic started we had all these
apocalyptic now that was come back into
fashion uh all these apocalyptic
forecasts of how the economy we're going
to have the deepest recession ever that
unemployment would go back up uh to the
1980s levels up to 3 million or so and
in fact as various members have
mentioned unemployment is now at
historic low the lowest since 1974 and
for the first time ever we've got more
vacancies uh than people who are
unemployed and claiming benefit we need
to work hard to make sure those people
are unemployed get into those uh
vacancies and we still have obviously a
big budget deficit uh that is getting
managed down taxes are heading up and i
just want to say i'm also with my my
colleagues from epsom and yule and
gainsborough uh who made the case that
taxes are too high and come down i
completely agree that has to be the
medium term trajectory
um a lot of the debate this afternoon
has been about costs of living and and
uh i don't want to reiterate a lot of
the point points made so i'm going to
focus really on the title of the debate
which is achieving economic growth
and there's reasons for that a lot a lot
of the problems we face as a country
could be solved by higher economic
growth it leads to higher incomes and
that obviously helps the cost of living
and higher tax receipts and that helps
the funding tax cuts
and that's why i really welcome the
government's drive to promote economic
growth i keep saying this the priority
of the government now should be growth
growth growth the chief section to the
treasury highlighted earlier the
government's strategy of improving
skills infrastructure and innovation
and i fully support that and many of the
measures needed to promote economic
growth are obviously fiscal
related taxes and reserve for a budget
rather than the queen's speech and for
example in the spring statement the
government outlined its ambition to use
tax cuts to promote business investment
and those measures will be then enacted
in the autumn budget and again that is
very very welcome
now there are many measures in this uh
queen's speech and this gracious speech
that will drive up national productivity
in the medium term or longer term
education reforms investing in skills
that other people have been talking
about transport improvements reforming
the planning system all those will help
promote economic growth but i want to
focus my comments on the bills aimed
directly at businesses which actually
not many people have been talking about
this afternoon but there are 38 bills in
there in the queen speech and many of
them are directly related to business or
specific uh industries so the digital
markets bill is most welcome the almost
duopolistic grip that google and
facebook have on electronic advertising
is not good for businesses it's not good
for competition it's not good for
innovation or indeed consumers
google frequently reforms its algorithms
in ways that are detrimental to ordinary
businesses that rely on online
advertising forcing them to pay for
expensive adverts if they want to reach
their customers but it also sets itself
up in competition with businesses in a
way that shows a clear conflict of indus
interest and damages innovation so for
example if you google cheap flights to
new york you it will directly direct you
to its own flight comparison service run
to independent companies such as sky
scanner or expedia
it is absolutely right to give the
competent that the government will give
the competition markets authority powers
to protect consumers ensure the
integrity of digital markets and stock
market abuse by dominant players but
this is a fiendishly complex area
and this law will only work if the new
digital markets union unit in the cma is
properly funded and can offer companies
salaries for highly skilled staff so the
staff aren't immediately poached by
industry in the same way the financial
conduct authority can offer sufficient
pay to make sure that it's its staff
lured by the city
the uk infrastructure bank bill long
overdue i used to work at morgan stanley
investment bank which does a lot of
infrastructure finance and not only is
it often very complex but there are
limits to the risk that any private bank
can take on with these massive projects
it needs the power of the state to
arrange suitable financing
when i worked at city hall in london i
was involved in sorting out the finance
for crossrail or the elizabeth line
that's now known i really look forward
to writing it next week london was lucky
enough to have the highly skilled
finance team at transport for london to
help arrange the financing for this 20
billion pound project but most
infrastructure projects don't come with
highly skilled finance teams pre-formed
like that we need to leverage different
forms of finance including attracting
private investment and there's a clearly
defined role for the uk infrastructure
bank but like my comments on the digital
markets unit and bill the proof will be
in the delivery and it's essential that
the uk infrastructure bank can operate
independently from political pressures
but also is funded in a way that it can
attract high quality staff
now the non-domestic rating bill
the business rate system is of course a
massive source of massive complaints of
business often very justified it does
need modernizing this bill will do that
but can i just float one little thought
um that actually a there could be a cap
on business rates to 10 of a company's
declared turnover which should help
startup companies and a lot of smaller
businesses without damaging revenue from
larger companies i'm sure the devil will
be in all the details there but i think
it's worth the treasury considering the
genetic technology built very big in my
constituency i've got probably more
genetic and genomic companies than any
other constituency
this is a huge opportunity for us a
brexit opportunity quite possibly this
is not about genetically modified
organisms it's gene editing which is
very very different it's speeding up the
breeding that happens naturally
electronic trade documents bill we
should have done this before can't
believe it requires legislation this
will slip through parliament quickly the
audit reform bill one of my members one
of my
honourable members did mention this i
think it's probably only one of them
this is everyone in finance knows
there's a major problem with audio it's
always been in the two difficult box or
two complex box so i just don't
understand the box thank god it's
actually being addressed now we need
that to stop the series of scandals uh
that have happened as a result of bad
order procurement bill i was heavily
involved in procurement when i worked at
city hall and the eu rules that we
inherited on public sector procurement
they're horrendously over engineered
stop abuse across 28 different countries
28 different uh cultures to procurements
and so on and there are severe
constraints on effective and efficient
public sector that often the government
can't deliver uh what it wants to do
because of procurement rules and we
absolutely need to streamline them and
finally uh the financial services and
markets bill this is a huge piece of
legislation and we've been looking at it
a lot in the treasury select committee
and i look forward to uh taking part in
to build the debates when this comes
through this house
it's the uk's dirty secret that we had
far more influence on the eu's financial
services legislation than any other
member in the eu and so actually eu
financial services legislation is not
that bad overall but compromises were
often made and it meant that in a lot of
ways it wasn't appropriate for a global
financial centre like the uk and there
are many reforms we can make that will
really help our global competitiveness
but there are real issues for parliament
here
it's right to give regulators more
powers absolutely rather relying on
everything being in primary and
statutory legislation but that means the
regulators have to have more effective
scrutiny parliament is not currently set
up to do that and we need to agree on
how we can more effectively hold
financial regulators to account so
overall the queen's speech has a very
wide package of measures to promote
business help consumers and drive up
economic growth and i strongly recommend
it to the house
thank you madame thank you mr deputy
speaker and today i just want to focus
on three key issues the first being the
cost of living crisis which is the
number one issue facing this country my
constituents in coventry northwest have
suffered months of skyrocketing fuel
bills soaring inflations and heights at
the petrocomp this has sadly been met
with a carefree response from this
conservative government whose policies
are pushing many below the poverty line
this crisis has been hitting my
constituents hard since last summer yet
the government is still not adequately
supporting them
when i surveyed hundreds of my
constituents recently a massive 88
said they did not expect their income to
keep up with rising energy bills
despite this none of the 38 bills in the
screen in the queen's speech outlined
offered any specific or effective
measures to tackle the cost of living
crisis
this is why this government must accept
labour's plan to introduce a windfall
tax on gas and oil companies who have
imported who have reported record
profits
and this will go a long way in providing
up to 600 pounds
in terms of cuts to energy bills per
households i think it's really important
this government wakes up finally to the
urgency of the crisis that we have on
ground
secondly mr deputy speaker i would like
to speak about planning roles
new housing developments and the impact
this is having on certain communities
across the communities of holbrooks
orsley cursely and easton green in my
constituency of coventry northwest
many of my constituents have real and
heartfelt anxieties about the impact of
large-scale new development and its
devastating impact upon green belt land
for years now i have heard constituents
warning that the current planning rules
are not fit for purpose and they
currently serve developers agreed and do
nothing to listen to local voices and
those most impacted
in coventry this means that the wrong
type of housing housing is being built
and those houses are being built in the
wrong part of the city and eventually
they are going to be sold at an
unaffordable price so from start to
finish it is an absolute mess and it's a
broken system
tens of thousands of new homes have been
imposed on my city of coventry in recent
years against the wishes of residents
and elected members
equally
the rules concerning new development do
absolutely nothing to guarantee the new
homes will come of the necessary added
infrastructure so that means large-scale
housing housing is being built
without
the back-up
infrastructures that are needed such as
decent public transport good quality
broadband connectivity improved roads
green spaces and extra local services
such as schools
and gp surgeries
what we've heard so far mr deputy
speaker from the queen's speech does not
go anywhere near far enough of really
reaching the key issues affecting my
constituents what they are are just mere
gestures towards a more democratic
planning system which will not fix the
problems in coventry or elsewhere quite
frankly across the country mr deputy
speaker the last issue that i would like
to speak briefly on is healthcare and
the future of our beloved nhs
our nhs
is struggling to keep up with increased
and more complex demands and it's
finding it increasingly difficult to
clear the backlog created by the
pandemic
take our ambulance services for example
in the west midlands ambulance services
are receiving more 999 calls than at any
time in history
simultaneously
our region is facing crippling ambulance
shortages
in my own city of coventry just days ago
a woman suffering from a heart attack
had to wait two and a half hours for the
ambulance to show up
this is heartbreaking and it cannot
continue to go on
however mr deputy speaker this is only
part of the problem
health services in the community are
also our breaking point following
successive conservative governments
failures to recruit more gps and roll
out additional gp surgeries
every morning dozens of my constituents
are waiting on the phone line often for
up to an hour just to try and book an
appointment with their gp
too often
when they finally get through to
somebody at their surgery they find that
all the appointments are booked up or
that the next available appointment is
not for wheat
so the government has already although
the government has already admitted that
it will fail to fulfill its pledge to
recruit six thousand extra gps by 2024
and that these shortages are making life
extremely difficult for many of my
constituents frustratingly there was
absolutely nothing in the queen's speech
to tackle the health crisis
labor however has a very clear plan that
we would make reducing waiting times and
boost staffing numbers in our nhs a top
priority in government so until this
conservative government understands this
this problem will not go away
on
the subject that the queen's speech did
outline one subject that the queen's
speech did upline actually was about
women's health
but like so many other critical issues
women health got empty words yet no
concrete promises
the inequality
many women face concerning healthcare
continues to be appalling so for example
more than half a million women face
horrendously long waiting times for
gynecology care
the government has repeatedly promised
to prioritize addressing women's health
issues with a long-awaited women's
health strategy but they have failed to
deliver this strategy again and again
it was meant to be delivered by
christmas last year this never happened
and we are still waiting five months
later for the women's health strategy
if this government generally
wants to do the right thing by women's
it must urgently publish a comprehensive
and intersectional women's health
strategy until then
it will continue to fill in its duty to
provide world-class health care to every
woman in this country
quite frankly this tory government has
been in power for more than 12 years now
yet they appear to have entirely run out
of energy and ideas whether it's the
cost of living crisis housing or health
care the government's
first to deliver the government is first
to deliver a sound bite but last to
deliver lasting changes that people of
this country need
mr deputy speaker this screen speech
this screen speech should have been an
opportunity to address some of the more
many complex challenges that we face
instead it was yet another demonstration
of this government's disinterest in
delivering for my constituents
my constituents are coventry northwest
and the people of this country frankly
deserve so much better thank you very
much the wine ups will start no later
than 6 30
so six minutes please i'm not imposing
the time limit but you'll be really
unfair to who's coming last if you don't
if you do more than ever
yeah thank you mr deputy speaker it's a
a pleasure to uh to follow
our honourable colleague from coventry
north west typically punch in political
speech with much to disagree on
where i would agree i suppose
with my colleague across the chamber is
the diagnosis of the current issues
facing the planning system and and
development
i think there the agreement stops
because i'm actually very optimistic
about the proposed solutions taken to
democratize the system
and make planning more transparent and
fairer i think there's much more work to
do to get stuck into the detail
but i think optimism trumps pessimism on
this account and planning and
development is not the only challenge
that this country faces of course we've
we've dealt with many challenges the
biggest challenges facing our country in
living memory um and it has been the
innovation
um of our people of our government of
our businesses that have got through it
i think the honourable member for
for rugby who's uh not currently in his
place but uh intervened earlier to to
point out that private sector innovation
is key to an unlocking economic growth
the subject on which we're speaking this
afternoon um but government innovation 2
has helped us get through the crisis
the unprecedented furlough scheme the
brilliant kickstart start scheme
all
put together in an interventionist
targeted interventionist way has helped
us become the fastest growing economy in
the g7 and build back better so as we
move forward i'm glad to see that this
innovative thinking has continued
through her majesty's gracious speech
more importantly it's this innovation
that will drive up skills and economic
growth in my constituency in milton
keynes north truly putting us on the map
as the silicon valley of europe
now i understand mr deputy speaker that
this is a bold claim to make
how can we compete with the tech giants
of the us
however it would be unwise to
underestimate the people and the
businesses of milton keynes it is milton
keynes where we have a proud record of
harnessing innovation entrepreneurialism
and creativity to tackle the challenges
of the modern world
we're home to many exciting
technological innovations such as
driverless car trials and so we welcome
the transport bill and the unashamedly
pro-technology approach that the
government is taking
the transport bill will truly
revolutionize the way we travel bringing
the benefits to the environment and to
people for those who are vulnerable in
our communities who struggle with
mobility or with their sight
self-driving vehicles will be
transformative connecting them to the
outside world and ensuring their
independence
and with the uk market
set to be worth around 41 billion
by 2030 and that's 6.4 percent of the
global market so we can have a bigger
slice of that pie it is vital
that the united kingdom leads the way in
the development of this technology
transport bill i think will be the first
step to doing that however
if we are to truly look towards the
future i hope that this legislation
can go further
mr deputy speaker those that have
visited milton keynes or indeed heard me
bang on about milton keynes in the last
few years will have seen or heard of our
much-loved starship robots buzzing along
our streets
delivering our groceries
delivering food delivering coffees
even
delivering beers to a barbecue if you
happen to run out of beers in my
experience
now they may be small in stature but
they are mighty in the positive impact
that they have not only do they support
local businesses but they have helped to
solve the problems of the last mile
delivery the most expensive and the most
carbon intensive part of the supply
chain
these robots have helped remove nearly
400 000 kilograms of carbon from the
atmosphere and have taken over three
quarters of a million miles of car
journeys off the roads in milton keynes
so
may i encourage the minister to ensure
that the scope of the transport bill
supports and enables the expansion of
companies like starship
bringing us closer to our net zero
targets and our ambition to embrace the
technologies of the futures yes
if we hope to see this technology in
action and to be a success we need to
ensure that we have the skills and the
jobs to sustain it the best way to do
this is through investing and leveling
up our education whether it is through
the school's bill or the lifetime skills
guarantee it is this government that has
provided people of all ages and
backgrounds with the right opportunities
to succeed
while it is right that we provide the
opportunities i also urge the government
to consider investing in the
institutions that will be able to
deliver the teaching of these vital
skills we need to teach the skills for
the jobs we can't even conceive yet
institutions like milton keynes
university a pioneer in the education
field mku represents a new approach to
higher education one which is designed
with business for business to give
students the skills and the knowledge
they need to meet the needs of our local
economy both now and in the future
degree apprenticeships in robot
engineering or cyber security may seem
alien to some of us now in this house
but it is these graduates that will be
leading the charge in future years
with this in mind i implore colleagues
in the treasury to consider the case for
mku more thoroughly as it will transform
our economy at both a local and a
national level
mr deputy speaker i truly feel that this
will be a critical year for milton
keynes as we are expected to have one of
the uk's fastest growing economies over
the next two years but to maximize this
growth we must invest in skills
technologies and the institutions of the
future
thank you mr deputy speaker and it's a
pleasure to be called in my first queen
speech debate
the prime minister likes to pose as a
man of action
but where in this queen's speech is the
bold and transformational action needed
to tackle the most pressing and urgent
crisis facing people across the country
the cost of living as we've heard many
times over these last few days
families in my constituency of batty and
spen don't want vague promises of help
to come sometime maybe they don't want
to be patronised and told that things
will be better in a few years time
they need an emergency budget now with
immediate help to reduce their bills
along with a plan for growth that offers
them financial security in the long term
people struggling day to day and week to
week are being let down by a government
that is presiding over a low growth high
inflation high tax economy
a government that talks about leveling
up but in reality is hammering our
communities down with an even greater
financial burden that shows no sign of
easy
hardly a day goes by without one
minister or another on our tv screens
showing just how out of touch they are
with the people of this country
people facing real hardship unable to
pay bills skipping meals turning the
heating off relying on food banks to
survive
all of which is taking a real toll on
their mental health
i've been contacted by suicide
prevention organizations in my
constituency who are busier than ever
indeed i've just been to a very powerful
event with mr speaker and the brilliant
band new order organised by my uh friend
the member for bristol east as today is
the 42nd year anniversary of the tragic
suicide of ian curtis
but what do ministers say to people who
are struggling
try and get a different job
work more hours or eat own brand food
unpaid carers and people on fixed term
pensions can't change jobs or do an
extra shift and the government adds
insult to injury by writing off 11.8
billion pounds in fraud and error
well it was their error not our
constituents
it's insulting it exposes their own
inaction and it shows their total
inability as a government to put in
place an economic plan that can work for
all the people of this country
because whilst the poorest households
have been at hardest many families who
until recently thought they were
reasonably secure now also feel
incredibly vulnerable
a serving police officer in my
constituency got in touch with me
recently
he's on a decent wage but due to the
huge increases in essential outgoings by
the end of the month he faces the
prospect of not being able to afford to
put petrol in his car
he searches the aisles of the
supermarket for yellow stickered
discounted food for his kids and they
share bath water to cut down on costs
when he gets to work he sees the wider
impact of the crisis with the soaring
number of emergency mental health
incidents he has to attend
and he is not alone
a family of four with both parents in
full-time employment emailed me scared
for their future
they're struggling and through no point
of their own no fault of their own
they're relying on credit cards and
facing a battle just to reach payday
what hope are we offering them and their
kids
nothing today
and the prospect of their already tight
family budget being stretched to
breaking point by inflation and wages
failing to keep up with rising prices
on this side of the house we believe in
putting in place the urgent steps needed
to provide an economy that allows the
benefits of higher growth and investment
to be shared by all not just the
privileged
an economy based on fair taxation where
loopholes are closed and those who make
huge profits while their customers are
hit with even higher energy bills like
the producers of north sea oil and gas
are asked to contribute more something
they say themselves they're ready to do
i'm not anti-business far from it but we
need a fairer economy that brings good
jobs into our communities and puts pride
back in our towns
but this queen's speech did not provide
the vision the ambition or the
foundations for an economy that will
work for the people of batli and spen
and the people of this country i will
always try to be fair to ministers
opposite although they don't always make
it easy
there were bills in this queen's speech
that addressed some important issues
such as online safety victims schools
and mental health and i look forward to
debating them in this chamber
but until we address the most pressing
issue of the day
the highest inflation and greatest
pressure on living standards in a
generation we are letting down our
constituents when they need us most and
widening the economic gaps that are
holding our communities back
that is why i am calling on this
government to take some action show some
urgency and show some compassion
to tackle the very real cost of living
crisis so many of our constituents are
facing
chris
thank you uh mr deputy speaker it's uh
it's a pleasure to contribute uh into uh
in this debate this afternoon to
follow the honourable lady for battling
spend mr deputy speaker i'd like to
reserve my comments in respect of
achieving economic growth in respect to
the rural areas of the united kingdom
and i would particularly like to
advocate so for my constituency of west
dorset
the queen's speech contained a number of
very welcome bills
the leveling up and genera and
regeneration bill the transport bill the
procurement bill and importantly to the
animal welfare
kept animals bill
west austin is a very rural constituency
it's 400 square miles
30 percent of the population is over 65.
one in twelve is over eighty
eighty five percent of all of our
funding comes from local
local taxation
and two thirds of our council tax goes
to support those needing social care
it's
constitution constituencies such as mine
that have a really strong requirement
for regeneration and leveling up in a
way that sometimes uh this house doesn't
quite recognize
the default view of some places in
dorset is particularly well off but i
can tell the house that actually it is
in many parts uh far from it west dorset
is in as much need as anywhere for
leveling up especially so as that we
were one of the few authorities to have
zero in the revenue support grant yet
have one of the highest council tax
rates uh in the country
i'm particularly pleased that the brexit
opportunities minister is at the
dispatch box at the saturn i was
delighted to welcome him to west dorset
just a few weeks ago to talk about some
of the challenges and difficulties
in west dorset 97 of our businesses are
small or micro sized
the pandemic was very harsh to us
six and a half thousand very small
businesses existed before the pandemic
five and a half thousand are there now
therefore i was delighted
to learn from
the minister that actually the
procurement bill will help those very
small and micro sized businesses to tap
into the procurement system that for far
too long
has been held back from access from
smaller micro-sized businesses because
of bureaucracy or because of european
rules
and legislation such things as approved
supplies lists and so on will i
understand be
reviewed and i think it will mean
an enormous amount to rural
constituencies such as mine with such a
high proportion of small and microsized
businesses
mr deputy speaker many in this house
will know that before i was elected in
2019 i worked for the railways for 20
years
that's one of the reasons why i'm
delighted to see the transport bill
featuring in the queen's speech
bus and rail services have also been a
contentious matter in west austin i have
the worst frequency rail line in the
country with a three hourly rail
frequency that many don't often
recognize
inter-regional rail connectivity is also
very poor and it's one another one of
the reasons why i'm delighted that we
will have a transport bill that will
reform the railways it will bring lots
of opportunity particularly taking full
advantage of regional connectivity and
meaning that where we see today maybe
some of the franchise boundaries
precluding sensible cross-regional
connectivity measures
we have the opportunity to
to fully review
mr deputy speaker west dorset is a very
agricultural uh area as well agriculture
has an enormous part to the local
economy it's also one of the reasons as
a farmer's son that i'm delighted to see
that the animal welfare kept animals
bill will be coming back in this
parliamentary session
it contains a lot of important measures
that i would like i would have liked us
to have addressed and dealt with before
but i am pleased it's coming back
animal worrying is a considerable issue
for our sheep farmers in and around west
dorset
the bill will put responsibility on dog
owners to keep their dogs under control
and i'm hoping that as part of that
uh part of that bill's debate we will
also be able to
uh debate in this house the unnecessary
nonstone slaughter of animals uh for
supply chain purposes
mr deputy speaker i am delighted to be
able to support this bill i'm very
pleased that the minister is here to
hear my points and to reiterate the
conversation
we had when he visited west dorset and i
commend the speech to the house
thank you mr deputy speaker unlike the
honourable member for bali and sven this
is also my first queen's speech debate
for a queen speech delivered during a
cost of living crisis this year's
address was regrettably notable for its
lack of urgency or solutions inflation
as we've all been hearing about is now
at nine percent the highest in over 40
years and people are struggling to
manage
imagine how they can possibly make ends
meet let alone make it the notion that
people can solve the crisis by taking
cookery classes or working longer hours
is as tone-deaf as it is offensive
the government talks a lot about
leveling up but in my constituency we
see vital local services disappearing
before our eyes i could talk about the
loss of multiple bank branches locally
or about protracted postal delays due to
ofcom's failure to hold royal mail to
its universal service requirements but
as i only have a short amount of time i
will focus my remarks on questions that
cannot afford to be ignored with their
commitment to making streets safer i had
hoped that the government would pay some
attention to local policing they talk a
good game about their commitment to
recruit extra police officers yet in our
local force in thames valley police we
were promised an additional 609 officers
by the end of may 2023
instead they were down 29 officers in
2021 this is why i was particularly
disappointed
to hear that rather than focusing on
provision to improve local policing the
home office planned to spend this
parliamentary session attempting to
force through draconian legislation that
was so recently rejected from the police
crime sentencing in courtsville
turning to future development my
constituents made no secret of their
distaste for the government's previous
planning white paper as such i am glad
that the government appear to have heard
the voices of the people of cheshire and
amisham and dropped those proposals
having been made to think again the
government are now looking to give
communities more say over developments
in their area i only hope that the
results live up to the billing
i'm pleased to see that there will be
more emphasis on environmental
considerations within this legislation
without a doubt the planning system
plays a big part in protecting our
natural environment however i am
disappointed at the lack of standalone
environmental legislation in the uk some
areas of outstanding natural beauty are
in decline and yet we're continuing to
destroy unique and precious habitats
ancient woodlands and the globally
scarce chalk streams in my constituency
alone if we're to halt this decline and
protect our environment for future
generations we need
specific protections to do so
i have previously suggested a special
designation and enhanced protection for
chalk streams and i would once again
urge the government to consider this
finally turning to transport the
government have committed to improve
reliability for passengers but i'm sure
fellow buckinghamshire members will
share my disappointment that our local
council received no funding for best
service improvement plans and i asked
the government what their plan is to
improve transport connectivity in
regions like ours which were overlooked
the neglect of cheshire and amishams
transport services is particularly
ironic given that our community is
obliged to watch as ever increasing
amounts of money is poured into the hs2
project which brings nothing to our area
than pollution congestion and
destruction the government's blinkered
approach means they're simply planning
on ahead despite spiraling costs
and an environmental impact far greater
than estimated i urge this government
before the high-speed rail crew to
manchester bill is brought before this
place
please
pause assess the damage already done and
undertake a fresh cost benefit benefit
analysis of the project which takes into
consideration the many changes that have
occurred since honourable members
regrettably consented to it
well within six minutes
hold on
duncan baker
thank you mr deputy speaker
i rise to support the uh queen's speech
its 38 bills and its broad legislative
agenda
i thought my opening paragraph my speech
wouldn't be too disagreeable but after
listening to some of the comments this
afternoon
i still firmly believe that efficiently
managing our economy and stimulating
growth
was absolutely a key priority that this
government should be helping us through
and in what will undoubtedly be one of
the most challenging scenarios for the
last 75 years
i think we're all in absolutely no doubt
about the challenges ahead but rather
than
dwell on those challenges
what we need to be doing when we debate
achieving economic growth is talking
about confidence
confidence in our economy and confidence
in our businesses because that is what
they absolutely need and as constituency
mps we have a fundamental duty i feel to
be talking about confidence in our own
representative communities
confidence
to invest
confidence
to recruit
into a market where opportunities are
plentiful we've heard many times this
afternoon that we have more jobs than
we've ever had
before for people we've had the lowest
unemployment since the 1970s
and we have to have the confidence that
people can go out there and businesses
can match the skills that they are
looking for then we will drive
the growth agenda that we need
and this is what is expected and is
indeed happening in my rural
constituency of north norfolk
now rather like buses who sit here for
nearly five hours mr deputy speaker and
nobody talks about the rural economy
until the honourable member for west
dorset comes along
not that i would ever
marry him with a bus
but when we stimulate local growth we
foster and we support thriving
communities
this doesn't just apply to towns and
cities but it also applies to rural
areas as well
and north norfolk is just one of those
areas set to benefit what better place
can you think of than swathes of
glorious rolling countryside sprinkled
with picturesque towns and villages
businesses are making a significant
contribution to both local and national
economic growth and the east mr deputy
speaker is a net contributor to the
economy and the chancellor and the
treasury and we should not forget that
we should also recognize that the
pandemic has taught us many things
remote working has changed everything
and places like my beautiful
constituency have never before provided
a work-life balance that the pandemic
has opened our eyes to
it's estimated that across the country
rural businesses currently make up for
28
of england's firms and they contribute
at least 19 percent of gross value added
to the english economy rural areas
have more business startups ahead of
population than many urban areas and the
most and have enormous amounts of
manufacturing businesses in these types
of areas those businesses can be small
medium and large but all of them
all of them contribute immensely to the
surrounding area and the national
economy
now whenever i've talked about leveling
up i've said that we must not forget our
rural areas
and mr deputy speaker i want to show
that there is confidence in the future
and so does a serial entrepreneur called
william sachi
who is the real leader here and i notice
that the honourable member for milton
keynes north has disappeared but i
should it's very interesting that that
twice this has been brought up in the
space of the last half an hour
but this gentleman is a tech
entrepreneur who is relocating his
headquarters of his robotics company
academy of robotics to a former military
base in my constituency in quite
literally the middle of nowhere
he's doing so
and placing
therefore in my county the vanguard of
driverless vehicle technology and
development
many have already described this company
as the closest thing we have to tesla in
the uk
if there wasn't ever a better way of
demonstrating that we are able to
achieve economic growth through the
suite of bills we have here and the
businesses opening in my constituency
then i really don't know how i better to
show that the benefits that this
business which has already been valued
at 100 million dollars
will bring
high-skilled jobs
it will go to show real real talent
coming into my constituency
and i hope that it goes some way towards
just showing how integral our rural
economy areas are they are quite often
the economic drivers
of growth and as we move out of the
pandemic it's absolutely vital that we
recognize this
and that we
realize
the inherent potential of businesses in
the rural economy and that there is no
barriers anymore to where you can start
a business and enable it to thrive
just like leveling up
economic growth
is not the president of metropolitan
areas anymore that the whole country
and i know that the government will
deliver on this thank you martian docude
thank you mr deputy speaker something
liberating about nearly coming at the
end of the debate knowing that you don't
have much time actually to get your
points across you tend to get right to
it so well
um i want to talk not only about
economic growth which we all understand
the importance of but also the
sustainability of that growth and the
type of economy that it seeks to create
similar i think to what the honourable
member for norwich south was talking
about earlier on in the debate
cost of living is the order of the day
as it should be mr deputy speaker but
for all the talk of economic shocks and
external factors we cannot avoid
so many of the largest price rises have
come in areas where government on these
islands has decided it no longer has a
role to play abdicating its national
responsibility i'm thinking particularly
about energy in terms of storage and
transportation now i see this as my
attention has drawn to the news that
russia had decided to stop energy
exports to finland the day after they
announced their intention to join nato a
decision that was met with a shrug by
the finns who have been planning for
such an eventuality and it avoided the
russian energy trap so many other
european states has slept walked into
now that's because resilience
is built into finnish society
their economy is as much it plays a part
in the role the total defense of the
homeland as the military does and that
is key to avoiding the temptation to
fall back on the easy gains of what some
call balance sheet capitalism now if the
house would indulge me i will quote a
paragraph from the introduction to brett
christopher's excellent overview of the
modern uk economy rent here capitalism
that i think nicely encapsulates the
quandary this place will find trying to
legislate here for inclusive and
sustained growth a form of capitalism
geared principally to doing pays heat to
the balance sheet only to the extent
that assets facilitate and liabilities
mitigate profitable making or providing
or whatever else a business does for a
form of capitalism structured by
contrast around having rentier
capitalism in other words a mode of
economic organization in which success
is based principally on what you control
not on what you do the balance sheet is
the be all and end all
in this political state as successive
governments blue and red have sought to
keep the city of london on site
unthinking deregulation has been the
order of the day and the rent here
capitalist system has been created mr
deputy speaker now
this may have kept stakeholders happy
but i'm not sure as we stare down the
barrel of massive utility prices that
are cons that our constituents always
have been including mine in western
martinshop a government which is able to
own and maintain the fundamental pieces
of infrastructure that allow
entrepreneurs and to peripherally and
thrive is the one which is able to keep
an eye on the horizon to ensure that our
fundamental national interests are
upheld and that the temptation to put
shareholder interests ahead of citizen
interests is avoided now my contribution
to this has been a published
paper published with stuart evers by the
progressive policy research group last
year regarding the ownership and
regulation of telecoms infrastructure
and as we get our head around the
challenges i think been previously
mentioned and opportunities presented us
by the new digital economy it is
imperative mr deputy speaker that the
keystone industries of this economy are
kept principally in public hands not
only because extracting
private rents from them is unfair
because it also allows us to get back to
focusing on an economy that actually
does things now it will surprise no one
mr deputy speaker in the house if i say
that i cannot see a way which this
political state is able to extract
itself from under the dead hand of the
uk's rent-a-year economy and so i draw
the conclusion that so many of my fellow
scots increasingly do that is only
through independence that scotland can
create an economy that is fairer for all
of us where growth is sustainable and
where the foundations are resilient
enough to face the economic headwinds
which we now are heading into i can only
hope mr deputy speaker that the
government opposite allows us to make
that decision for ourselves
if you and to here ali will be the last
backbencher to speak before the wind-ups
and so any member that has participated
in this debate now should make their way
back to the chamber for the wind-ups to
hear ali
thank you mr deputy speaker
this queen's speech clearly comes from a
beleaguered government that has run out
of ideas and that has lost the ability
to show leadership in a time of acute
crisis
as several of my colleagues have already
made abundantly clear the lack of
measures to address the cost of living
is an indictment of this government and
demonstrates the complete disregard
for everybody struggling to pay
struggling and working in the uk
inflation continues to rise and the bank
of england is warning of an imminent
recession
with the wages stagnant my constituents
in birmingham hall green
consumers across the country are cutting
back on spending as the cost of
essentials like energy and food
skyrocket
whilst energy companies amass record
profits
small and medium businesses in my
constituency
in
high streets and on local centres
struggle with rising costs and less
income
the cost of living crisis threatens to
become a vicious cycle
where working people struggle to make
ends meet
small and medium businesses struggle to
stay afloat and people's jobs are put at
risk rather than leveling up this crisis
threatens a downward spiral
bereft of ideas
the government hasn't even done what it
usually does and still labor policies
the government has ignored our calls for
a windfall tax on oil and gas companies
as was demonstrated
in last night's vote vital
that
it would help raise significant revenues
to assist those struggling to pay for
their energy bills
nothing has been said about the issue of
low pay and stagnant wages nothing on
how rising interest rates will increase
mortgage costs and rents nothing on the
scourge of insecure work and fire and
re-hire and nothing on child poverty and
staff retention crisis
in our hard-hit primary and secondary
schools
the new brexit freedom
bills threatens to further undermine
parliamentary scrutiny of important
legislation yet another attempt by this
government to avoid accountability
where positive measures have been
announced such as ending no fault
evictions for renters the government
accompanies this with the cronian
nonsense like criminalizing the homeless
for rough sleeping
and the missed opportunities do not end
there
new proposals for street votes on
extensions and conservatives provide a
compelling medal a model for local
democracy once sadly wasted on
relatively
minor matters the government has been
made well aware of the problems around
exempt accommodation
in my city of birmingham and in my
constituency of birmingham hall green
where local people are demanding a voice
in decision making about whether
the so-called exempt accommodation is
established by government departments in
their neighborhoods i think this would
be far more suitable issue
around which to develop street votes and
local democracy rather than whether
someone wants a conservatory or an
extension on their street or not
in conclusion i think
the real achievement of this queen's
speech was to use so many words to say
so little of substance
the people of this country were looking
to this government to show courage and
leadership in a time of great need
instead all they got was more missed
opportunities and hot air
thank you very much
windups jonathan reynolds
thank you mr deputy speaker it is a real
privilege to be able to close the final
debate of the queen's speech tonight
after over 30 contributions from
colleagues on all sides and i want to
start with a candid admission of
jealousy
because every time i see a government
present a queen speech i'm envious of
the right that they have
to lay out not just one bill not just
one measure but a full a comprehensive
program a chance to address the many
issues our country faces i mean what an
opportunity that is
and for this government with its large
majority now in the delivery stage of
this parliament what a moment this
should be after 12 years in power
this speech should have been the
crowning glory of everything this
government is about
but can any reasonable person say
the queen's speech matched that moment
that it sees the opportunities of the
future
in a list of 38 bills we should all be
able to find one or two things that we
like
but can we say this lives up to the
fundamental challenges being faced in
homes across this country
like many of the speakers today
i moved to ask
is this really it
we called this debate to outline a
vision of the future but the government
have quite literally sent a vision of
the past
the test for the queen's speech was
whether it could deliver both the
short-term relief
and a long-term plan for growth that
this country needs
but mr deputy speaker it has surely
failed on both counts
now many colleagues raised in their
speeches today the news that inflation
has hit a 40-year high rising to 9
it's the highest one-year increase in
consumer prices since records began
people are grappling with impossible
decisions and they're rightly looking to
this place for action
the average energy bill has gone up by
more than a thousand pounds this year
the food shop's gone up by five percent
and the bank of england have warned of
further apocalyptic food price rises
putting petrol in the cars jumped up 20
pounds every time
and since january
2 million people in our country have
gone a whole day without eating because
they simply cannot afford to do so
now these aren't just statistics and
headlines
they're real people they're our friends
they're our neighbors there are
constituents
and we can do something about it
because these are all symptoms of a much
deeper problem
at the heart of the difficulty we're
facing is the fact that our economy has
not grown as it should have done since
the conservatives came to power now this
isn't a contested argument it's a fact
economic growth under the conservatives
has been slower than the historic
average and it's been slower than it was
under the last labour government
and what sadly this queen's speech
showed is that this government cannot or
will not take the action needed to
rectify that
in contrast our position is our economy
can and it must do better
we believe the uk needs greater
investment in net zero we believe we
need a real reform agenda when it comes
to things like business rates
we believe we need a modern industrial
strategy that provides a route for every
business and worker in this country to
fulfill their true potential
and that ambition that hunger for change
shown through the contributions of my
honourable friends in this debate
i think about my honourable friend for
leed central when he talked about the
urgent need to overcome the problems uk
businesses are having exporting into the
single market all my honourable friends
for nottingham eastern slough when they
talked of job security being essential
to well-being and yet the employment
bill is nowhere to be seen
my friend forever oven who talked of the
new opportunities available to
manufacturing and the need for private
investment in the uk to increase to
capitalize on those or my friend from
batley and spend who called for
transformational bold thinking and gave
examples from her own constituency about
what the contemporary situation meant
my honourable friend for the ronda and
perhaps the phrase of the debate called
this more of a gracious
intervention than a gracious speech
and he is surely right
even on the government side the
frustrations were actually evident the
member for rashford raised legitimate
points about the media bill and the
creative industries the member for rugby
asked why the audit reform bill is just
in draft form and it's supposed to be a
priority
the member for thirst and moulton
again admirably raised points about
small business lending
which is right to do so
and lots of government members members
for gainsborough for epsom for south
cambridge
pointed out that taxes on working people
are too high and they are very high
under this government
listening to the whole debate today it
just seemed to me
that having had the policy to cut
corporation tax which the government has
now abandoned having tried an embryonic
industrial strategy which has now been
abandoned having tried austerity which
is originally a growth policy not just a
necessity and has since been recognized
to have gone too far have we had the
super deduction which has been undergone
there just really are no big ideas left
on the conservative side at a time when
we really need them
and mr deputy speaker the first line of
this queen's speech could and should
have been that we will introduce an
emergency budget to offer relief to
families and firms struggling with the
cost of living crisis
instead
we have the prime minister saying he's
neither in favor or against the windfall
tax the business secretary saying he is
ruling it out but everything is still on
the table
the prime minister telling us to expect
action on the cost of living soon
and the treasury telling us to expect
action on the cost of living never
the truth is families and households
across this country they don't need
lessons in budgeting or cookery classes
they need help dealing with challenges
that are too big for individuals to have
to deal with alone
on this side of the house
all we're asking for is action that is
commensurate with the scale of the
challenge
and that
is an emergency budget
with a one-off
windfall tax on oil and gas profits to
cut household bills by up to 600 pounds
and a tax cut for small businesses
saving pubs and shops up to 5 000 pounds
this year
and a contingency fund for energy
intensive industries to be able to stay
competitive so we could keep for
instance fertilizer factories that are
currently closed open meaning we don't
see further food price inflation into
next year because of an action now
these are real proposals for real action
now
because if we wait until october
business conference continues to fall
and inflation continues to rise
already hard decisions will become even
harder
and what frustrates me
is despite all of this
we are a country with such incredible
potential
we have an amazing cutting-edge business
sector and industries up and down this
country and it's a privilege as a shadow
business secretary to be able to go and
see those firms for myself
in the last few months i've had the
opportunity to see electric cars being
manufactured in sunderland green
hydrogen in sheffield i was with a new
generation of entrepreneurs at leeds
business school last week and they were
buzzing with ideas and innovations that
would boost our economy
britain is a great country to work and
do business in
so why then should we accept projections
of weak growth of poor productivity and
ever higher taxes as a result
we know how good britain can be but over
the last 12 years the conservatives have
failed to capture that potential and the
future projections are no better
in the debate several concerned from
peace and it's actually
international forces beyond their
control it's global commodity prices of
the conflict in ukraine that are to
blame
but that claim just doesn't stand up to
scrutiny
conservatives have been in power for 12
years
law growth had taken hold long before
the contemporary international events
were concerned about came into play
and that's why the government have had
to raise taxes on working people to
historic levels
and the imf says the only country that
will grow slower rate than us in 2023 in
the g20 is russia
yet
all that all the government have to
offer is more of the same
now we're also clear that a plan for
economic growth must offer good jobs
high skill high wage secured jobs across
the country
jobs you can raise your family on
a number of honourable members have
rightly raised the absence of the
employment bill in the queen's speech
something that was a promise in 2019 in
the general election and has since been
promised 20 times
additionally
what is it about flexible working rights
banning fire and rehire and sorting out
sick pay that the government is so
afraid of i still haven't heard from
anybody an explanation as to why it
wasn't included
the treatment of people
in the piano furry scandal wasn't just a
scandal it was immoral
and mr deputy speaker as a pro business
pro worker party we stand proud to say
better employment rights are a key part
of our economic plan for britain
this country
is crying out for a serious plan to
break this cycle of low growth low
productivity and high taxes
and we've got that plan
an industrial strategy built on a
partnership between employers and
workers
catalytic public investment 28 billion
pounds a year every year to build the
industries and jobs of the future
reforming business taxation to encourage
long-term and sustainable growth
increased investment in research and
development buying making and selling
more in the uk
this is the action needed to grow our
economy to drive up living standards and
fund the public services this country so
desperately needs
mr deputy speaker
the queen's speech just doesn't meet
that moment
we have to ask
if a government has so little to offer
in the face of these tumultuous events
what really is the point in this
government
away from all the bluster and the
boosterism
the fact is this government has wasted
the mandate it received and frankly the
british people will not forgive them for
it
leadership vision optimism that is what
is required as i said at the beginning
the opportunity to present a queen's
speech is an immense privilege
and the circumstances we live in made
this queen's speech a particular
responsibility
it required nothing less than short-term
relief and hope for the future but the
government have been unable to provide
either
and it's clear
this country won't get the queen speech
it really deserves until later have the
chance to write it
jacob reese
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you mr deputy speaker
it is a pleasure for me to close this
debate on behalf of her majesty's
government and i thank honourable and
right honourable members on all sides
who have contributed to it
they made many important points
quite rightly holding the government to
account in the best traditions of this
house this has made for an excellent
debate to follow her majesty's gracious
speech
that speech set out the government's
plans to grow our economy ease the cost
of living and drive our leveling up
agenda
my right honourable friend the chief
secretary of the treasury set out
earlier the ambitious plans for
accelerating economic growth in this
country
and i echo my writing friends comments
that there are reasons to be optimistic
last year
the united kingdom was the fastest
growing economy in the g7
unemployment has fallen back to 3.7
percent below pre-pandemic levels i
think mr speaker before even you were
born the last time assuming you weren't
born in 1974
um the lowest in almost 50 years
however mr deputy speaker as in 1974
inflation is once more on the prowl it
is a global issue
because of wars and rumors of wars as
well of course as covid pandemic
energy prices have risen globally
other supply cha side chains are
disrupted and china's biggest cities are
in lockdown
container shipping is in the wrong place
in parts of the world
the monetary policy prescripts that were
necessary to deal with the global
financial crisis
and the pandemic risk of economic
inactivity have also taken their toll
these present challenges to the
government
not just in this country
but to governments across the world
fortunately
this government her majesty's government
has plans to deal with this
the areas under my direct responsibility
are some crucial essential
fundamental supply-side reforms
in the brexit freedom bill and the
procurement bill
these two bills along with a host of
others in the queen speech
covering data reform gene editing future
transport technology financial services
reform and more provide exactly the sort
of meaningful policy
supply side reforms the members opposite
always oppose because their answer is
always more regulation and more
interference but these are the things
that will open up the bottlenecks in our
economy
and provide the british people with the
plenty and the prosperity that they
deserve
once again conservatives are the ones
who are willing to take proper
long-term well thought through policy
decisions
to the benefit of the british people
but before i move into more detail on
the bills
i do want to refer to some of the
comments made
during the course of today's excellent
debate
and what a pleasure to start with the
honorable lady the member for leeds west
and i think that her speech was a
beautifully crafted an elegant audition
for the leadership of the labour party
that she has set out her stall and
having always been thought of as being
quite moderate economist for the bank of
england i believe at one point
now she is red in truth and claw the
prescripts of socialism came spewing
forth higher tax higher regulation more
spending the fuel for the inflationary
fire was to be piled up as if she was
looking for a veritable bonfire and the
honourable lady was only to be outdone
by the honourable member of the
honorable lady for nottingham east who
if the honorable lady
was solomon the other honourable lady
was rahab boham if it were whips from
the honourable lady the shadow
chancellor was scorpions from the
honourable lady the member for
nottingham east the scorpions of
socialism that have lashed this country
before and we will not be stung by their
like again
but i must move on
to the very distinguished honorable lady
of the member for glasgow central
because there is a phrase that comes to
mind
because the honourable lady was looking
around for something with which to
attack this government extraordinary
thing for her to do
and so she found the one thing which was
of course the obsession of the scottish
national party
who want to be free from the united
kingdom only to be
enthralled to the yoke of brussels
so she found a few pounds that used to
come from brussels
but doesn't come from the united kingdom
but she forgot the 41 billion pounds
that will go from the uk taxpayer to
scotland each year for the next three
years the 170 million pounds of the
leveling up fund for eight scottish
projects the 52 million pound to support
the establishment of two green free
ports 42 million pounds for scottish
fisheries and 1.9 billion pounds for
farmers and land managers
1.5 billion pounds mr deputy speaker for
12 city growth deals
so the honorable lady sat there
elegantly straining at a gnat after
camel after camel had been greedily
swallowed by the scottish government
previously
so now
let me turn to the
inspired and helpful interventions that
we had from this side of the house
i'm not saying mr deputy speaker that
there is a monopoly of wisdom on this
side of the house although it does
sometimes look that way
but we started with my right honourable
friend of the member for ashford who
pointed out that productivity has been a
challenge for this economy now for some
time and he is absolutely right and that
is why supply side reforms are so
important
my rhino friend the member for epps
renewal mentioned shale gas
and i recalled an occasion where a much
more distinguished speaker at this
dispatch box decided that the argument
coming from the back bench was so strong
that he could not rise to answer it and
remain within the confines of collective
agreement my more distinguished
predecessor wasn't it happens robert
peale and the argument was won over uh
free trade but though i was not entirely
won over by my right-hand friends
argument
nonetheless i'm glad that her majesty's
government is reviewing the position on
shale to ensure that we do maximize
safely the resources that lie under the
feet of the people of this nation
oh yes of course i'll give way to
honourable gentlemen
i'm very grateful um several um
members on this side and on the other
side spoke in favor of a windfall tax on
windfall profits today he is as i
understand it wholeheartedly opposed to
this socialism so if the government and
when the government introduces it will
he resign
[Music]
mr speaker
unfortunately as so often the honourable
gentleman not been paying proper
attention to the day's debate
if he had he might have heard an
authority greater than i am answering
half a dozen questions on this very
issue from the leader of the opposition
slightly earlier the authority in her
majesty's government is obviously the
prime minister of whom i am a humble
servant so let me come to my honourable
friend the member for harriet north
essex who raised the issue about supply
chains and the disruption in supply
chains this is a fundamental problem and
until supply chains are restored
inflation is likely to be difficult but
the contributions ranged widely from my
honourable friend the member for west
worcester rugby bolton who i was pleased
to visit last week and had the pleasure
of going to elk's biscuit factory and if
you want a better biscuit buy elks
biscuits they're absolutely delicious i
helped i won't be good at helping but i
did nonetheless help and they sent me
home with a packet of bourbon creams
which have never been devoured faster
than they were by my children so may i
thank you for having me uh on on that
visit my own befriend the member for
southwest bedfordshire for ryegate for
gainsborough my right old friend who
insisted that we stick
to the title how do we get economic
growth and he's absolutely my rhino
friend is almost always absolutely right
but on this occasion he's particularly
absolutely right we want to stick to the
issue uh of economic growth uh my
honourable friend the member for this
good moulton
and my own friend the member for harvard
and stalford who
um
i don't know whether i'm delighted or
i'm somewhat miffed because she made in
one short speech a point that i'm trying
to be may tried to make for about 20
years and she made it epithelia and
better
and used a cricketing metaphor than i've
ever achieved
and that is the government is the
groundsman
the most the government can do is
prepare the pitch for the bowlers and
the batsmen to come on and they are the
businesses across the country who
provide the economic activity we are not
the players in the game we are
the groundsman
and that was her point and as i say it's
a point i've been trying to make for a
long time and i'm going to steal her um
pithy aphorism shamelessly and i hope i
have her position permission to do so my
own friend the member for both silva
south cambridgeshire who said that
growth is everything agreeing with our
right home friend the member for
gainsborough my only friend the member
for milton keynes north um i think he
needs to contact the um the boundary
commission because during his speech he
decided to rename his constituency the
silicon valley of europe now i think for
that to be officially approved it will
have to go through the proper processes
but it seems to me a jolly good idea
that we should have the silicon valley
of europe in milton keynes uh with
robots going around saying how modern
and technologically sophisticated they
are
um i was also uh delighted the
contribution my honourable friend for
west dorset whose constituency i visited
very recently
um and where he generously provided me
with the most excellent cake you all
think honourable members and right on
members will think wherever i go i am
providing with confections of the most
delicious kind but this is not
compulsory i would happily visit without
the cake to visit poundbury and palm
breeze the most amazing success of
planning to provide things that people
want it is beautiful it is elegant and
um it achieves a density that other
places do not achieve and i also listen
to my honourable friend the member for
north norfolk with pleasure
now on the other side
how could i refuse to so elegantly
phrased a request
i'm listening to what is a very amusing
after dinner speech but would he agree
that the serious issue here is that if
on trend growth from the labor
government we continued on that people
would have an extra 11 000
pounds to work with would you agree that
the tax rate is the highest rate since
world war ii the inflation rate's the
highest rate for 40 years and and
there's 2.6 million people going to food
banks this is a complete
catastrophe and he's just making a big
machine joke which shows he shouldn't be
joking
mr deputy speaker
the honorable gentleman must think there
has been a collective outbreak of
amnesia not just in this house but
across the nation he seems to forget
that when the coalition came to office
in 2010
the country was bankrupt
and it had been bankrupted because of
our spend now find the money later
approach taken by the socialists and was
it not margaret thatcher who so rightly
said that ultimately you run out of
other people's money they had run out of
other people's money that is why growth
has been lower because of the
utter irresponsibility of the socialists
prior to 2010 and the then chief
secretary of the treasury left a little
billy do did he not saying i'm sorry to
tell you there is no more money left and
we have a cat call saying it was 12
years yes it's more than 12 years but we
won't let them forget because socialism
always leads to economic failure every
socialist government has ever been has
led to economic failure devaluation high
taxes low economic growth and the
conservatives come in
and the conservatives come in and clear
things up but i was referring to of
course i could wait
very grateful to my right honourable
friend just before he leaves the
planning point i haven't had the
pleasure of visiting canberry but i have
visited prince of wales other
development near newquay at nance levin
where there is a wonderful new large
doctor's surgery being built
many of us have a serious issue with
large new developments where we haven't
quite got the same british prowess at
getting general practice capacity in as
we have other areas when he's next round
the cabinet table would he forcefully
represent that point which i think is of
concern to many of us across all sides
of the house
my honourable friend is is so wise and i
think this is part of the reason why
palm beach also has been a success
because it provides the basic service
and also a primary school and that is
part of the requirement
of planning so i do agree very much with
my my honourable friend um i just want
to continue replying to some of the
points and because i was delighted
by the writer and gentleman the member
for leeds central's contribution which
is not words i thought i would use nor
words he probably thought i would
utter because i always thought he was
the high priest of romain and he
delivered a speech most of which i could
have delivered myself about the
intransigence
intransigence and the stick in the
muddiness of the european union and i'm
glad to say
that in the uk we're being much more
flexible
we are recognizing that the eu hasn't
suddenly become dangerous
we may not like the eu we may not think
it's the best construct we may not want
to belong to it but we don't think
they've suddenly become rabid
and that is why i was delighted to be
able to announce in april the remaining
import controls on eu goods will no
longer be introduced each year and this
isn't a delay
this is a change in policy because we
recognize that goods produced in other
parts of the world not just the eu can
be produced safely and therefore it
makes sense to have unilateral
recognition if others won't give us
mutual recognition and what we are
looking to do between now and the end of
2023 is see how far we can extend that
with other friendly nations that have
high standards and this cuts costs for
consumers and the honourable right on
the gentleman probably has better
relations with um highfalutin eu figures
than i do and he may be better placed
than i am to persuade them that
reciprocation would be more in their
interest than it is particularly uh in
ours so i'm great of course i'll give
way
to minister giving me on that point in
terms of open trade could you make some
clarification about friendly nations
would that include india shipping cheap
indian whiskey to the united kingdom
well it will have to be a risk-based
assessment if the honorable gentleman
can say that it's dangerous or it's
poisonous or it's breaking a trademark
do we really have a scotsman in the
house mr speaker who doesn't like his
whiskey to be cheap does he want to pay
higher prices for whiskey is he calling
is he calling is he calling for the good
people of scotland this is news mr
deputy speaker a news flash i hope pa is
reporting it carefully along with ansar
the snp want higher prices for whiskey
higher prices for your evening tipple mr
deputy speaker well i look forward to
that being a good and successful slogan
at the next general election vote smp
for higher whiskey prices
is i
oh how can i refuse the honourable
gentleman
indeed he cannot um can i ask the the
minister on the issue of whiskey in
india if you can update the house on
progress towards reducing the unit of
150 tariffs on scotch whiskey which
impacts approximately 400 jobs in my
constituency
mr speaker what i would say is that the
government is a free trade in government
and is why we are negotiating around the
world to improve access to other markets
it's very important part
of what her majesty's government uh is
doing um i wanted to mention briefly one
of the other things that came up in the
debate which was on the issue of public
sector fraud and on some of the
um all right i will give way another
time the minister giving way before he
moves on on the issue of trade we take
the opportunity tonight to welcome from
the dispatch box the deal that was cut
the first overseas deal that was cut
between northern ireland and australia
right boss and my constituency in
walgreen and australia that have now put
on are going to put hydrogen buses on
the streets of australia this has come
out directly as a result of our new
ability to cut free trade dates
well i must confess mr deputy speaker
that is particularly good news and
welcome that northern ireland with the
difficulties over the protocol is
actually seeing genuine benefit from our
free trade agreements
um i want to make a point on fraud which
came up during the course of the debate
because two years ago it was a
fundamental importance to get money out
to businesses quickly and that was the
right thing to do and it was supported
across the house
it is now right to follow up to make
sure that all that money was used
honestly and if people didn't use it
honestly that they are subject to proper
processes so 750 million pounds of
taxpayers money is being committed to
following up in fraud we are setting up
a public sector fraud agency and we are
working with the banks themselves who
own the loans to ensure that bounce-back
loans are repaid properly and honestly
but it was right to get the money out
quickly two years ago and dare i say mr
deputy speaker everybody wanted to do it
of course i'll give away those gentlemen
i i do thank the former leader of the
house on that particular point does he
think that it was right for
more than four billion pounds to already
have been written off
in terms of unrecoverable
fraud and does he also think that the
minister who resigned at the
at that point in time on a matter of
principle was he also wrong to resign
but i'd correct the honourable gentleman
the money hasn't been written off and
actually my noble friend lord agnew has
been in touch with me and i've spoken to
him and have been seeking his advice on
how to ensure that our anti-fraud
efforts are affect as effective as
possible and i think he highlighted the
issue very effectively but may i also
thank the honorable gentleman for his um
contribution earlier along with the
honourable lady the member for baltimore
southeast and the honourable lady member
for paisley and ren fuchsia south
because the three of them in my humble
opinion
are three of the most sensible and
civilized members of the opposition but
i think they decided i think they
decided that the queen's speech was an
occasion for them as it is for the
heralds that they put on their tabards
and their fine show
to really have a theatrical display
rather than to say something that they
normally say in well-rounded and
moderated tones all three of them went
to the wildest fantasies of excessive
criticism of the government i i've
already given away once um and it was
splendid but it wasn't really what the
debate uh was was about and i admire the
heralds as well i think they are a great
addition to the state opening and i hope
that the three of them will make this a
traditional part of queen's speeches in
future to be able to over egg the
pudding when it comes in front of them
but mr deputy speaker
i have a feeling you and many others
assembling now for the vote may be glad
to hear that i'm coming to my yeah
it is so easy to win cheap popularity
[Applause]
the government has seen this prospects
brexit world as an historic chance to
seize the opportunity for innovation and
regulatory reform now that we are free
of brussels dictators
our future is one of innovation and
enterprise spurred by competition
following the end of the transition
period the uk's new trading relationship
with the eu
many businesses have prepared and
adapted to the new environment
this has been a period of change and
it's made all the more extraordinary by
tackling a global pandemic at the same
time
the cost of business regulation is too
high
too much eu regulation has been written
at the expense of consumers and
entrepreneurs with new ideas
many of its regulations like solvency ii
or the gdpr rules benefit big incumbents
rather than small competitors and
deprive consumers including members of
this house of new technologies or better
products and services
our future is in building on our
competitive advantage as a knowledge
economy our success will be based on the
quality of ideas in working hard to turn
those ideas into new industries and
reforming and enhancing our old ones and
exporting those ideas
we have the opportunity now we're
outside the eu to think boldly to
conceive and implement rules that put
the uk first
and get rid of things the nonsense the
folder all the port services directive
and such like that do not help or
benefit
us we are going to have a brexit freedom
bill that will make it easier to get rid
of bad eu law we'll be deregulatory in
principle we'll remove the supremacy of
eu law and will ensure that our statute
book is a statute book of scottish law
and english and welsh law and indeed
northern irish law rather than one of eu
law and i think that even the leader of
the scottish national party in
westminster is looking chirpy at the
thought of having this degree of control
um we are going to have a procurement
bill that is going to make life easier
for small businesses it was said in this
debate that small and medium-sized empty
i think it was the member for moulton
and thirsk who said this small and
medium-sized enterprises are the
lifeblood
of our economic activity they are the
ones that create the jobs they are the
ones that defeat the monopolists they
are the ones that help bring down prices
but mr deputy speaker ultimately there
is a choice there is a clear choice on
this queen speech it is a choice brought
in to sharper relief by the inflation
that we currently face and it is a
choice faced by previous generations in
this house and in this country do we
wish to go down
the false path of socialism do we want
to follow the honorable lady with higher
taxes higher regulation and wasteful
spending or do we want freedom and
liberty and enterprise i commend freedom
liberty and enterprise mr deputy speaker
[Applause]
amendment w in the name of the leader of
the opposition has already been moved so
i all i need to do now is put the
question and the question is that the
amendment be made as many of that
opinion say aye country no
vision no the lobby
the question is that the amendment be
made does many other opinions say aye
aye country no
till us for the iceland's twist and
jessica morden tell us for the news
michael tomlinson and gareth johnson
uh
me
okay
sorry
[Music]
so
so
so
so
[Music]
foreign
oh
so
so
okay
so
so
order
order
the eyes to the right 229
the nose to the left 312.
order
the eyes to the right
229 the nose to the left were 312.
so the nose have it the nose have it
unlocked
[Music]
we now come to
the next amendment which is amendment m
and i call ed davey to move amendment m
formally
the question is that the amendment be
made as many of our friends say aye
of the country now
[Applause]
[Music]
order the question is the amendment be
made as many of that opinion say i
of the country no
tell us for the eyes alistair carmichael
and wendy chamberlain tell us for the
nose michael tomlinson and gareth
johnson
so
so
[Music]
know
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
no
[Music]
[Music]
the eyes to the right 59 the nose to the
left 315
the eyes to the right
59
the nose to the left 315 so the nose
have it
the nose have it
unlocked
i now come to amendment s and i call ian
blackford to move amendment s formally
formally
the question is the amendment being made
is made underneath say i
of the country no no
division
clear the lobbies eight minutes
order
the question is the amendment be made
does another opinion say aye aye
tell us for the eyes
fellows and richard thompson tell us for
the knows michael tomlinson and gareth
johnson
[Music]
so
so
so
lockers
so
so
so
order
order
the eyes to the right 59 the nose to the
left 313.
thank you
the eyes to the right 59 the nose to the
left 300 313
so the nose havoc the nose have it
unlock
we now come to the substantive question
and the question is
that a humble address be presented to
her majesty
as on the order paper as many of
are of that opinion say aye
of the country now
[Applause]
division clear the lobby
ah the question is that an humble
address be presented to her majesty as
on the order paper as many of that
opinions say i
of the country now
tell us for the eyes gareth johnson and
michael tomlinson tell us for the nose
jessica morden and liz twist
so
[Music]
so
so
see me
it
so
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you